this is Jocko podcast number 351 with me
Jocko willink
Master Sergeant Andrew Christian
marcusana was born in Phoenix Arizona on
October 22nd 1986 he graduated from San
Luis Obispo High School in that in 2004
joined the army in 2005
as an infantryman
Master Sergeant marcusano's first
assignment was in Fort Bragg North
Carolina where he served in the second
of the 508th 82nd Airborne Division
Rose through the ranks from Riflemen to
squad leader while at Fort Bragg he
deployed to Afghanistan in 2007 and
2009.
in 2011
he was assigned a Hunter Army Airfield
in Georgia in 2013 Master Sergeant
marcusana was deployed again to
Afghanistan in 2013 he attended Special
Forces assessment and selection at Fort
Bragg North Carolina
and he was selected to attend the Q
course there he graduated in 2015 as a
special forces weapon sergeant
assigned to Second Battalion seventh
Special Forces Group
Master Sergeant marcusano deployed again
to Afghanistan as a senior weapon
Sergeant on Oda
7223 and in 2016
to Colombia
Master Sergeant marcusano schools
included basic Airborne course modern
modern Army combatives level one and two
Ranger indoctrination program small unit
Ranger tactics course Warrior leaders
course
basic non-commissioned officer course
Advanced leaders course Ranger course
seer
Free Fall parachute discourse and the
Special Forces weapons Sergeant
qualifications course
Master Sergeant marcusano's Awards
include the Silver Star the Army
Commendation Medal the Army Achievement
medal valorous unit award army Good
Conduct Medal National Defense service
medal Afghan campaign medal combat
infantryman's badge
Ranger tab Special Forces tab parachute
badge
military Free Fall parachutist badge
master sergeant marcusano had a wife
and three children Riley Andrew and
Madeleine
and his friends that served with him
alongside him
called him the real Captain America
and in early July 2020 he sent some of
those friends a message
he said text me I told you before my
door's open my phone is at hand
we did things that people make movies
about and in some cases writers and
producers wouldn't even try to write our
story
but the rucksack is heavy
and when it gets heavy we help each
other
but you have to reach out
don't let the valley win
so that's
Andrew marcosano
the kind of guy that
we all look up to
kind of guy that's looking out for us
kind of guy that we see is strong and
unflappable
kind of guy that's helping others
and of course couldn't possibly need
and he helped himself
but a few days after sending that
message to his friends and comrades on
July 6 2020.
Andy marcusano
killed himself
which is
a nightmare
and
it's only one of
thousands of these cases and we've
talked about some of them on this
podcast we talked to Sarah Wilkinson
about her husband Chad
who committed suicide after multiple
combat deployments with the SEAL Teams
we talked with Mike Hayes
about a friend of ours named Joe price
another seal
this one who
killed himself in the middle of a
deployment
and the list goes on and on and every
branch and it's not a new problem on
this podcast we discussed
Charles White whittlesley
Medal of Honor recipient World War One
who killed himself after returning home
we discussed the awful suicide of Lewis
polar Jr son of chesty puller
who was wounded in Vietnam and fought
Off the Darkness for 25 years
before finally losing his battle with
the demons
but there are people
that overcome
there are people that find a way
to push through and push on and begin to
truly live again
and there are many ways to get there
and tonight it's an honor to have
Amber and Marcus Capone
with us two people who have
found a path
a path out of the darkness a path toward
the light and they're doing their best
to share it with as many people as they
can Marcus was a seal
for 13 years completed
multiple deployments overseas
and his wife Amber
also here who
stuck with him through all that and much
more and from everything I can tell she
eventually saved him
from himself
Amber Marcus thanks for uh
thanks for coming on I know it's a heavy
topic and I know you all are in the
trenches every day dealing with this and
trying to help people out so thanks for
coming on here
to share your story and and hopefully
guide some other people in the right
direction
um
I guess we just start at the beginning
like uh
I guess start with Marcus your your
childhood where'd you grow up what was
that all about yeah well first thanks
for that introduction that was uh wow I
just wow
yeah uh powerful you know one of one of
my most
um
you know every every single Marine knows
who chesty puller is probably the most
iconic Marine of all time
um if not he's definitely in the top two
or three
and yet no one knows about his son
or I shouldn't say no one very few
people know about his son and well it's
I think it's one of the most tragic
stories
in history about what happened to his
son and
Louis puller Jr coming out of Vietnam so
severely wounded but I mean he like kind
of got it together eventually and wrote
a Pulitzer prize-winning book which is
an incredible book and
it just kind of fell apart at the end
um
and we should that should be you know he
people should know at least as much
about him as they do about his dad
because if that's not a warning then I
don't know what is
um yeah Jack I think that's a good point
um and that story in particular is that
you know I'm good right now and guys are
good but
it took him you know 25 years you know
he wrote Pulitzer Prize
book seemed like he was okay but I feel
we've all come to this point and even
you know you go do this treatment that
we're going to talk about
um it doesn't mean you're healed forever
you don't go to the gym or go downstairs
to work out and think you're going to be
a black belt for a day or you're trying
every day right and so I think in this
healing process it's you know I don't
want to call us damaged but we came to a
point where we needed some help to climb
out of some darkness and so I have to
work on it every day literally every day
probably forever and so I you know you
mentioning that story I think is
important for people to hear like this
is not a one and done there's not a
Panacea you know this is this is forever
right and this is for everyone so we
gotta work on ourselves every day
forever otherwise you know we don't want
to end up uh
you know underground too early so
um
yeah
so let's talk about how you got here how
you got here sitting here today uh
where'd you grow up yeah so I was uh I
was born in Queens New York
uh moved to the island when I was Long
Island when I was three and
um you know I thought I was just like a
typical
Long Island kid I played everything you
know my dad and my grandfather both
played college sports basketball
baseball football
um so I literally I think I had a ball
in my hand at you know two or three
years old I was on skis at three I was
in the water at four
um
we had one of the top wrestling programs
in New York and so I was like on a mat
at like seven you know in most those
places you didn't get to wrestle like
junior high or maybe even high school
and so you know I was lucky
um and I grew up in a Beach town in Long
Beach New York and so you know I was
always in the water always on the beach
I was a lifeguard at 16.
um yeah I mean I thought life was good
and you know I know that sounds like a
pretty freaking no I mean it was good
yeah it was it was you know at least I
thought it was good both your both your
uh your your dad and your granddad were
athletes you said like yeah they were
they were athletes my uh my grandfather
was an All-State basketball player
um white dude too from New York which is
you know to play basketball and I mean
I'll brag I think New York's got some of
the best basketball in the world so I
you know we we played played in tough
leagues and then my dad was more uh
football baseball so he he started as a
freshman in high school which was huge
in in the Catholic High School league so
I went to all boys Catholic High School
where he went Holy Cross and flushing as
a shout out and
um yeah so I help them cut out for that
all boys scenario yeah well maybe it's
why I'm here today
who knows
um hey what about grades and stuff are
you doing good in school I was I was
good in school I was really good up
until high school and that I slipped a
little bit so I was like still in an
all-boys School in high school yeah high
school was all boys so I went to public
grammar in Middle School in Long Island
and then I went to Old Boys Catholic
High School in back in New York so I
took the train for an hour every day uh
the football coach at the time would
pick me up in Valley Stream so wait what
year is this so this is 90 like what
year did you graduate 94. okay Jack
and so
um yeah I would I would take the train
at like 5 50 in the morning he'd pick me
up at 6 30 the coach and then he'd drive
me in
um the rest of the way so that was just
normal back then
um you know some people don't understand
it now but the uh Catholic High School
league and everything was good and I
didn't I grew up in a town that didn't
have a great Public High School
and
um again I was you know I was all about
sports so wherever they had the best
sports I was
I was going out I was going what'd your
dad do for a living
um you know he he kind of
just a bit of a hustler really never
um never finished College uh Mensa smart
though super smart you know it was
really into the market and but just
never applied himself
um
he uh he wind up I think the last 20
years he was a bridge operator so he
literally opened and closed a drawbridge
in the county and you know he worked for
the county and well had benefits the
funny thing is whenever
my I think my Uncle Shane asked me what
does Marcus's dad do and I asked you or
asked him or something he goes tell him
I work for the union just leave it at
that yeah for the union well he used to
tell people he was a bridge engineer
it sounded better than telling him that
he was uh opening and closing a
drawbridge and um and then on the side
he moonlighted he um he drove for people
so he would drive for
um
elected officials yeah but um who I'm
drawing a blank
yeah yeah you know just a few like kind
of so we had like a celebrity he had
like a town Lincoln Town Car and he was
getting literally had a square Lincoln
Town Car yeah that was handed down to me
yeah VA sucked gas it was awesome
I love that thing hey what about your
mom was she around he hit it right on
the head yeah yeah Mom worked for a
dentist for over 30 years so she was uh
she was at the front answering the phone
you know paying the bills greeting
everyone so I had free free dental
growing up which is nice right and what
about brothers and sisters none your
only child I was only child I had a I
have a half sister I've never met
um
well I can't remember well I mean I we I
mean I never I can't I don't remember
that yeah so it was like lesson one when
I think they separated us but uh
you know then that was just me so
spoiled
spoiled only child and the focus was
just on Sports it was all in sports and
you know in academics my dad was he was
an academic and you know I would
literally get like backhanded if I came
home with like you know a b or the part
of his childhood yes
very very hard Dad yeah Dad Dad was hard
right so um what do you think was
driving that your dad because it sounds
like he's kind of laid back in a way or
is he just pouring all of his dreams
into you I think that I think you hit it
I hate I think you hit Adam head yeah my
parents went to Woodstock I mean they
were like they were like sort of hippies
you know mom used to protest the war
um but yeah he had like a real mean side
and his Gran his dad my grandfather was
even meaner
um I think he told me what before noon
he'd already he would already drank like
two quarts of beer you know quartz back
in there
um and then he owned they owned uh like
his family owned a bunch of the um I
guess a medallion like a cabs in New
York oh yeah you know Capone's from New
York right
um and so I don't know how he was
treated as a kid well I'll tell you how
he was sent away to boarding school
in the Bronx
at four years old
so I mean if you and I think back at
four kind of love we had from our
parents his sent them away
uh to Catholic boarding school in the
Bronx and
I could just imagine what went on there
from you know
some of the
some of the individuals that you know
we're hearing about now all these
stories these days so maybe he had some
[__] that he was he was getting out on
me
um possibly but it sounds like he just
wanted you to be successful in a big way
it was all about me yeah he like they
hung up their life to he was at every
practice literally
um you know right there cheering
watching they didn't yell at the
restaurant no that was my mom okay so no
he would he would backhand me if if
something just didn't seem right and she
would get thrown out of the Little
League World Series because she was
screaming at the freaking umpire about a
call and they actually did get thrown
out like she had to leave the stadium
hell yeah I say hell yeah I like people
I don't know why people get the
impression that I would like be uh
yelling and screaming but I'd never like
before my kids played Sports I would
just I wouldn't say anything I wouldn't
even coach him I wouldn't even but well
maybe occasionally but most of the time
I'll just sit there and watch because
it's hard to coach your own kids man
they don't
they don't really want to listen to you
so no no matter how much you know yeah
you just tell me the story downstairs
yeah
yeah I I was telling him my son was
doing Jiu Jitsu I've been doing Jiu
Jitsu at this point I've been doing Jiu
Jitsu for like 25 years and my son I'm
watching him roll and he's got an arm
lock on somebody and I say hey you know
you need to get your hips a little
further underneath that elbow and he
looks at me and he just goes no you
don't I'm like okay fair enough bastard
um not gonna listen to anything but so
so you your grades are good you sound
like a freaking good model kid
I was a good kid but I think that was
the problem too I was like I was I was I
was too nice I'm still a little too nice
but um yeah so I got you know I was
skinny too so I was skinny nice kid that
also got put ahead not held back like
like we do in Texas we hold back our
kids yeah Texas the kids like 17 years
old is freshman absolutely well I mean I
mean you have your son graduated with
someone who was turning 20. yeah I mean
you have to you know you have to pass
for 3 000 yards you know of course they
call it Texas gray shirt
no instead I got put ahead early for
whatever reason and so I was with older
kids skinny nice kid and uh yeah I got I
definitely got abused
just picked on picked on constantly I
think some people call that rite of
passage I think there's a little bit of
both but uh it wasn't fun what kind of
music did you like
growing up in New York like in Queens
um
everything rap and like uh Beastie Boys
right from Brooklyn
um
Guns and Roses
so just you're kind of normal yeah music
yeah it wasn't for late 80s early 90s
yeah some yeah but then I got into like
some other stuff in high school like um
trying to think like kind of
lollapalooza-esque music pro jam you
know everything that was coming out of
Seattle that's right so all that stuff
was good because that stuff made it
mainstream you know in the early 90s so
you could you could pick up on it yeah
baby boys school boys Catholic High
School in Queens and was all this geared
towards you going to college to play
sports yes it actually was that's all we
talked about I mean that's all I knew
were you going to camps I was going to
camps every summer from the I can't even
remember
Jocko that's how far back I was either
in a basketball camp
or a football camp at Fordham or a
baseball camp
uh Junior Lifeguards like just all that
[__] yeah and what what did you what
sport did you like the best
I liked football
is that is that the one you were best at
as well that's the one I was best I I
played in college for her dad we'll get
into that later um but yeah I got full
scholarship to play
um definitely beat your body up of
course but
um I just I don't know it's one of those
things I liked
um I was a quarterback from I think like
seven years old and
um you know I think it was up to me I'd
probably be surfing and I tried because
because we did live in a Beach town and
my dad was like not having it at all
um so I would try to Surf and then
immediately like it would go right into
you know some kind of camp or you know
baseball double headers in Brooklyn you
know at 90 degrees in the middle of
summer type [__]
check all right Amber your turn well I
entered the picture
at the football juncture where my dad
recruited him but prior to that you must
have been doing something prior to that
what were you doing yeah prior to that I
grew up in a really small town in
Southern Illinois so everyone when I say
I'm from Illinois thinks Chicago but
I've actually only been to Chicago one
time in my life
um I grew up on a retired dairy farm in
a very rural part of Illinois retired
dairy farm meaning There's No More Cows
there yeah it's not there's there's all
the barns were still there the milk
house was there The Farmhouse was there
all the land was there was it your
families that retired it yes my great
grandfather great great and great
grandfathers were the Milkmen of my
County
and then they shut it down at some point
yeah so they had I don't even know how
many you know hundreds of cows my
grandfather worked the farm whenever he
was in high school and then at some
point shortly thereafter he was like
their farm hand and he ended up going to
college and uh getting married to my
grandmother and I think at some point
they retired it after that and did your
dad have to work on the dairy farm at
all or was it already done that was my
mom's dad my dad's dad owned an
Excavating business and yes my dad and
his brothers worked the tractors so I
come from a very hard-working family
yeah Dairy Farmers that's a hard life
man yeah a hard life but like a really
good wholesome life and I just grew up
in a really wholesome family in a really
wholesome town and um
my dad being a football coach just
really always drove me loved me but
drove me and like he
the the one thing he taught me was don't
you ever quit anything don't ever quit
and so you know it didn't matter how
uncomfortable things got in my mind I'm
like I'm not quitting I don't have a
quit in me did you play sports
I was a cheerleader I probably would
have been more athletic had my dad been
in my life and my parents he was in my
life but not in like a dad way you know
he was um my parents were divorced so I
saw him spring break a couple months
during the summer over Christmas but you
know day to day I was raised by my mom
and she did how long did you do
cheerleading for
from the time I was in seventh grade to
senior in high school
damn so you were out there yeah I
remember I was working and my middle
daughter she did gymnastics and then she
that's like a little there's a little
there's a little off-ramp or a little
on-ramp to cheerleading right and so she
was doing gymnastics then she got on
that little ramp
and you know I was kind of like dang it
you know like
it just doesn't seem like it's the thing
that you want your daughter to do at
least for me right and then two things
happened one of them was this woman CEO
that I work with who's an awesome woman
I told her I was like yeah I know my
daughter's just doing cheerleading she's
gonna do cheerleading and This Woman's
like I did cheerleading and it was
awesome and I was like really she goes
yeah you're out there you're standing in
front of people you're projecting your
voice and I was like okay fair enough
and my daughter only did it for a couple
years uh then she's then she got more
committed to wrestling
which was awesome
uh that and another thing that happened
was one of my buddies was also had a
daughter who was also doing cheerleading
and he's like he's kind of making fun of
me he goes oh you're letting her because
his daughter's doing cheerleading my
daughter's doing they're both doing
cheerleading but he's gonna make fun of
me because I guess I don't seem like the
cheerleading type of dad and he goes oh
you're letting your daughter do
cheerleading and I go yeah you know I
figure I either let her do cheerleading
or she comes home with a tattoo on her
face when she's like 18 right because
that's what happens you like yeah
pressure your kids or you like steer
them or you prevent them from doing
something they're gonna Rebel hard
against you and then up on the wrong
path so anyways she did trailing for a
little bit all good uh and did you do
good in school oh yeah I was pretty much
a straight A student
did you what did you want to do when you
grew up did you did you want to go to
college like what was the deal so my
parents were both raised in this really
small town they were in the same class
together and had this sort of crush on
each other since they were in third
grade all the way through you know
junior high school high school prom king
and queen captain of the football team
captain of the cheerleading team like
you know they
everything was my two two sides of the
family in this one little town but my
dad had these big aspirations to be a
football coach and so he actually got a
full ride to University of Illinois and
um
that's where he ended up going for his
first coaching you know his first
coaching gig and
um
from that point on when he got out of
that little town he always said to me
you get out of here as soon as you can
because he knew that you know there
wasn't the opportunity for me there that
I would need to have you know that he
wanted me to have in life I don't think
he thought Marcus would be my ticket out
of there but um you know he helped
facilitate that all right so let's get
to that so you end up getting recruited
to go play football I did at Southern
Illinois
um and I remember your dad was the head
coach there yeah so at that point he'd
been from U of I he went to Miami of
Ohio and then got the headphone head
football coaching job at Southern
Illinois University and that was about
10 minutes from this little town that I
grew up in so he was 34 years old and he
was the head coach
um of you know our our hometown team
yeah big school though 25 000 students
division one yeah right now it's
the enrollment's really gone down
significantly like a lot of schools but
it was it was you know it was a large
school back then yeah and you roll in
you get recruited D1 yeah it was um so I
got hurt in high school so I wound up
not playing my senior year what was the
injury uh I tore a couple ligaments in
my wrist my throwing wrist
um tried to play through it for a couple
years and they never actually no one
ever knew it was torn I just kept having
this like I'd land on it wrong and you
know have this like screaming pain
finally got an MRI and they're like yeah
you're you have several torn ligaments
like that's why you're in pain so I said
we can do surgery
um now you'll miss football season but
you'll be back for baseball season or
you can play football season and then
have surgery after but you'd Miss
baseball season
and so just chatting with you know Dad
um I was excelling more in baseball
and we decided you know what let's hang
up football have the surgery and we'll
get you ready for baseball and you said
what year was this what was it before
but what school year was it like this
was your junior year this was my uh uh
like summer yeah summer summer going
into senior Year got it
and so we decided to go ahead with the
surgery and and uh they went in and and
uh they did like an author scope and
they found like the ligaments torn and
then they just went ahead and sewed them
back and I remember it was a long um
recovery it was like it's almost six
months
um and this is this is so my dad so I
get done
get the surgery go through you know
however long I was in a cast
get the cast off literally came home
from getting the cast off after being in
it like four months it was it was long
it was weird
and he he literally put grabbed two
mitts and pulled me onto the beach
and he was like throw the ball
I'm not I'm not making this [__] up but
first off like can you imagine the size
like difference it was like my wrist was
like this big I hadn't done anything
I pick up the ball and this is no [__] I
throw it throws a baseball or football
he was a baseball because I was trying
to I was trying to get ready baseball I
literally threw it like a foot in front
of me I didn't even know and I didn't
even know what to say like Dad I can't
like I'm in a lot of pain did he get mad
he like yeah oh my gosh
it was so [__] weird
um Jay got mad at me like it was my
fault that I couldn't throw this
baseball after I just got out of anyway
so so I played baseball
um didn't have a great season just
played and and
um
my
younger football coach Tom Frawley I
considered kind of like my second dad
and quarterback coach and he just said
hey man you're so talented he's like I
think you should play football in junior
college like you're you know I you know
I think you have something you should do
that and I said yeah you know I kind of
threw it around and went okay I'll you
know I'll take your advice and I started
throwing him in the summer and I wound
up enrolling in uh at Nassau Community
College in New York and not so every
year had like top 10 football they
always sent literally anywhere between
15 and 20 guys to division one and and
big division ones like Ohio State and
Miami and things like that and so I was
going to a real place to play and when I
showed up man I was uh
I was skinny I was 17 going into my
freshman year college and you were young
yeah it was yeah it was
bro your dad for all this pushing should
have held your ass back like two years
dude too you're right you're so right so
I you know I show up again six four one
eighty
and um I mean these this is like a
division one Junior College these guys
are [__] massive from like Brooklyn
and the Bronx and these guys are like
straight up meat eaters and
um I'm like man I don't even know if I
belong here so I hung in as a as a
freshman you get redshirted
um I went to practice every day I worked
hard and I turned 18 that December of my
freshman year and like in February I
went from six four one eighty to like
six four two twenty five yeah I was on
the program getting jacked getting
jacked and uh yeah it was good I was
actually you know I felt like a felt
like a human after that well and
I didn't know you then but from what I
gather all that pent-up frustration from
the bullies of your childhood you
started taking it out with your
increased Society yeah we've talked
about this so yeah so so with the
increased weight and size
um yes Amber is correct
um I did I started getting into a lot of
fights choco really stupid like dumb
like all the time a lot and it was like
and this is when you're at this
Community College yeah it just fed me I
think because of the years of maybe
you know Dad and then like being skinny
constantly getting harassed
um I finally put on some weight and uh I
would just snap every time we went out
didn't matter where any bar I was
getting in a fight yes guaranteed I was
like that guy you drinking now at this
age yes yep that doesn't
that doesn't subdue fighting either it
doesn't help at all it doesn't help um
yeah I think growing up on Long Island I
actually remember the first time we
drank because it was all my high school
buddies freshman year I believe it was
Memorial day like hey Memorial Day we're
all gonna get together we're gonna go
get a couple cases we're gonna go down
to the beach we're gonna drink some beer
and I remember saying how can like how
can you put something in your body and
it makes you act weird like I don't I
don't get it like I honestly did not get
it and we were having this argument like
I don't get it like I could drink 10 of
these like I'm gonna be fine
um I think I remember at some point of
that night like humping the pole
um literally and so uh yeah
don't don't drink this is your freshman
year you're like 12 or 13 or something
literally 13. yeah I think it was 14 at
that but yeah because it was the second
part of my freshman year so so did you
keep drinking through this
or was it a thing or not really well
yeah yeah no I drank but I drank
um I drank on the weekends when we went
out so never during the week Amber still
makes fun of me that I was in bed
he had a bedtime 9 p.m until he left at
the house lit through senior year of
high school like not even during senior
year was this a mandated by the old man
this is mandated my mom okay like but at
that point though I didn't think for
myself at all I was just like oh it's 8
30. I need to get ready and go to bed
you know the light was on and my mom's
screaming down like Marcus shut the
light off go to bed you got to get up in
the morning and catch a train you know
um I mean while Amber's out at my house
in college till like three in the
morning but we'll talk we'll get into
that after
um yeah so uh where are we at are you
are you thinking through high school are
you thinking about the military at all
no not at all I mean I didn't I didn't
think much Jocko I'm just starting to
come into thinking the last couple years
and you were just totally focused on
Athletics that's it um but uh yeah I
didn't think the only thing the only
connection I had to the military
um my grandfather had a purple heart it
was in the house I didn't know the
difference between a purple heart and a
purple rose and
um he mentioned it was from a mortar
attack fighting the uh I think fighting
in Northern Africa against the Italians
um
and but he was another guy who evidently
got in a lot of fights because I I guess
the military was a lot different in
World War II where they would pull like
your rank away like when you weren't on
the battlefield you know if you got in
trouble like he did and then when he
came back I don't know some weird story
that I listened to it was probably
completely wrong coming from my dad
um so that's the only like real well and
your dad was in the Army well he was by
I think on uh I don't think I don't know
if he got
your dad the hippie was in the Army yeah
he was an MP he was a dog handler that's
all I heard about growing up it was his
ferocious dog that bit everybody so I'm
like so you're a shitty dog
because we had a few of those guys too
right did it give you any impression of
like hey you know the military's dumb or
you shouldn't join it or whatever
anything like that absolutely yeah he
was you know he never I don't think he
ever talked about it negative just just
wasn't it we just wasn't there got it
and I wasn't with a crew of like um you
know first responder families like
police and fire so I just didn't have
that you know it was more like artists
and
and uh but nothing negative nothing ever
negative but really no
um I was never uh it just wasn't a part
of my life I was raised a patriot yeah
Marcus was not yeah yeah I have a letter
that I framed that I wrote in third
grade on Veterans Day and it was it's so
funny to read it back but even as a
nine-year-old I'm like yeah that's who I
am were your parents military or was
your dad military or Granddad or
anything No my great grandmother had
five brothers in World War II and two or
three of them were killed one of them
was a pow and so you know I just it was
just instilled in me that we love
America and we honor our military
um but I didn't ever think I wanted to
be married to someone in the military I
think that's a whole different ball game
right I was also you know my hometown
was so small and
um it wasn't you know a very uh
there wasn't a lot of money in the area
that I grew up and so people that joined
the military in my hometown couldn't
afford College it was just a way to pay
for college so like I had this great
appreciation but I also I was completely
dumb to like what the middle what
military service actually was all right
so let's get into this how the coach's
daughter
I mean how does this go about this can't
be this
much right Marcus I mean this is the
goose is like taboo is there anything
more taboo than oh that's a coach's
daughter cool yeah that's where I'm
gonna go yeah that's exactly it
um so I I end up at Southern Illinois
um
in I don't know was that 96 Amber yeah
and uh
just trying to think how I get into how
how are you and I so okay when I was
first looking at the
um like the media guide for the football
teams before I even went to Southern
Illinois I was still in New York
um I saw that coach Watson had had a you
know obviously had a family in there and
had a daughter and I just again never
even I was like oh wow that's
interesting you know that that's came
across my mind
um but that was it like let's put that
away now for like two more years and I
show up at school and I think about a
year and a half in
is I met you
at cuckoo's no at a golf tournament but
I didn't even see you there you didn't
see me I saw you at the golf tournament
you looked really angry and pissed off
that you were there
yeah yeah so we had we did a um I guess
uh like volunteer
for the some golf tournament and I
remember seeing Amber there like at the
table and she was angry and I remember
guys saying like that's coach Watson's
daughter you know and everyone's like
okay stay away from are you just trying
to keep people at Bay just scowling at
everyone or what was up with that I
don't know I think I was probably
I don't know I think I was probably
traumatized by having to be there yeah
um so so that's the first time are you
Marcus at this point are you like a
full-on like just straight beard
swilling jock yes
100 but a nice but that was a nice job I
don't know if that makes any sense but
you're fighting a lot I'm fighting a lot
still fighting a lot when you get to
College oh yeah oh gosh yeah um I mean
we'll go into I mean I was suspended
from Amber's dad my whole sophomore year
after I just got named the starting
quarterback over four seniors
so your dad was great in in recruiting
me but not in the choice of of
Personality
um so that night I go out
uh go to fraternity party this is the
night you get named as a starting
quarterback so you're a sophomore
freaking stoked and I'd been hearing
about him and you know like the whole
area had been hearing about him because
you get like this big good looking guy
from New York and it's who's named
Marcus Capone and so I'm like hearing
this buzz but did you meet him yet when
he gets named quarterback no and
apparently we'd been at that golf
tournament but I didn't know who he was
and got it so all right so now you get
named so we go out myself the fullback
who was my roommate who's just a stud
you know like 600 400 pound guy like a
squat bench you know that type of dude
and can run like a four or five forty
and
um we go to this fraternity party which
is really off limits
um football athletes and fraternities
really didn't mix okay um most of the
fraternities officially like you're not
allowed to go to him or just no it's
more you just don't because a lot of
those guys were High School athletes
that couldn't play in college and so
there was a little bit of like you know
Bad Blood we went because a lot of the
female trainers that you go and get your
you know put your ice in in you know
your elbow and ice or get hooked up to
stem or whatever
um they were all sorority so they
invited us so three of us went
and right from this get-go you can tell
like just it's in the air you know
exactly what I'm talking about the uh
you could feel the energy in there it
was just not going our Direction and uh
one thing led to another and the next
thing you know there's uh literally a
whole fraternity house on top of us in
the middle of the yard there were so
many of them I think it was lucky I
think it was what saved us because there
were so many that they couldn't like get
to us and like punch and kick and
everything else but I do remember like
being on the ground and going man they
can't even get to us there's so many of
them I remember this hand I could feel
this hand like coming up like my arm and
then my shoulder and then my neck and
then I feel it like get to my face and
then like just start like like like
raking me like raking my eye I'm like
this guy's trying to boom and I couldn't
do anything about it so for somehow this
is the best so somehow the fullback my
roommate crawls out underneath all of
them and charges the wooden fence and
literally hits it and knocks the whole
fence down in the yard so you can tell
how well these fences were made in a
college uh you know collegiate House
pieces of crap so the fence goes down
which enables us to get out because now
we're out of the yard so I'm standing in
the street like my eye is completely red
like they now they like it's it's it's
good and scratched
um I'm missing a sandal my shirt's
ripped
um you know I'm standing in the street
cursing
and
we we cool down a little bit and we go
walking back to the the um the dorms go
to bed because that was a fun night
getting getting jumped by a fraternity
house the pikes
and I shouldn't even gave him that
keeping that shout out
um you guys are just jealous
um and we we come across
um we we crossed the strip where all the
bars and clubs are at
and uh
out on the street this club is emptying
and it's the um
all the guys on the football team are
coming out and they're like Marcus
what's going on wait what what the [__]
happened to you I'm like oh man you know
the the the Pikes they they jumped us
and these guys are everyone's drunk and
that was it so they decided they're
gonna go back to the fraternity house so
like 30 dudes go back to the fraternity
house I follow behind them
and when I get there it's complete
Mayhem there's people getting bricks
busted over their face I watched a
person in the NFL pick up a
uh grill a grill and throw it on
somebody
um so it was it was that type of [__]
going on and and I was like wow
so uh police you could hear police
sirens coming and like everybody splits
and you know kind of the rest is history
I get brought in because I was the only
white guy at the at the fight they
couldn't identify anybody there and um
they wanted me to give up all the names
of the guys over there and I was like
no chance I don't even know who's there
actually so because I would not give up
any names
your dad Amber suspended me for the
whole season god
um because they couldn't identify
anybody and so I wound up being
suspended for pretty much that was and
that was a kind of crushed your dad's a
hard ass
I think well I think it was pressured no
my dad is very principled and on the
same hand my dad you know was trying to
turn this program around and his entire
team would have been out so Marcus took
the punishment for the whole team and I
I know he felt bad about that but I also
know that he respected Marcus not giving
up anyone's names and it coincidentally
saved his house too I'm sure
um but I remember that fight because I
had worked really hard all summer to
save money for a car and we were gonna
go buy the car and I had I had picked
the car out we were supposed to go in we
mean you and your dad
no really just me oh okay
um just to go back like it wasn't it was
a local fight but evidently some of the
guys at fraternity houses dads were in
kind of higher positions in Chicago so
it made national news because there were
eight guys got sent to the hospital so
yeah it was like a it was not good
that's a legit scrap and I had a few
drinks as you can imagine
um it was it was legit scrap for sure so
I had picked out this car I'd been
working so hard for it my dad been so
busy and we were gonna go on Saturday
morning at 10 A.M or something and I
called my dad and I'm like Dad are you
ready and he goes like no honey my
quarterback caused the biggest fight
last night you have no idea the
shitstorm I'm dealing with and so I'm
like screw your quarterback I hate him I
don't even know him he's all I wanted
was I've waited so long to get this car
so anyway that was also the beginning of
my independence of being like you know
what I'll go negotiate this deal and
that's exactly what I did so
um that was sort of how I came to know
like who Marcus even was because it was
all over the news and then I saw his
picture in the paper and I was
immediately like oh damn this is the guy
he's so hot and um like Fast Forward
probably a year my best friend had drank
too much at a bowling alley slash
nightclub and I had to go pick her up
and I was not happy about that either
and so when I walked in I went to the
back door and the bouncer opened the
door
so I could get in to get her and Marcus
was like remitted him right now he's
right there and I was like immediately
taken so back and I just said oh you're
the troublemaker and uh we sparked this
conversation I oh I was so smitten but I
didn't I don't think I let on like I was
and I saw you there every week for like
four weeks I I went back every week and
then he wasn't there one week and his
friend who was a bouncer there took my
number and gave it to Marcus and he
called me that night and we hung out for
the first time on July 4th of 1997.
and we've been thick sense
the end
so as we get suspended was that your
sophomore year that's my sophomore year
you get suspended yeah are you allowed
to practice like what are you doing yes
so I had yeah I worked my ass off I
practiced every day
um I went to treatment room you know
three days three times a day still went
to study hall which we had to do every
evening and then I broke down every film
so I'd have to watch hours and hours of
every play from every angle of every
upcoming game and then I would write you
know take notes and like all defensive
coverages and so like I learned you know
I I learned but it was miserable because
I couldn't play on what did you think of
my job I don't think I've ever asked you
this well I mean what was your
relationship with my dad like
it was it was good no yeah I mean we
always had a good relationship I mean I
was angry because I didn't get to you
know I didn't get to play like how did
he treat you then
he treated me well
yeah I mean I was cutting up film for
him it seems like like there's a little
bit of mutual respect like he respect
kind of respect the fact that you didn't
rat anybody out he actually said they
said that too they all said that because
they were like you kind of save the
season because if you if any of those
you know they were all they were all the
you know the guy all the stars right so
um and these were good guys
um so they weren't yeah they weren't
angry they were just like you're an
idiot
okay one you got caught two what are you
doing at the Pike house you know that's
why so there was one time when we were
dating but we hadn't been dating for too
long that Marcus came home from practice
and said your dad knows
and I was like oh what do you mean my
dad does
if that's after he left and went to
Northwestern yeah so we were never
dating when my dad was there got it that
year that Marcus was breaking down film
and whatnot at the end of that year my
dad took a job at Northwestern and so a
new coach had come in and I met you when
when Coach Q had taken over the team
yeah and your dad already left so but he
did find out and he called and he was
not
happy with her
yeah I was 17. oh I was using my senior
year in high school oh damn and how old
are you at this point
20. oh yeah that's not a happy Dad I got
three daughters man yeah you wouldn't be
happy I have a sophomore San Diego State
I get it yeah she has pepper spray and
taser at all times
he I had to call him because I didn't
you know I respect my dad
a lot and
um I wanted to call him and sort of like
head this off and one of Marcus's
coaches who is still friends with him
said like hey coach Watson knows that
you're dating his daughter so I called
him and he was like well
honey I'm going to tell you this
um
he said Marcus is one of the few players
that I can say that I I truly love like
I love that kid he's like but
he's a womanizer and he will break your
heart and if he breaks your heart you
tell him I will break his neck oh there
you go right on
the Hops coming in hot he hit it yeah he
hit it he had a temper yeah he had a
real temper on the field he had a temper
no he actually had a temper everywhere
he's a amazing human being though so
so your dad leaves from coaching that
job the next year now it's your junior
year in college are you starting as a
quarterback no they brought in a a
really good quarterback from Missouri
who actually split time at University of
Missouri with one of the guys who was up
for the Heisman
so you know really after the fight I
feel like everything just went downhill
after that so were you still on the team
I was still on the team I was still
under Scott you know stolen scholarship
so I um this this guy came in and you
know we're actually really close to to
this date
um uh Kent scornia he's very successful
in in Missouri in St Louis and uh
actually he's a donor to vets and
um he was always my roommate on the road
but uh he yeah he came in he was like a
true quarterback from the Midwest like
this guy could sling the ball all over
the place and I played quarterback more
as a linebacker you know
um and that was our difference so I
would you know I would put my head down
and uh you know he would he would throw
the ball you know and slide and things
like that and uh
and finally they moved me over to tight
end my senior year just because
um I wasn't going to get on the field
with him but we we actually split time
the first couple games of the Season uh
and I did well but he wound up like kind
of taking command and control and and uh
he was like a true leader true
quarterback I was a bit of a knucklehead
and wanted to get in fights and run
linebackers over you know and uh yeah so
um
what was there a point in your life when
you thought you're gonna play in the NFL
I mean from when I was you know five
Jaco and that's what I wanted that's
what I wanted to do I should have
rephrased that you know there had to be
a point in your life when you were going
to play in the NFL when did that dream
go out like when did that flame
extinguish that flame extinguished my
it was my
before my senior year so I popped for I
popped for uh testosterone this is your
senior year of college yeah yeah going
into the senior year so Marcus you're
moving over to tight end you're gonna
start at tight end put on some weight
Roger that so I went found some
testosterone tip and eight and got got
bulky and faster and I remember we were
doing off-season workouts and the the
quarterback who who uh we're about the
same speed I put on 20 pounds and then I
started beating him in the in in Sprints
he's like dude what the [__] he's like
how can you gain weight and be faster
than me all of a sudden
um so the NCAA came in actually three
weeks early and uh a few of us uh popped
positive for for performance enhancing
drugs so
that's like I had a I had a knew a guy
that was a bicycle Rider and he said
that when you're on or maybe I just
heard this on I don't know where I heard
this I think this guy I know who said
like he's a bike rider and he said when
someone's on on juice
it's like they're on a Harley like you
literally just can't hang with them
they're just that much better so did you
feel like I mean it sounds like dude you
put on 20 pounds and you got faster Oh
you mean I could I could dunk a
basketball just from a straight vertical
leap you know
um yeah it's it's pretty
pretty potent stuff when you're when
you're abusing it like that not when
you're like using it for like
replacement therapy you know where
they're trying to keep your levels at
around seven or eight hundred we're
talking about you know 2400 2 000 you
know your blood your blood levels are
through the roof and uh but you do you
feel you lose your guide during this
guide yes
this is like this is straight up is
better Bro Science no Google
um this is what three of my buddies said
oh yeah that guy was in the Marine Corps
this guy you know took steroids in high
school and yeah we think it's okay
you'll be fine
so you pop positive I didn't know the
NCAA was testing back then yeah I guess
I'm just the idiot yeah they tested
everybody well I shouldn't say they
tested everybody was random
but and so then are you done or is that
the end of your that's it and I'm done
so you said that's the moment when you
realize the NFL wasn't happening
NFL wasn't happening
and you finish how'd your dad feel about
that before we go what do you finish but
so Amber uh no it wasn't your dad uh no
your dad already left
the head coach called they weren't happy
you know but everything you know they
were always like ah it's not Marcus's
fault you know it was it must have been
something yeah my parents oh your
parents were like yeah they shifted
blame they covered for you a little bit
but your dad must have been realizing
that the dream was over probably his
dream the NFL dream yeah in history
which by the way I had like a one in
like a trillion chance of maybe making
it to the NFL for sure for sure but you
got it I mean it seems like anybody in
pursuing any athletic uh Pursuit that
hard is gonna think well I'm gonna be
able to make it and then at some point
you go
it ain't happening you want to go as
hard and far as you can right I mean
that's that's all you know literally so
you know I mean I remember getting in
the teams and telling guys and buds like
dude I never turned a wrench like all I
did all my dad had me do is play ball
like I literally you know so I learned a
lot just you know that's why I thought
just the teams were so good so I just
learned a lot of like man [__] outside
of you know playing ball which I look at
now I don't even I don't remember the
last time I watched the sporting event
right like you know I kind of frowned
upon some of the stuff that's going on
it's it's gross but
yeah so is this when you started
thinking about going in the dams into
the teams what was the uh what was the
trigger there you're gonna love this
this is this is right up your alley Jaco
so
my roommate uh of course uh dad was a
seal in Vietnam
I don't think he was he may have been a
marine wait what roommate Jason
Jason O'Neill
oh yeah we lived in the apartment
remember yeah I didn't know he was part
of the story I think he's part of the
story I'm just thinking you know you
said I'm gonna love this story so I
figured like one of your brother you're
one of your friend's dad was him you're
gonna love it and then you're gonna
scratch your head too and be like all
right we're gonna go with this Marcus so
we're we're sitting we're sitting in the
apartment one night and this guy
actually started as a freshman wind up
uh when we graduated I went in the Navy
he went in the Marine Corps flew f-18s
you know did the whole
do the whole thing uh Top Gun and all
that all that good stuff and then of
course the Marine Corps what they do to
their guys who go to flight school fly
f-18s and go to Top Gun you would expect
them to continue flying they handed him
an m16.
and put them on the ground in
Afghanistan
you know with all that training I guess
as a fact that's what the Marine Corps
does and that's one of the best things
that they do is because those guys can
talk to aircraft better than anybody
else and 100 and he did but he did
complain because he said man you know
they spent all this money on training me
how to fly and he's like I was really
good at it and then I'm on the [__]
ground in Afghanistan dodging mortars
you know uh which he never ever signed
up to do so it was just interesting to
hear from his perspective like they
don't like they don't like it you know
like they want to fly and now they're
stuck going and calling in cash one of
my uh one of my really good friends was
the same thing Marine Corps F-18 Top Gun
Top Gun instructor Top Gun senior
instructor then he was a fact on the
ground he was an Anglican uh team leader
in ramadi with us just getting after it
and
it's funny because he taught like all
the stuff he did in the Marine Corps he
taught like he talks about what he did
at first one six-month deployment to
ramadi because it was a lot different
than what it was as I constantly tell
him being in an air conditioned cockpit
you know 20 000 feet up in the air
that's right yeah yeah so you're right I
mean those guys can you imagine what
kind of perspective they get oh it's
around and then go back up there and go
wait a minute like I know what it was
like down there yep that's that's the
Marine Corps uh and I've read some great
stories about like the Korean War those
those Marine Corps Pilots that would go
and deploy they're like the Marines
everyone loved them because they they
can just talk to those Pilots the way
they need to be talked to so I mean and
look we have the jtax there's jtex are
awesome too uh but in the Marine Corps
just with the way they do it and it's
pretty freaking cool uh so this guy is
your roommate so my roommate so I come
home
we throw on the TV and
on comes this movie and looking at it
and you know it's got people running
around and I think you're talking about
Sean no I'm not
okay no you're you are incorrect one
Amber's incorrect two times out of a
hundred always 98 right I just don't
ever remember you living with him yeah
we live together remember for like six
months I don't remember that
sorry it's okay go ahead it's all good I
love you
um and and they so here GI Jane So GI
Jane comes on oh I'm just gonna get you
know I'm just gonna get to the point all
right GI Jane comes on TV and I'm like
that what is this and uh they start
talking about you know these units and
this and that and I have when you were
talking about exposure to the military I
hadn't I had none so if I had exposure I
could have maybe called this out right
away this was it this was my military
I'm like I want to do that like this
looks hard they said these are the best
of the best right because they talk
about it in there not not Demi Moore but
the rest of it so that's what actually
just
um told me that there's a unit out there
that's special and supposed to be the
toughest training in the world and
that's
that's what piqued my at least my
initial interest to start to look into
it and go let me just look into what
this is and so you know then I read the
first book because back then it was
um there was nothing online about the
teams so I just I I read I literally
read every book from Vietnam
I mean everything right all yeah and the
more I read
the more I got like focused and the more
hungry and and and
you know and then nothing else mattered
do you start training at this point I
did uh I did
um you also met
um someone who is at SIU and art he was
a seal right yeah oh God I forgot his
name uh from yeah from he died in a car
yeah Team Four yeah I remember I know
you're talking about yeah I thought he
was like will be show well Michelle
there you go we'll be shell and so
imagine you're in college you know how
it is you want to be a team guy or in
high school and then you go you find out
that there's a guy that was a team guy
so he of course he you know he slipped
people's throats he's Behind Enemy Lines
like so every time I saw this guy I was
like I was in awe you know and of course
then when I got to team they're like oh
that [__] no I'm just kidding I'm joking
I'm I'm totally kidding he he actually
had a decent reputation but yeah I
looked up to this kid and
um yeah I was just you know I was just
hungry after that Jocko it was uh
nothing mattered I called my parents I
told them what I wanted to do and they
thought I was crazy Amber thought I was
crazy
but as you know once you get on that
that path Nothing Else Matters and it's
nothing but focus and discipline and
like that's it what did you do uh will
you drop and wait were you because I
stopped lifting that's what I did so all
I knew was like sport lifting you know
heavyweights
um I completely stopped lifting and all
I did was a body weight workouts so the
typical like Stu Smith I think I had
maybe the book you know push-ups
pull-ups sit-ups dips nobody taught me
how to do any of these by the way nobody
taught me how to even like jog to it
like I didn't know anything like I never
jogged like just went out and ran like
six miles everything was like 40 yard
Sprints you know or maybe hundreds but
that was it and so I thought I was like
jogging at a good Pace until I ran with
Sean toll who was in the Army uh for a
long time I I went for a run with him
and were you jogging slower or I was
joking slower okay I was like oh this is
good I'm like I'm working this is
jogging this is this is yogging and uh
he crushed me like I couldn't even I
could barely keep up with him and he's
like I'm not even running at a hard Pace
I went holy [__] this is like so he kind
of brought me up to another level that I
just didn't know about
um so then I started you know jogging
faster
um and so this is what you're doing your
senior year this is my senior college
senior senior college
and it was like this summer before your
senior year that you decided to do this
he came to me and said he wanted to be a
seal and of course there was no 911 I
didn't know what a seal was I really
didn't know the difference between the
Army and the Navy although I was I knew
I was patriotic but then I also thought
that maybe the military wasn't for me
based on what I knew about kids from my
hometown that went in it and so I
thought you know it's just a great
jumping off point because Marcus was so
captivating and so cute and such kind of
a check in the box for me to be like I
dated the SIU quarterback I don't expect
that we'll stay together you know I
thought maybe we'd date for the summer
you know whatever and we'd been together
at that point for two and a half years
and I met him at 17. so you know in my
mind like no other guy had ever existed
because he was everything to me but at
the same time I knew that I was young
and I was you know very independent and
I was raised an only child I have two
half brothers who I love like like
brothers and I consider them brothers
but I was raised an only child and so I
wanted to be independent I wanted to be
I wanted to graduate and and move to
maybe Chicago or St Louis
at some point I even thought like maybe
I'll move to LA or New York I just
wanted to be and when he told me he
wanted to go into the military I thought
this is this is perfect because they've
kind of been thinking this and we're
young and probably not going to stay
together and get married so by jumping
off point you mean jump off the the
freaking Marcus train and go your own
way yeah but in a house yeah like oh
good we talked about it and he's like
you know these are my goals and this is
my vision and I'm like well I'm you know
I'm a couple years behind you in school
and I wanted to rush a sorority I wanted
to be young and be not be in this
committed relationship and so we we had
it super amicably decided to break up so
you break up and this is how when did
you talk to a recruiter so that's that's
what I was going to talk about next so I
did I just went on the Strip uh same
place where I ran into the guys coming
out of the club there was recruiting
there was uh Marine Corps Navy
Recruiting Station there and I went to
talk to the Navy recruiter and he was a
um
I think it was a diver combat diver
and he was really cool like really cool
and he just said hey he's like you're
you're at the you're at school here
right and I said yeah he said well you
know you you can be an officer and I was
like what's that I literally said what's
that
[__] knucklehead right
um he's like well you know you go to
college you get your degree and you know
you could become an officer in the
military most people that are enlisted
you know don't go to college and they
enlist and kind of explained it said
okay well that that sounds cool like
let's do that
and so he handed me off to St Louis
which was running I guess
um they I think they managed the
individuals yeah the officer recruitment
and and again I didn't like have I had
no mentors you know
um you know as you know a lot of the you
know the officers that go on either go
to the academy or they have you know
congressmen like they just they have a
better Network I just didn't know
anybody and so I was training on my own
and then the day I had to uh he drove
the the officer recruiter drove down
from St Louis and met me at the
University to take my like PRT coprt
test I borrowed a pair of I've been
training in sneakers I borrowed a pair
of boots because I didn't have any she
had to wear boots I'm a size 14.
I the only size that was available to me
I think was like 11 and a half or 12. so
I literally squeezed my feet into these
size 12s
about the second lap in I completely
like both my legs cramped up
uh finished the Run
um do start doing push-ups and I'm doing
uh what they call them uh grasshopper
push-ups oh like like little half
push-ups yeah like your elbows are in
instead of like out here and he's like
stop what he goes those aren't those
aren't push-ups those are we call those
grasshopper push-ups I was like well
it's the only ones that I know you know
so I'm going to keep going because I
know you can't because they don't count
you have to move your arms here so the
whole test was a complete failure like I
[__] that thing up completely and
um you know I found out of course I
didn't get picked up for perspect war
but I got picked up for every other
officer program so you come in go to
Nuke you go to whatever so
um you can't can't go to Buds and you
can transfer after two years and then
yeah but you know the reason you know
just
the only time I actually thought a
little bit and the only reason I'm going
in the military is to be a team guy and
and so I just told him like no I you
know I want to go to Buds and he said
well you can just go back to the you
know the recruiter and you can enlist I
said great yeah can you give me a ride
yeah give me a ride we shook hands I
took my you know my little packet that I
already started building my record and
went back to the recruiter and I think I
enlisted right there like sign you know
MEPS
yeah you're right
so you in how long was it like when you
enlisted how many how long did you have
to wait before you could leave
it was quick and we'll get yeah we can
get in that story but from when I talked
to the recruiter I think it was about
six months so I was you know I'd show up
every month and they'd have like little
Gatherings or whatever but I was still
training
um starting to get a little bit
indoctrinated into the into the military
so were you going to school were you
guys split up when you actually signed
the papers no uh we were actually living
together oh dang and I don't remember
that now I'm just
and yeah you were just training and
getting ready and we knew that you know
that the end was coming
but we were still together okay and then
you signed the papers and now you got
your date hey you're gonna leave on this
date
I'm gonna leave I'm gonna leave on this
date uh what's that June
15th
000 and
I don't know when did you tell me you
were also finishing he had his last
semester in school ended in December and
then you did your well then I did my
internship I did my internship for four
week no four months at The Breakers
Resort in Palm Beach Florida what is it
wasn't a terrible internship there's
like Resort management like I basically
got paid to be a a uh a Cabana Boy and
like get tips I mean literally and then
two weeks run the children's like kid
program it was crazy and that's what you
did from December until until uh April
yeah so April came back graduated didn't
walk I didn't really care about like
walking across the stage to me that well
we're we're missing a huge chunk of that
don't go too far into the story because
well in May 2000 okay good
so in the summertime
July August school starting is when we
decided this will be our last semester
together I knew he was going to leave at
the end of the semester I also had an
aunt who was dying of breast cancer and
so and I was working full time I had 18
credit hours I was working 30 hours a
week my aunt was dying and so
um for a couple of months I was thinking
like I'm not sure I feel quite right but
I just kept delaying what I would soon
realize was the inevitable which was
taking a pregnancy test oh
and I finally took this test in October
and I had been pregnant since August
so I was in about 12 weeks pregnant with
our son when I found out and he was set
to leave in two months in December
set to leave for the Navy for his
internship for the internship
okay so got it now I'm tracking yep hey
I'm still trying to track the story so
so it was a world and what did you do I
mean so freaked out completely freaked
out and Marcus was so supportive
initially he's like
he's like this is going to be fine like
we're going to be parents it's going to
be fine and here he is like all this
these dreams and plans and I was the one
freaking out and then he told his
parents and they freaked out and when
they freaked out he freaked out when he
freaked out I really freaked out there's
a lot of freaking out there
freaking out [__] rolls downhill
obviously oh I just thought like my life
is over it's ABS I was so excited about
this new beginning and
it's over and um
I I now see that is the beginning that's
the beginning of everything thank God
wow so you find out in October then in
December you're going to be a Cabana Boy
in Florida right Commander boy but
meanwhile you're an expecting dad
right at the same time right at 20
22 years old and you're already know
you're going to join the Navy yes
and then what's the call then
so the call is I go do my internship
because you got to do to graduate or
whatever to graduate
Amber stays back did you did you
um did you go to school in the spring oh
yeah you did okay so Amber's pregnant
she's going to school in the spring I'm
in Palm Beach Florida
working as a Cabana Boy and snorkeling
in the evenings on the on the on
training yeah I trained my ass off down
there no I did but you're working 17
jobs or whatever with 18 crackers still
you're just like I think I took 15 then
in the spring but um yeah I was working
full time and going to school I was you
know nine months pregnant taking finals
it was Amber worked forever like from
the day I met her she was always working
like
Non-Stop and it hasn't stopped so the
reason we're still here
um yeah she worked her ass off she
really did she's a grinder and then how
did this whole uh scenario impact your
decision to go in the Navy
it I mean it really didn't like I was
this is what I want to do I you know at
23 I I
didn't
um I didn't even think about what it was
like to start a family but then again
what were we supposed to do I was
supposed to graduate and then get a job
and you know like well here's your job
yeah yeah I mean here's here's your job
how are you making you know how are you
making money again you know my dad
handed me a ball when I was three
um I didn't know I was scared to death
honestly I remember saying
I'm supposed to put on a shirt and tie
now and go step off in the private
sector and get a job you know doing what
and making what to support support the
family like I was scared to death too
then once I started really thinking
about it but the Navy seem like the
viable option the name of a family the
Navy seemed at that time
comfortable
you know yeah it's like a paycheck
Health Care paycheck Healthcare yeah
right and I think that's some of the
probably advice I got from individuals I
don't remember I mean I think maybe I
talked to a few just said hey you'll you
know she'll be taken care of you'll be
taken care of you make a few hundred
dollars more if you're married whoa
um and at that time when you don't have
any uh money and I don't think anybody I
mean my parents are definitely not
supporting us and
I mean Amber's Family of course would
have but we I don't think we were
thinking about that no so you end up
getting married prior to leaving well we
spent most of my pregnancy apart and not
just because he was in Florida it's
because you know we had this whole like
existential crisis where we didn't know
how to make this new curveball fit and
there was there were several months when
I thought I'm just going to raise this
baby you know I I absolutely thought
about ending the pregnancy and I
couldn't there was no way I could and I
thought I don't care what this means I
don't care how hard this is I'm just
gonna figure it out
and um you know even if that meant doing
it by myself and
Marcus was in the um kids area like he
had alluded to earlier and we had picked
our son's name
before he left
and at the time no one was naming their
kid Caden you know it was like he wanted
to name him Cadence I think we saw in a
baby name book and he's like oh it's
like the quarterback calling Cadence
he's like but it sounds like a girl's
name so let's shorten it and there was
this little baby that came in when he
was at the breakers named Caden and we
never heard that name before and so he
called me that night and he was like I
can't do this anymore let's figure this
out and so
that's what we did and we named Caden we
named him Caden of Battle of War that's
the that was the ready for battle ready
for battle that's the that was the
meaning
why not I mean I tried to call him like
Nico oh Nico Vito and major were his
three names of choice but I wasn't going
for that so yeah we Kaden was born in
May of 2000 Marcus came back proposed
um we got married in June of 2000 and
then six days later he he left for boot
camp
typical story it's like most Americans
right and did you stay like at home in
Illinois I did when you left for boot
camp and everything because there's no
point in yeah you know move the Navy
wasn't going to move me but um of course
and then he had to go to a school and
see school let's be a sonar Tech and so
when he was finished with C school and
he was getting ready for buds in doc I
was able to move out Caden was nine
months old at the time so I was 21. I
had never been away from my little you
know Tiny Town in Southern Illinois and
we moved to the towers in Coronado and
so he would
walk to work like you know walk to buds
every morning we had no money no we were
raking in the money at 1082 per paycheck
and our rent was a thousand I was gonna
say what was the rent a thousand a
thousand so we got a little bit of help
from Mom and Dad a little bit not right
not really no we didn't you're right we
just racked up a lot of credit card
bills
and now you're rolling into buds rolling
in the buds how are your how's your
preparation are you good I'm good yeah
really good
Ian you joined in May June July so when
September 11th when is that what's your
career where are you at yeah
no I was in third phase oh damn yeah
before we get to that line let's start
let's start with first phase I mean
how's that going you you're first phase
was uh first phase was good so I showed
up uh 175.
started with 175 pounds no no no I'm
sorry the number of uh people in the
class yeah got it so I get yeah I show
up and I look around
and there's a lot I mean that's a lot of
people 175 is a lot yeah and all I keep
hearing is you know one in four are
gonna make it like 25 and honestly the
first thing I thought of was
how can I be one of these one in four
there's so many people here and I'm
again I'm I'm
I don't even consider myself I'm not a
big guy compared to like the guys I
played ball with in college but but
everybody else there was like Oh Marcus
is a big guy oh yeah for sure how tall
are you six four and how much did you
weigh when you start a buds like two and
a quarter two and a quarter 225 that's a
big dude going through buds yeah and I
and I was just FYI I was like just
turned 19 and uh I was 174 pounds when I
got there I was like a little kid it was
so awesome yeah guys like you probably
like you we had guys that gained weight
during bud I did I gained 10 pounds yep
I gained 10 pounds but like if you you
were what 23 24 23 yeah sir you're like
a man I was a man ish well I was not
really well I was like physically
physically physically I think you're 24.
I'd be questionable the instructors if
we were men right what's that I think
you were 24 when you started buds was I
so you're in pretty good [__] you're in
good shape I'm in good shape
but this is this is what I'm getting at
so I look around and see these guys and
all of a sudden you know we start doing
the indoc
and everybody is just in phenomenal
shape they can do pull-ups forever they
can run forever
you know I'm still a little heavy so for
me pull-ups I can do them but I can't do
like I was watching guys do like 20 30
40 50 at one time or run art class I
swear we had at least 10 individuals
you know Mike Murphy Nelson Sanchez
these guys were running
sub 24 minute Four Mile timer Murph and
and Sanchez would always be like
[Music]
it was insane right and I was you know I
never I so this was cool about the runs
I never uh I was in the Goon Squad
literally one day one time
uh never failed Four Mile time run and
never got gooned except the one time so
like for me the running
I did it and I you know I got ahead of
the Goon Squad but it was miserable you
know it was what class were you in 236
236 check yeah and so so third phase
Jaco so we're in third phase oh we'll go
back to first phase yeah I um I was in
good shape but but again I look around
and see 175 guys and I was I was nervous
and then after I started seeing guys
work out and then guys doing literally
doing splits like am I in the right
place like these guys are these are
there's some freaks here you know like
Olympic swimmers and all these these
these crazy individuals and then as you
know class starts in the loudest it is
wild the loudest screamers all of a
sudden you're like Hey where's so-and-so
he you know he talked a lot of [__] you
can't even
comprehend it like we were talking
before we started recording it's like
you and I have Survivors by us meaning
every friend I have 100 made it through
buds so as far as I know the freaking
pass rate for buds is 100 so you know
like oh everyone mates everyone everyone
I know made it made it but yeah the wild
thing is the people that like you said
like Olympic swimmers and Olympic this
and D1 this and D1 track guys and D1
football players and everything and they
all just quit it's insane yeah they all
go away pretty quickly
was there anything in hell week that
like tripped you up or were you just
like hell yeah
the reason I say hell yeah for me is
because I I like sucked at everything
well I didn't sucked I was I was okay at
everything but I had to put out really
hard
to pass runs I had to put out really
hard to pass the o-car so I had to put
out really hard to pass the swims and
look everyone's putting out but I had to
put put out really hard to pass the
evolutions but in hell week
it wasn't it's not pass fail it's just
keep going we do there's anything I'm
okay at it's like oh I can keep going
right I will I will keep going and so
for me hell week was almost like a break
because you just had to keep going which
I was good at everything else like I did
I failed I failed to Four Mile time run
I I paced myself I was an idiot I mean I
wasn't fast enough to Pace I just needed
to Sprint I failed to swim and again
like a bunch of people failed to swim
and I was one of them so that sucked I
don't know if I failed an obstacle
course I probably did but it like so I
was kind of middle of the pack but it
was because I was putting out hard so
for me hell week was like cool and a
bunch of people quit
a bunch of people quit and I was like
damn are you dumb like yeah and a lot of
those individuals were up front oh yeah
it's insane yeah we had some pipe
hitters some like legit I shouldn't say
pipetters because they're not they're
good athletes right they're good
athletes and yeah it doesn't really
matter man get tired wet and cold we had
I mean we had a bunch of Rangers and
Marines in our class
um we had some Egyptian officers in the
class and it was it was diverse
um but you know I I did have trouble on
the runs but like you I put out so I had
to really put out hard to stay up and
pass the runs
um I couldn't I couldn't like keep it
back a gear you know I had a I had to
really put out but no I everything I did
was
um I did I did okay I remember one time
they pulled me out of the
um log PT because everybody was
literally just it was falling on their
head and I was just I don't know I was
in a different gear and like Capone sit
down like a higher gear like doing
better yeah yeah I just felt I felt I
felt good you know with the log and they
made me sit down one time they're like
you know just sit down because you're
you're damn you're you're doing all
right
um it was one time at hell week I think
it was what were those elephant elephant
cage Elephant Run oh elephant runs yeah
when you're like holding yeah so there
was one day I was super dehydrated and I
remember this and uh like I thought I
was gonna die and I kept trying to like
pull back so like guys would run and I
would I was literally trying to like
pull it back because I couldn't I
couldn't keep up and you know I was
getting yelled at I'm like guys I don't
know what's going on like I I can't I
can't do anything right now and I barely
made it through that Evolution I
remember it it was it was miserable I
remember to this day because
you know how it is you just everybody
hits a point right and I hit that point
where I could not I felt like I couldn't
go any further and the only thing that
kept me going was like probably the guys
behind me like kicking me in the ass
like hey dude like keep going
um and then there was a there was a rock
hump when we used to do uh you know you
just do the O course throw on a pack
whatever it was three miles there was a
time there also that I felt like I was
about to like pass out something was
wrong and I remember one of the guys in
the class and I remember never forget
this Ben Sauders who you know a lot of
guys made fun of because he grew up in
the Midwest and he was a Bible beater
and he never cursed and he never drank
and never did anything he comes running
up past me he's like hey man what's
what's wrong with you I said I don't
know I was like I'm I'm about to die
he's like I'm gonna stay with you and
I'm gonna I'm gonna is that cool I'm
like yeah absolutely he ran with me the
whole way until we finished and this was
because you were dehydrated
dehydrated or whatever so those are like
the two times I just remember at Bud's
where it was like
you're about to you're gonna die you
know but other than that how about dive
phase how are you in the pool because
you surfed I like yeah I like the water
um I think I had some trouble with
um with pool comp like everybody else
does
um my I think if I remember my
exhalation knot I almost [__] drowned
because I'm like hey there's water going
in my my tube here and it's not supposed
to be you know so you come up and like
I'm trying to explain myself to the
instructor staff and they just jumped
all over me no no no wait just listen
just hear me out one time I was talking
pool comp with uh Andy stump the other
day up at Jiu Jitsu Camp because he was
an instructor he's a third phase
instructor and you know how that
like he's just like
so hilarious and what he's telling me
from like his instructor point of view
of what he would do and what he would
see and how he would do it and like he's
laughing hysterically like and I go how
many people did you I go were you like
the hard instructor he's like oh yeah
how many people did you pass
oh no I said I said will you like the
hard instructor and he goes I passed
three people in three years or four
people three years past his pool comp
everyone else failed and he said the
guys that passed he said I respected him
because you know he put them through
hell yeah any
um we we did Andy's podcast and Andy put
me through um jump training on the East
Coast yeah and uh yeah he was you know
and he knows this he was God he was such
a dick to all of us except if you were
in his like his Circle you know um but
it was cool to see him up in uh Montana
and uh yeah it was great just what he's
got going on now he was awesome he's one
of the best you know obviously one of
the most talented uh jumpers that like
and one of the most talented wise asses
he's just so good
um but yeah you gotta have him debrief
you on his experience as a I think he
was a freaking dive instructor or a
second phase instructor for like a
couple of years oh man so he was telling
me about how like he'd watch the kids
hands and when their hands would go into
this like involuntary claw like motion
and he goes yeah that's when I knew I'd
had him it's like good God I cannot
imagine uh him having more fun torturing
people but I guess he's doing it uh and
then you're in so then you get the third
phase third phase and third third phase
um I couldn't couldn't wait for I think
like most most guys and uh yeah third
phase is great
um the only problems I had there out on
the island
we we made a really shitty hide site for
like you know your your day that you
were supposed to take hours to do it it
was it was so pathetic Jocko that um one
of the instructors came out I don't want
to say his name
um but he lost his [__] he lost his [__]
so bad that I think if uh some type of
brass was there they might have thrown
him in jail
um he flipped out on us he took one of
the students like just threw him every
Rich Direction I think put his boot in
the guy's chest and like kicked him a
mile you know it was one of those things
uh we were scared to death and then we
worked on that hide for another four
hours and I chose tight but so but
because of that we had to sleep on the
beach it was a camp stupid
so I got to sleep at Camp stupid which
you really don't sleep because I was
getting I was trying to sleep on the ice
with those ice plants and Ice plants had
nothing but some kind of nasty bug that
was just biting us all night so we
didn't get any sleep some kind of sand
flea some areas it was bad so um yeah so
that was my uh my third phase experience
and uh well also the towers came down
well then the towers came down so we're
up at um we're training out east you
know in the desert and
um
structure comes out from the house there
and says hey the US is being attacked
the World Trade Center just got hit by
by an airplane
and we all looked at each other and
we're like man
can these [__] guys just leave us
alone like we're in third phase this is
a conversation we're about to graduate
and they're still messing with us like
what'd we do wrong like we had a shitty
second phase I I should I shouldn't talk
about that
um we had a really shitty second phase
but important
I I actually did me and and I'm gonna
I'm gonna name him uh me and me and Jeff
boss so he and I are swim butting it to
the bathroom
and we go running out and our our uh our
Proctor was a guy by the name of you
know Fiverr uh super laid back sdv guy
like probably the actually we were told
the only instructor that you can't piss
off like it's impossible to piss him off
we we somehow figured out how to do that
because we were running to the bathroom
we didn't see him
and he called us evidently like three
times
and we didn't answer and he [__]
flipped his lid because of that and
because the Cadre was like yeah he
doesn't ever flip out like we've seen
him for like 15 years
they made us spin the wheel of
misfortune every day for this was the
first day of segregation they made it
every day just you and your swim buddy
no the whole class oh God which is even
better right so we got really we got we
made a lot of friends after that
um so the real Misfortune I've talked to
classes like before and after us like oh
we spun it like twice
I'm like twice a week or like no no the
whole phase I'm like we spun it every
single day we got back from our dive so
we'd get back from our dive didn't
matter one o'clock midnight it doesn't
matter
put all your stuff away get back in the
grinder spin you know spin the wheel of
Misfortune uh 208 counts go
so we did that every day for second
phase which I was told like never
happens and it was just like a miserable
second phase because we had to do you
know more PT for like an extra hour or
whatever so it sucked third phase we're
still being harassed we thought it was a
joke they March Us in we watch it on TV
for 30 seconds we March back out to the
grinder and uh we just didn't have any
idea what was about to happen the Cadre
their demeanor was completely different
I'm getting chills you know talking
about it but you can tell like they knew
what was about to happen and I remember
them like having this like hatred and
just you know like we're about to go to
war guys and and we're just like no
we're out here we're in buds we're on
the beach we're working out
and the demeanor from the class which is
all we want to do is get through buds
this sucks
from their demeanor which was like we
are we're going to war like this is
what's happening and it was it was
totally different and and from that day
forward from the last last part of the
third phase like they were serious it
wasn't more of this like joking
crew of Cadre like they were
um
like this was real this was not the [__]
you know that
in all honesty that some people signed
up for I mean there was right after that
there was a few guys from sqt and one in
one particular I remember quit in sqt I
was like I didn't sign up to go to war
you know I went to college and whatever
so I think some people this was like
obviously a big reality check for us we
I don't think we knew any different
because we were just trying to get
through buds so damn so Amber this whole
time your new husband is coming home
freaking with the [__] beat out of them
and he's working crazy hours and all
this like what's your what's your
impression at this whole scenario before
September 11th
I really Draco thought we just have to
get to the end of buds I literally
thought after the six months of training
things are gonna really even out
of course I mean even minus 911 that you
know nothing could have been further
from the truth but in my mind that was
like at least something that was an end
goal and so all of the late nights and
Ice baths and I don't I just need to
stay on the couch all weekend like that
to me was going to come to an end and
life was going to be normal again it was
also some of the sweetest times because
he was so spent and I look back at
photos of our one-year-old climbing all
over him and he's got both knees you
know wrapped with ice and he's trying to
be a dad and you know we've got pictures
at the zoo and I can see how beat down
he was being a bud student and trying to
be a dad
he came home one night on our
anniversary and it was like you know
midnight like he'd missed the
anniversary and he had geraniums picked
from our apartment complex it was the
sweetest thing like he was still trying
so hard to be the sort of this dual role
and after 9 11 like it's like Cadre I
mean he completely changed and what
about what did you realize what an
impact September 11th was going to have
from the perspective of when I was going
in the serial teams and it was 1990
1991. I thought I was going to Vietnam I
thought I was going to Vietnam War like
I thought we hey there's seals just
sneaking around the world just killing
people and that's what I was going to be
doing so I just thought that's the way
the SEAL Teams was that's what you did
uh then I got to the SEAL Teams and it
wasn't like that in the 90s it was not
like that at all so did you have the
impression like hey he's going to war
anyways
or were you like oh once this is once he
gets done with the Seal training we're
gonna be you know able to just kind of
live normal lives but now this September
11th happens
I didn't know what had happened because
I went from being an independent
sophomore to a pregnant college student
to a wife and a mom and now 9 11 happens
and
um my birthday is on September 12th
today and um
my mom had come to visit in 2001 so
yeah 2000 911 too oh my gosh it's 21
years nine eleven okay yeah sorry zero
one
yes anyway my mom had come to visit and
um I remember telling her like I think
he's I think he's at War like I think
he's gone he was on the island I had no
idea I'm like I think he's probably
gonna leave like today
and we also it was just a crazy time I
had no idea how much
it would yeah I don't think any of us
did yeah even uh I mean from my
perspective I had been in the zero teams
for like 10 years at this point and
you know you thought like everyone was
paying I was paranoid that you know I
wasn't gonna get any I was gonna miss it
it was gonna be over like everyone was
feeling like that and because it seemed
like it would last for you know what six
months maybe
maybe I wouldn't even I was about to say
maybe a year but I don't think anyone
fought oh this is going to go on for a
full year like we would do some strikes
we would do some hits take out some
targets and then that would be that
um I would love to hear someone tell me
that they knew it was going to last 20
freaking years I would I would be very
suspect now I did have some officer
senior officer friends me that said
when I was like hey get me back to a
team please now they were like hey this
is gonna go on a while
I'll give them credit for for thinking
that and first tell me that
um but almost everybody was like oh we
need to get over now if you don't get it
now it'll be another you know because
the first goal four of you but you kind
of based some stuff off the first Gulf
War which was 72 hours right it was 72
hours Russian Ukraine right right away
everyone said oh this is going to end
this is going to be a month yeah and now
it's like wait a minute yeah oh wait a
minute um it's a it's it's a lot
different
um yeah so I think that everybody in the
community
no one no one that I talked to was like
oh this is gonna last two decades that
wasn't even a thought
um
did you go to sqt on the west coast yes
yeah okay
that was like I think I was the first I
think it was the second class where they
didn't do the stt anymore everyone did
sqt you didn't get your well actually
you got your you got your Trident when
you graduated sqt oh so that was that
was your class that was a class I think
before us I think it was
like uh
it was uh was it 35 yeah like Goggins
and uh Brent uh I know it was relatively
new yeah yeah and I remember thinking
like
I'm so happy that he's going to get to
do
something with all this training because
you know sales during
times of Peace versus you know 9 11 on
um I'm sure it's a very different way of
living and deploying and being and I
just thought like I know there's been a
you know it's been peaceful times for a
while and good for him I'm glad that he
gets to actually utilize this training
and I also remember thinking
seals are so incredible they nothing you
know they don't die I guess you had you
know you hadn't heard and that was my
thinking back then was so naive
um but I never was afraid like he can't
do this anymore or I was actually very
uh I was afraid but I wasn't thinking
that I needed to intervene I was very
supportive of
of him to plane
yeah
um that's so crazy because you were
young we're all I mean I think so I was
in the Navy for 13 years before I shot
my weapon at the enemy so 13 years that
you're talking about like this peace
time and I actually it was awesome like
I had a great time like we worked hard
we trained hard we were hanging out with
our friends uh we were trying to be
ready for combat which was the big thing
that we didn't know and didn't
understand so you're kind of preparing
for something that you don't really that
you really don't understand but I really
loved the job of being a seal even if
the job is just going out and going into
the desert and doing desert Warfare
training I love that job it's an awesome
job but I mean what you're talking about
Amber like the fact that you feel that
as like a mom and a wife even you felt
like I'm glad he's gonna get to do his
job imagine what the dudes are like the
dudes are like oh I you know it was it
was I mean we used to I hate saying this
because it sounds so freaking horrible
but we used to like pray for war like
just want to go to war so bad we just
that's what we wanted to do and um yeah
it's
we got we got what we asked for
um we got what we asked for
I was going to ask you about sqt
so you go through sqt yeah and now that
must have been those dudes must have
been like
fully full-on like we're going to war
you guys are all going to war yeah
absolutely it was it was weird too it
was like a transition so they're
bringing guys in that had uh just gone
overseas and done something and like
after actions and so like all of a
sudden the shifts started changing from
like H gear to stuff that actually you
know fits you and works and we also had
I think 11
guys in sqt class that came back that
had gotten out
right after 9 11. they came back in So
we had all these guys that were two guys
before went on the private sector 911
that's your point Amber like can you
imagine you're a dude you were in the
team for four years or six years you get
out of the teams you're going out you're
doing whatever you're doing outside the
war kicks off you like I'm going back in
I'm throwing everything I have away all
built up whatever I'm going back in
because that's what dudes wanted to do
exactly uh did you get so you get your
Trident at the end sqt what what'd they
do when you go what team did you go to I
went to 10. they just commissioned ten
and seven so half the class went to
seven for STV one and then half of us
went to ten did they did they did you
did you keep your Trident when you got
there because I know I heard some good
stories like some teams were taking
you're trying to painting it blue so it
was a nerd two and four two and four oh
yeah like you showed up like you didn't
have it you got it ripped off I think as
soon as you came across the quarter deck
I know I want to say somebody sdv was
telling me they took their tridents and
put them into a bird cage that's what
they did on the East Coast so they put
them on they put them in bird cages
they're like you could look at it but
you can't you can't have it you know and
of course the ones you know the guys who
struggled uh they had to keep their
tridents in The Birdcage you know a lot
longer than guys that were that were
squared away so but we did you know we
did um
we did get beat into our chest uh from
the instructor staff at sqt you know
while all the families were there and
stuff so that was you know at least we
felt like it was something there but
yeah maybe not so much
compared to how it used to be like used
to be Burke of the day yeah it was cool
uh you know I checked into the team and
we went through something called seal
tactical training at the team and they
needed a board with your uh did a board
with like the senior people in each
department but man the training that the
guys get now the training that you got
this like centralized training with all
the experience all Consolidated it's
it's awesome like there's no doubt
they're I think they're coming out of I
don't know if they might be coming out
of buds now not just SKT I think buds
with like four weeks of CQC training
yeah it's you know compared to like you
wouldn't even see it until you're at a
team you know six months down the road
that you went to Shaw's for two weeks
you know yeah and that the thing is like
uh when you were talking about guys
coming back from like combat deployments
and getting in there and that's cool
right that's awesome but imagine like it
turned into hey these guys were in
sustained combat operations for years
because I remember in the 90s like if a
guy did ah Mission like singular like
one Mission it was like Hey dude this
guy's combat experience and
like they had this thing that you didn't
you know like I had a platoon Commander
who's an awesome guy and he had been in
Grenada
and it was like you know he had he had
slayed the dragon and we were all just
looking at him like yeah he was the
coolest guy ever we had first phase
instructor was on the uh the train op in
Bosnia you know yeah I was like oh man
there was a gunshot like like five miles
away yeah a farmer who was like a animal
and like that was a contact left you're
getting debriefed on it not judging
anyone that was there just yeah no props
pass him passing you did you did what
you were uh what the country asked you
to do so you get into a you get you show
up the team now you go right into a
platoon yeah what's your job do you just
get handed at 60 or what how did you
guess you didn't think I'd be like the
comms guy or
um I got handed 60 just because I
couldn't wait I was like give me two
please
um I couldn't wait to be a 60 owner
actually did you get a Mark 48 or did
you get a 60 I got a 60. sweet yeah by
the way Marcus had never shot a weapon
before
yeah I mean I was like I said I grew up
yeah I grew up playing playing ball well
the cool thing is no bad habits good
hand-eye coordination because you were
an athlete like that's all points to you
probably being a pretty good shot and
everything I was I was a better pistol
shot I picked that up quickly
immediately rifle took me a while to get
proficient at it and even when I went
over to to Deb group you know I I never
struggled with it but like the pistol I
was
I was a really good pistol shot and
quick and faster in everybody but the
rifle like I was like middle of the road
I had I struggled with it actually early
on
um I remember out at Shaw's the uh the
guys out there Ross and just coming over
and saying hey you know we just you know
don't don't put your magazine on the car
like just a bunch of things that like
he's like I can work on but soon as he
worked like with me you know I went from
being pretty like not good to to to
excelling but it took me a while and I
tell people I was like no I actually had
to like really focus and practice and
like stay late or you know go out to the
range in the evening when guys were like
hanging up because I just there was just
something not right about not being
proficient at it you're right like I
want to actually be good I don't want to
just hang it up and and walk away so I I
got I got decent at shooting a a
you know a rifle what year was it when
you checked into team 10. 2002. like
April and do you do you know where
you're going on deployment do they
nothing we didn't know anything yet they
were oh because the world was still just
chaos yeah it was chaos and new team
like they were going through you know
Growing Pains I think and so we didn't
know anything and my first deployment
actually went over to Germany and just
got your Yukon got we got our Yukon on
um yeah and that was that was whatever
right you just trained more training
yeah and the frustration level is
everyone just going nuts like
insane the people that were getting out
like after you know as soon as a platoon
wouldn't go to
um you know Iraq or Afghanistan like
guys were getting yeah you saw it out
out here guys were getting out
immediately you know they're jumping
into black water and all these other
places
um I saw a lot of it I mean guys get out
to one one platoon because they weren't
you know because you'd hear about like
these Rangers and SF and like all these
guys are going down range and you know
you're like what I'm [__] going to
Germany to do what like yeah I just went
through Buds and sqt and it did two-year
workup and what is this for you told me
I'm like good you know maybe that was
garbage yeah and plus you have that
feeling that this whole thing's gonna be
over like really quick and I better if I
don't get it now if I don't get out and
go work for a contractor that's freaking
horrible
well how are you liking the team life
Amber
you know I didn't mind it I realized
really early on that there was a pretty
clear distinction in the wives that you
know is probably best to keep one foot
in but don't try to you know jump in
Full Throttle and don't stay completely
away I saw that there were women that
were very
angry and resentful towards their
husbands and I I felt like there were
women that were really supportive and I
always wanted to be supportive
um I also felt like you know it it was
not something that I wanted to
necessarily make my life about but I
wanted to support Marcus enough that I
knew what was going on within the
community and so it was good you know we
had two kids at that point yeah I got
pregnant with our daughter when Marcus
was in was December of 2001 right after
9 11. so
um we had two kids when he checked into
his first platoon and he was pretty much
gone all the time
so wait no no we had no I was at I was
at lead climber when you were like
nine I was overdue you got home on my
due date and then I ended up being five
days overdue but um yeah he was at lead
climber and I'm like can you tell them
that you're having a baby and he's like
no
no I can't she's literally ready to
burst and I'm yeah
it's just like it's such a you know all
the way it's the way this is the way I'm
like if you're deployed that's one thing
but you're in West Virginia I'm in
Virginia he had no no cell phones there
was one cell phone no a pay phone you
walk to
and he would call and be like have you
had the baby yet so he got home on my
due date but I ended up being a little
overdue and um yeah it was just gone all
the time it was really actually hard I
was an only child so there was part of
me that really you know I was raised an
only child so it's part of me that that
did love that Independence and didn't
need him around but it did get lonely
and I was now with two little kids away
and I was meeting wives but it was you
know there's there's just there was a
lot of like
I don't know what schools of your has
your husband been to what's your
husband's ranking I just I don't ever
I've never played that sort of like
living through getting validity through
your husband's career Marcus was always
like you know my reputation means a lot
to me and so don't ever do anything that
would embarrass me in the community like
don't risk my reputation I really
respected that yeah yeah
um my wife was due with our first kid
and my EXO who's a prime list a guy
who's an awesome guy this is at Seal
Team too
he's like so when did your baby do and I
was like oh you know like September or
something and he's like
oh when are you supposed to go on
deployment I'm like uh August something
he's like he's like you're not going I
was like yeah sir no I'm going on an
appointment he's like yeah you're not I
was like sir I'm definitely going on
deployment like I'm not I'm I'm
definitely going he's like you are
definitely not going and so he literally
said hey you can go on deployment as
soon as she has that baby and that's
what I did and I missed about a week and
a half a deployment she had the baby and
I left the next day which was
probably I mean at least I was there but
the attitude from me was just like no
it's like first baby whatever like I'm
going on deployment that's just
that's just the way it is I mean so like
for you to be like no you know uh I'm
not coming home I'm at a school right
now and I'm not coming home that's the
way it is like it's just the the normal
thing and then I remember I I told my
wife God bless her uh
she called me at work
and I don't I forget what was going on
but she called me at work and won't my
chief was like Hey Jocko your wife's on
the phone and I remember I pick up the
phone and I go what and you could tell
she was like so apologetic because it's
this I put probably put the same
freaking psycho pressure on my life that
that Marcus put on you of like don't you
know don't freaking mess don't embarrass
me and so I was like what and she's like
uh you know what and I go okay and that
wasn't like hung up like a total jerk
like I'm a total Savage uh so I'm sorry
darling about that but what I'm saying
is like that's just the normal thing
like you you just you're in the team you
all about the team everything's the
teams and
it sucks to be married to those dudes I
think in a lot of way it does but there
was also this shared sort of like
aggression if you will for lack of a
better term that I understood that he
needed to be so focused and I was just
pissed after the the attacks uh of 9 11
and I just thought like yeah get over
there and like
do whatever you do but oh yeah yeah do
it go do it just yeah I don't want to
know about it but go do it like I knew
that the teams always came first and I
accepted that because I knew that it was
a short period of our lives and
it needed to be done
so your first deployment you go to
go to Germany you're sitting over there
so why the hell are we doing this you
get back and you roll into another
platoon what's are you gonna be a 60 gun
again what's up absolutely because I
asked for it
but I think at that time they were I was
kind of more just like Kevin to 48 Mark
48 guys 46 too yeah
um so that was good we you know that was
uh my task unit was uh was Red Wing so
you know we
um
you know we worked up together we
flipped a coin uh
you know
Grievous platoon basically got to go to
Afghanistan first we go to Germany first
oh this is when we were ripping out like
halfway through to get guys more
exposure yep so literally over a coin
toss and uh so those guys went down
range and we went to you know we went to
Germany and then
you know the rest is kind of history and
once the Hilo went down we actually
deployed a week later because you know
they were a wreck
half the team's gone and the other guys
were you know not good how do you even
how did you guys get word what are you
guys doing it was terrible how we got
word
um we actually got word from from them
so here we are we're forward deployed in
Germany actual unit and we got to find
out from our spouses
that there's guys uh in full uh military
dress showing up at people's doors like
that's that's how we found out so it was
a that was a rough couple days
um it went on though I mean it was the
communication wasn't a whole lot better
back in Virginia Beach because
they were still searching for Marcus
Luttrell I know that went on for like
what almost a week
um
and you know no one knew if their
husband was on the helicopter or not and
the ones that survived weren't allowed
to call home and so it was literally
pins and needles and they weren't
hearing much more but then when the
knocks started coming
um
they were finding out
yeah I remember being on the phone with
you and you like screaming crying
because like somebody was
like somebody showed up to the door like
you were they were all you know women
were together and stuff so it was that
was like a just a shitty you know just a
shitty time I think for everybody and
then the community as you know
um didn't really didn't experience a
loss like that so it was really
difficult how people were handling it
um when those guys got back to Germany I
think they flew in a psych to like meet
with everybody for 30 minutes the first
guy went in there and didn't come out
for almost three hours so they were they
were they were gonna they gave each guy
30 minutes to talk to psyche the first
guy went in to come out for three hours
so it was just one of those things I
don't think anybody even knew how to
prepare what to do or and so it was just
a bit you know it was a bit rough for a
while but again once we got like over
that week and got our heads back
straight we were like get us over there
yesterday like why are we still sitting
here but we did we wound up within a
week we were in country and we already
we were doing our first mission like
within the first couple days so and then
what were you guys doing what was like
your mission Set uh mission was going
after different like like different
cells different Taliban cells that were
um but like larger it was almost like a
little bit different
wasn't like CT missions even though we
did like a CT op right like initially
the first stop was like a no [__] like
it's probably the coolest app ever like
you know Blackhawks come in ropes go out
you know fast rope you know charge on
the gate like boom everybody you know
like it was like a real op and then
because that was done at night it got
shut down in the whole country then got
shut down because you're not allowed to
go after bad guys at night because
that's not nice
so that's what we were dealing with in
in uh you know in Afghanistan at the
time so then we started just you know
going out to uh in the daytime
um chasing different
um different groups like in valleys and
we're working with the can stop so the
Canadians who are like men compared to
us they're [__] they look like
Vikings but they wore way too much gear
and we had to tell them to like like
dude you're going out in the mountain
for three days and you've got six nine
mil mags on your body do you think
you're gonna use six nine mil mags I
really hope you don't need to use six
nine milbacks so you know [__] like that
but um but uh so that's what we were
doing and what's your job on the platoon
um how's uh air Ops lead breacher
and so I um and then fire team leader
and
um yeah got we had a good like I would
say good good deployment
um it was it was a really spicy
deployment I mean we had uh like
multiple engagements we had our chief
got hey we got lit up by uh
Army
uh Apache which was wild because like
that was not supposed obviously it
wasn't supposed to be horrify it was a
big deal because it was it was daytime
still don't know how they didn't
recognize us uh full-on engagement like
full-on gun run not just like oh there
might be a position of what like we were
we were engaging a small group that was
engaging us and we were it was like
five of us and maybe three of them and
we were starting to bound forward like
from cover to cover and you know I
actually I was patrolling with a with a
saw so it was a little bit lighter and I
just remember just like just [__]
going off on that thing it was awesome
and then I remember hearing this deep
um like deep deep sound of just like I'm
like what the [__] is that and literally
in the middle of this little Valley and
it was it was not wide I turn around and
this Army uh this Apache is in a full-on
like front tilt gun run and I literally
thought it was a movie like you saw like
the dirt and the you know whatever that
was a 20 millimeter maybe
um it was just coming straight at me and
I'm like you know all this happened so
fast I'm like are you [__] kidding me
like we're getting engaged by our own
guys and so it's come it's tearing ass
we all dive out of the way I remember
diving behind rocks and watching my
chief do a full-on like dive like into
rocks like did not give a [__] and the
thing comes tearing through you can't
see anything because dust's everywhere
he wind up getting hit in the face
well the way they were working uh gun
runs then is that dash one would come in
and do uh 20 millimeter guns you know
what Dash 2 is coming in with next right
2.5
rockets and so I just get this rock and
I just huddle up and I'm like this is
[__] it like I may live but like I'm
gonna get [__] up I'm gonna get
fragged here because like we we've been
calling in gun runs all day long into
caves and like we get we'd get engaged
we'd pull back call in some guns move
forward that's what kind of mission it
was through the through the mountains
there and so I was just waiting I was
like huddled up I'm like oh this is it
we're gonna get I'm going to get sprayed
hopefully it's not bad like I was like
trying to cover up my face I'm thinking
like okay if I just get wounded you know
it'll be okay but just not my face or my
head
and the second one just comes tearing
through and doesn't fire anything but I
could see that I could literally see
them in the they were so low so somebody
who who uh didn't have their head up
their ass was able to move over to fires
and call it off somebody cleared them
hot I still don't know to this day and
we still talk about it because
like it was a [__] up you know it was a
bad [__] up how bad was your Chief
wounded he his whole face was like
um like you couldn't it wasn't bad bad
like but it was like
if you took a picture you almost
unrecognizable because the I guess the
frag going that fast was so fast it just
kind of blew his face up and he was like
like spitting blood a little bit but he
honestly was fine yeah yeah totally
let's be real yeah yeah 100 like you
know looking back you're like but um
yeah that was a big deal I just remember
well I think when we got back and again
I was a e but I think E5 at the time
maybe E6 you know so I was I was tucked
away but I think the leadership got in
the ass
of that unit you know over it um over at
Siege soda it was like what what
happened yeah there you know who called
first off who who cleared them hot you
know we were on the offensive it was
just a it was a total mess when I was a
young radio man I was standing out in
the desert in Fallon Nevada trying to
call in for an extract from a helicopter
two helicopters and I'm sitting there
and I'm looking they're they're like
maybe a couple hundred feet at altitude
and I I'm just standing there making
calms with them like hey you know we're
ready for extract and they couldn't see
me and I was like this is crazy I
started like waving my arms they still
can't see me and finally
uh you know I'm like I'm getting a
bearing and I'm like hey I'm right over
here to your Southwest and they just
can't see me and finally I like pop up
whatever pop of smoke and I Mark you
identifying blah blah but it showed me
that when you're in the air like things
just look so totally different
and uh they can't see [__] and they're
moving freaking 150 miles an hour and
they get told like you're cleared hot
guess what they're gonna freaking shoot
man
um because a lot of times they're saving
your ad they're saving someone's ass too
yeah and you know there's like I mean
you know all the blue and blue that was
happening just everywhere and again it's
not you know of course it's not
nefarious it just it happens just like
that yeah
um but we had uh as I'm sure you know
you did uh we were in day you know day
panels and I popped out immediately and
they're like are you [__] kidding me
guys like we can't see it yeah day panel
that's cut up out of your shoulder so
like that the lesson learned that day
forward was like no no you got to carry
a full day panel and like bust it out
you know because that's the only thing
they said that's the only thing we can
see there's no way we can see that
little thing on your shoulder
you know so uh incredible Lessons
Learned
um yeah and and so that that deployment
wraps up
um
but I mean you lost freaking so many
guys from your task good good guys yeah
a couple buds mates and yeah it was wild
I mean matter of fact right before we
deployed right after the heal well not
right after the Hilo it went down but
they flew Marcus flew back to Germany
and they're like hey you and so and so
get up to I forgot was Ramstein like go
meet him like he's [__] right now so
we we got a car went up there met him
like once he I think they they cleaned
him up once he got out of like the you
know the um
you know the ER or whatever but he was
covered in he was nasty looking and he
was like it looked like he his the all
the the wounds he had were just like
just healing it's like his face was
covered in [__] all his arms and legs
were like covered in like he looked
horrible but he was like super excited
to see us because he was yeah yeah he
thought he was gonna get his head cut
off I was uh I was the Admiral's aide
and I was just about done with that job
started to come back from Iraq and I I
became the animal Jade and so when that
was happening
I was tracking what was happening and I
remember they're like like they're
telling the Admiral hey it seems like
there's a guy that's alive
and I was like I said I was a radio mix
I was like bro they're like they have
they have his radio like this isn't I
might I didn't say this verbally but I
was thinking to myself
man they have his radio and they've
turned his radio on and they turned on
the transponder or whatever you know how
is that guy alive right now it didn't
make any sense and then by the next day
it was like no they actually have comms
and I remember thinking this is a
freaking Miracle
um how this if this guy's alive for real
and the weird thing was I I had met
the Latrell boys at a West Coast reunion
I mean and I just saw him but I remember
because they were big giant monster guys
and they're twins right which is they
just stand out corn fed Texas yeah and I
remember like me seeing them and being
like damn that's freaking legit you got
your twin brother and you're both in the
Deep it's like how cool is that and then
sure enough as I put the piece together
it's like oh [__] it's that guy it's one
of those two guys uh and man that was
horrible horrible scenario
um
I remember thinking at that time hey
this is definitely going to be made into
a film because the story was just
unbelievable and B oh [__] like bad
things can happen to Team guys like you
know you've heard of like a death or two
training accident or you know someone
died overseas but until
that helicopter went down I sort of
thought Team guys were invincible and
for the first time I remember thinking
like oh [__]
um
this might not end well and you know you
see so many of your girlfriends suddenly
become widows and
got real really quick
so what'd you do when you got home from
that deployment
we had a huge party we had a big party
invited everybody including the CEO and
I think um to this day we still talk
about that Amber bought me a Kegerator
she was kind of celebrating us coming
back and you know a few people were not
happy at that because of the you know
you know because of the Healer coming
down and guys didn't come home and those
were all our like brothers and friends
and sisters and and uh we you know
Amber's thought was I just want to
celebrate like that guys came back you
know and so we threw a party and she
bought me a keg Raider I think from
Costco and that was really cool because
I just all of a sudden I gained like 100
friends overnight like guys would just
stop by and be like hey I'm just
grabbing a beer out of your Kegerator
um but I think that night Amber had the
COS stop don't even say it no it's great
she had this he had she had the CEO's
wife doing a Kegerator but I had her
like legs up in the air she got thrown
into that on in her defense it was great
but it's still a good story because I
think I think it was E5 she's great and
he's great and they're the greatest
they're amazing uh what about career
what you what are you doing now what's
your next move from there yeah so uh
come back for my second deployment I'd
already screened for uh after my first
and they just said hey uh we're not
taking anybody after one platoon so go
you know you're good go go do one
deployment and come back and you'll be
in that next class so I was in 06 and
and you roll into that selection how was
that it was good
um again just full Focus
um you know I
you know to my surprise guys didn't
practice but like I just wanted to be
there like I wanted to be just you know
when I found out about that place I was
like yeah that's exactly what I want to
do so I trained and worked hard and
um
yeah I just I had a good CQC block and
like I was saying like like was one of
the I was the top like pistol shooter
and with the rife that's where I was
like struggling with the rifle and I
went from like they post your scores
every day your time there's no hiding
like like when you shoot like you show
up you're like Oh Marcus 57 out of 60.
like what and everyone's like oh look at
[__] bag like if you don't move up
you're out of here right and so
um I wasn't like getting the pistol
pistol is at the top but the rifle the
initial week I was really close to the
bottom and I'm like
dude this is not like I I can't that's
so weird it was weird and then to be
good at pistol yeah and not good at
rifles just weird it's weird was there
something that didn't click in your head
and then some something finally made it
click Jocko I'm still trying to figure
out what's [__]
um I don't know I I I man I I wish I
could I could say but uh I I managed to
crawl my way back in the top ten just by
like sheer you know have to as and you
would respect that like I just I had I
had to get I had to get good and I got I
got a lot better so but no I I did
really well
um
I finished that and kind of finished
Green Team and and you know they kind of
do a ranking and
um you know you're not supposed to know
but I was I guess I was chosen first
um and I went over to Squadron hung out
with our got to work for our bro that I
talked about earlier I don't know if
you'd care if we say his name on here or
what but I say don't say his name okay
yeah
um but yeah it was uh everything
that I thought uh probably actually more
and and a lot of stuff that I didn't
expect
um for sure and probably Amber will tell
you like
life's just got weird ER after that so
now you start knocking out deployments
yeah um what's the cycle that you're in
every year so we were deploying every
year sometimes twice no but at the time
it was six on and then three six on it
was three yes three month deployment six
six six six pack yep three going three
three training three on standby three
gone three training and then on standby
you know flyways
um
and um it was good again but it was away
way more than even
um
than and even at the teams where are
your uh deployments to
um Paul Assad uh
uh you know Bagram
uh so both Iraq yeah both yep and you're
bouncing back and what what's your um
what's your job
uh there's also a preacher there
um
yeah I mean that's that's exactly that's
all I did
um I loved it and I was um I did a lot
of the combatives so it was that split
at the time where it was like
sport Fighters and combatives and
combative guys hate sport Fighters and
Sport Fighters think combative guys are
gay and you know it was like that thing
going on you know and I thought it was
funny but I do tell the story
um because I trained every morning I
went in we had um you know coochie had
his guys every day and so I'd go in for
two hours and train I never trained at
at a at a gym just because we after work
I went home
um but I did train every day and there
was one day I was um I had a guy in a
full Mount and I was trying to figure
out a way to to put a like a like a
collar like some kind of Choke with you
know and I was trying to grab his collar
and then it like stopped and I looked at
him I'm like what the [__] are we doing
why am I trying to choke you why aren't
I like why am I like hitting you put my
knee on your chest like get up and go to
my sidearm or pull out something and
sticky with it or just like push you and
get away and
from there I was like you know I'm not
doing any more sport fighting I just
like I just want to know how to like
just like pound pound or you know gouge
your eye out or just like stick you in
the gut with a knife and just get the
[__] out of here and and then like I
started more moving into the camp of
like the combative side of the house and
then of course you had people saying
well no if you're a better sport fighter
that'll transition it's like the
skydivers like if you Skydive slick
forever no I could any of those guys
could strap on a heavy Rock and you know
so it was just anyway it was back and
forth and
I don't know I digress where where are
we going on that one
I loved all of it how about that it was
you know I um but so okay my you asked
me what I was doing I was a breacher and
I did you know I did a lot of command
stuff that's and I climbed and and Amber
what's what's life like for you now now
he's gone even more I was way more
settled so that's actually when I met
around that time is when I met Sarah
Wilkinson
um and our life was very centered around
the command and
um you know other command members
command families we all sort of you know
worked out together hung out together
weekends together with the kids it's
Sports and pool parties and birthdays
and you know it was it was um very
tight-knit
and one of the one of the things that I
remember so much about when Sarah was
talking through you know her experience
with Chad
was
like he left such an impression on me
she's just talking about like this
personality change that she saw from him
over time and you know it
that were you seeing that kind of thing
for Marcus at this point were you seeing
was he getting withdrawn was he you know
short fused was he it's you know it
sounded like what what Chad was doing
was more like the withdrawn thing and
you know she was like look he wasn't
like the most talkative guy in the world
but all of a sudden like she noticed
that he was different yeah and then
before you even go like and and so I I
worked with Chad he was one of my recog
guys and I never like he was
smiling happy joking and again this is
right when he he showed up there yeah
it's in 2008 so he was still like
just back from
being out in the private sector for a
number of years and so like he was I
feel like he was still like Giddy and
just hey Life Is Life is Chill it's good
it's
you know nothing's really taking me down
at least that's how I remember him if
you know if we go back to the examples
that I already gave of Marcus with you
know our son crawling all over him and
showing up with the picked geraniums
like he was still very much into being a
husband and a dad and even in his first
and second platoons
um you know with Maggie's birth
he was there work came first but he was
there what we Transit transitioned into
was living completely separate lives and
so he would come home and he would say
things like hey where are your cups
you know in his own home that he was
paying for
and we would get everything looking
perfect because you would be home for
five days which you know is pretty
typical between trips
um anything more than that was a pretty
long time but
it he had we had become distant and I
had become you know way more rooted in
my friends and my life and my kids and
it was okay that we lived Separate Lives
because the ladies that I was around and
their children were living that same
life and so there was this shared
respect and sacrifice that no one else
understood but the people in your inner
circle knew without having to even talk
about and so as he was becoming more and
more distant
um
I guess you just sort of chalk it up to
that's how things are now
and do you actually notice it or is it
like the proverbial like boiling of a
frog where it's just like it the frog
doesn't know that the water's getting
hot until it's all of a sudden it's dead
it's too it's too slow is it like that
kind of thing where I think so you're
just going through and it's like oh yep
he's going on another trip and oh it's
another trip and yeah um he's back but
he's you know going to sleep or I don't
want to bother him that type of thing
over time yeah like we could play nice
for those five-day spans where the house
looked perfect and then the kids behaved
perfect and he was
as present as he could be but it became
a lot more comfortable to live
separately and um
you know it was all in the name of
the United States of America it was all
for the greater good and it it felt like
when he would come home he would
certainly be more checked out like he
couldn't wait to leave again like I
could sense that and family time felt
like forced time especially at the
command so
um
yeah it was getting really hard he was
getting certainly pulling away more
drinking more
he felt like a stranger
how much are you drinking at this point
normal Mouse uh by team standard but by
our standards by the Bros standards
um
yeah I think we just
man we just
we just went around a rabbit hole I mean
we
I think I was just drinking a lot of
bourbon often
um but I never really knew that because
it wasn't with him that much yeah but
even when I came home like it was
I didn't know like what his drinking
habits were because we were really never
together I mean
the last couple years that you were
deploying he was gone for almost 300
days a year like
you know I think it's pretty toxic I
mean we're all everyone's doing the same
thing everyone's drinking hard
everyone's I think going through the
same things some are affected probably
more than others and
I didn't say anything wrong
you didn't see anything wrong at what
point did you at what point did you
start to see something wrong um
2008 yeah I think 2008 Josh
yeah Josh uh one of my close best
friends from from Buds and then through
the teams uh passed on a on a op
um and that was just unexpected and that
was like a river and stream crossing
right yeah and
um it was just it was tough because I
was um I was supposed to do that River
and stream Crossing
um and
we um when when he got swept down the
river we
I think we looked for him for almost
it's like 10 to 12 hours
um and then he he washed out 50 clicks
down uh Kona which was like a you know
class four rabbits it was it was nasty
it was gnarly
um so just you know seeing him kind of
get get pulled out of the water is like
really it's not not good
um not good and uh
myself and another individual
um took his body back to his uh his
family in North Carolina and we stayed
there a week and then we were there is
when um Jason and Dusty got killed like
a couple days later
um
uh direct fire if both of them got shot
and of course we were supposed to be on
that op and uh it was just you know it
was just you know you went through it
Jaco and it was just one of those times
that was uh
it was uh you know I tried to look at it
as like though this is what it's
supposed to be like this is just the way
it happens and I became numb after a
while
um you know even when extortion went
down I remember talking to
Scott Moore I'm a more about it I was
like Admiral I'm [__] numb to this
like this doesn't affect me anymore like
I don't just I don't get it like why is
this still happening and it was just we
it's just the conversations we were
having I think through these years were
just getting
just odd and um I think I remember
seeing this the psych for the first time
in 08 at the command just like asking
them like
what's what's going on can you you know
help me out a little bit or whatever and
um
that was like the first time I ever
actually went and spoke to somebody but
if we didn't talk about it like nobody
talked about it maybe but he also has
we have his medical record and I was
just looking through it and it says like
um
you know decided not to talk to the
command psych for fear of not being able
to deploy which is the you need to hear
all the time I don't even remember I
don't remember that
yeah so I was certainly noticing that he
just it seemed like he was just like a
renegade to me he did not care he did
not care and those deployments were so
insane it's like someone was dying every
deployment and so it felt like Russian
Roulette and
I just
between Josh and 2008 and then there
were you know other deaths that weren't
so close to us and then Adam Brown dying
in 2010 who were very very close with
Adam and his family and our kids best
friends at the time
I was just like this is nuts
we can't do this anymore yeah and so it
got got to a point where I just felt
like I had to do something different I
wasn't like fully fully checked in and
um again talking to the Admiral he's
like you should go to OCS he's like you
should be an officer I'm like I just I
need a break right now bad
he's like now you just go to CS you're
gonna be a good officer and so I went to
OCS for like two days
oh yeah didn't you have to put like a
package oh yeah I did [__] all this
[__] I did you even passed up being
promoted to Chief so someone else could
have it because he thought he was going
to I didn't I went in I went in and
talked to the uh yeah the CMC at the
time said don't make me achieve I said
make so-and-so a chief because I'm you
know I'm gonna go to OCS like why would
you make me a chief and I'm yeah like
you're going to take it away from
somebody so they didn't then they made
him Chief and and uh and I went to a CS
so you knew what you were getting into
with this not no obviously I did because
no I didn't I didn't honestly like I
didn't I was not um I wasn't thinking
clearly let me ask you this when you
went and talked to the psychologist yeah
what do you say what do they say
they have like a you know they have
their standard list of
like sop you know like what what's how's
your home life you know how is your
family you're like oh my wife is great
my kids are great it's fine like what
are you are you drinking yeah yeah a
little bit but you know normally what
you know what the guys are doing nothing
you know like it's it's very
um vanilla right it's very templated and
I think you know obviously we'll talk
about the route that I went eventually
when when I separated but
um I think that's the problem is like I
go to school and they try to solve a
problem in this box that they're taught
but everybody's different like you're
different than me and I'm different from
her like they can't use a standardized
template to I think it's also like a
check in the box like you know it's
actually called the 30 minute checkup
from a neck up right oh is it oh wait is
this like a like they say hey did you
get ordered to go do this this is a
starter part of the standard operating
procedure okay you're back from three
deployments you gotta go check in with
the psych is that what I don't know and
then you give the answers you know that
you think will probably get them off
your back yeah let me let me figure out
what I have to say yeah so they're not
life is fine kids are great I'm ready to
deploy yeah I'm good and so is that what
you did you go in there because you said
you were a little you were starting to
feel it a little bit did you expose that
at all when you talked to this this
doctor I don't know or not really I
don't think so I don't even remember
I'm not sure I just remember I just
remember him telling me Marcus you guys
aren't crazy he's like but your wives
he's like they're freaking nuts well it
is crazy I mean like I literally like of
all the conversations that's what I
remember he's like Marcus I don't think
you guys are crazy he's like but I do
think your wives are crazy I'm like all
right doc whatever whatever you say I'm
on board so that's kind of crazy that
you went in there you're feeling like
something's not right but you still get
like an up check to go to OCS by the way
that it was the the reason I went to OCS
is because I believed in
the Admiral I believe in my Skipper like
that's the only thing again I don't want
to let him down at all and so he's all
fired up so fired up he's all fired up
he's like hell yeah he's always fired up
I love him yeah for sure and so he tells
you no you're gonna be a great officer
yes he's OCS and you're like I'm like
Roger that it made sense on paper for
sure
but I remember telling my close friends
like
like no like my very close friends was
like like I can't at the airport I can't
do this right now like I can't I'm not
good he's like no bro you gotta go like
you're gonna regret this I'm like no you
don't understand like I I can't like I'm
not good he's like Marcus you got to get
what do you mean by not good like I was
just not I was not into it anymore like
I was not mentally
like focused or determined or like
driven or like any of it like I just
didn't
didn't want to be there were you seeing
this Amber I was but I was also in a
complete tailspin because we just needed
to we needed to change the scenery I
just needed like a calm in the storm to
reassess so you can like survive like a
tornado for example it's much easier to
survive than it is to like survey the
damage I was in complete survival mode
and so it seemed like okay well this is
something that could get me to the other
side to survey the damage that's a good
metaphor so you're like in the storm
shelter you there's this Mayhem going
you're okay in the shelter but you know
at some point you got to get out of this
thing you got to get somewhere safe yeah
yeah and then once the storm is over
like you know you think about like any
natural disaster we lived in on the East
Coast hurricanes like preparing and
surviving the hurricane isn't the hard
part the hard part is cleaning up all
the mess on the other side and so I knew
we needed to get to a place where we
could start cleaning up the mess but you
just you're in such survival mode that
you don't even know what that looks like
and so for me OCS sort of like checked
that box it was a different change of
scenery and in my mind Marcus always
needed a goal his goal was to get a
scholarship to become a sealed to get to
the command this was just the natural
next goal
I didn't know that he was so depleted
mentally that he didn't have the
willpower to care about the goal and it
was the first time that I had ever seen
him
not care about a goal that's what I was
going to ask you because you're
describing a mess right but at the same
time you're both also kind of like you
know the kids are doing good you're
weird no we're doing everything so was
there some like under I'm the reason I'm
asking you these this question or this
line of questioning is because if
someone is a wife and they're looking at
their husband what are they looking for
and how do they go oh you know what I
see I know what this is
I I understand what's happening there's
a loss of motivation did you see
behaviors was there anything that you
said this is not Marcus is not in a good
spot right now
yeah yeah I mean there were certain I
just felt like he was Reckless I felt
like he was a complete Renegade he just
didn't care and so for me OCS was a way
to dial it back in
give him some direction and focus
because like I mean he didn't cut his
hair for nine months he he was drinking
and then like the RSO the next day like
drinking till 4am then the RSO at eight
like it to me it was just sort of like
very atypical behavior for him
um maybe not necessarily of the teams
but he was so laser focused that the
sudden sort of renegade attitude was
definitely alarming at the same time I
never saw him so it was probably 10
times worse than I knew
OCS two days yes
because I went to OCS I know and I can't
imagine uh he'd come back from
deployment like literally a week or two
prior
I [__] hate it I showed up and you
know you have all the Marines and
yelling and [__] and you have like a
rack like this and they're like [__] is
this guy and uh I honestly I might have
lasted a day and a half I remember
sitting first off I was getting
migraines they gave me they got me
ibuprofen six hours after I I was
[__] hurting and then I remember
sitting on the floor my back was killing
me I had all types of like [__] going on
with my my uh my my L4 and L5 and I'm
like trying to read the uh was it 11
General Orders of the century like I'm
trying to I'm trying to uh you know
trying to memorize them and I remember
taking the book and throwing it across
the room and I'm like hey who's in
charge here like in a very nice way
oh the sentences like can I speak to him
please uh yeah sure I was like Hey sir
here's the deal I was like I just got
back from my six combat deployment I was
like I got back a week and a half ago
I'm like
and I didn't curse I was like why are if
I have to go to OCS like why are you
guys sending me with people who like
never been here before like I don't want
to be around any of these people like
honestly I was like I just want to go
back to my unit he's like you know we
usually keep guys here for 12 weeks he's
like you can go tomorrow I'm like thank
you and I did that it was dude that's
insane it was I was like what am I doing
I'm like I'm learning how to fold my
underwear again are you kidding me and I
remember going back and and telling
Admiral I was like Hey I was like if you
want good people to like stay in you
guys got to figure out this OCS thing
after guys are going over to see us to
war for 10 or 15 years like come on like
that's just you're gonna you're gonna
get more people like me that are like
[__] this or they hear about what OCS is
and instead of going through the whole
process of sending their packet in
they're just going to hear about it and
go there's no chance because that's what
I've told I talked to a bunch of people
when I got back they were like oh yeah
you didn't know that uh they're like
that's why I didn't go I was like how
can you go deal with that for another 12
weeks after all the other [__] they're
like so I didn't they go but there's
this workaround and if you if you become
a
it's like if you go and Reserve you go
to like a fork and knife school for like
four weeks you get pinned and then you
go back on active duty like they they
decide to tell me that's help them out
yeah
but he honestly like he knew
intuitively you knew you shouldn't have
there was no chance he called from the
airport he called me and he called his
best friend and I think I said like
you've got to listen to your gut and he
just ended up pushing through and
getting on the plane and going but from
the day I showed up I'm like what am I
I'm not what am I doing here yeah that's
this is [__] the last place I want to
be boot camp welcome like so ridiculous
yeah it was good so they sent you right
back to the command yeah and they
usually keep it out process they keep
people in holding stuff like 12 12 or 13
weeks at OCS and yeah they let me go
like the next day and what did what did
like the commands like the detailer say
they were just like what you know
because that's bizarre dude like get a
Billet oh it's hard to get a bill to OCS
I know I did have to apologize to
Admiral he's like hey I'm like I know I
was like I know
um
but he was I also think he was on the uh
would the committee that
that selected you yeah well I'm sure he
had a lot of pull whatever his position
was yeah for sure but in hindsight it's
like who ever thought that that was a
good idea anyway
um but yeah so I went back and they were
like hey what do you need to do I said I
just you know there's someone out there
right now going see OCS is so hard
just gotta quit
that's it I Quit
um yeah so I just told him I said hey I
need I just need a break because
wherever that is
um I said I was thinking maybe maybe go
out to the West Coast and just forget
about stuff and like yeah that's fine go
do it
that's what we did so I went went out to
uh yeah I went to the center and wanted
to teach tactics and they threw me in
first phase which is like the worst
place they could have put me and it was
not good like I was
and as you know all the guys are are
awesome like good dudes all of them been
overseas hard hard-nosed dudes like
great workers I didn't want to be around
anybody I was like I don't want to make
friends with anybody they probably
thought I was like standoffish because
like I didn't want to hang out with
anybody
um it was just it was just not a good
time I um I body slammed a student in
front of the flagpole and like one of
the one of the instructor staff grabbed
me and he was like Hey man he's like
you're gonna get in a lot of trouble if
you don't [__] like tone it down like
I don't know what's going on and so
there was just a lot of little things
like that that were starting to happen
and
um I just didn't care I was like you
know [__] everybody uh you know at the
time one of my guys uh JP DaNell who's
been on this podcast a few times and he
was um he was in my task unit it was in
ramadi came back went to another platoon
and then they got shoulder surgery and
got pulled out and they sent him to Buds
and it was like one month deep they
called me over at Trader and they're
like you gotta come get your boy it was
the same thing he was just not in a good
head space to be put in
students through you know first phase
because you just wasn't in the right
spot you know like had to get him out of
there and get some freaking you know he
was a loose cannon
um
you're working for how long are you in
first phase for first phase for a year
and then finally they they kicked me
over to the sqt No No you're sitting
here saying like I don't want to be
around anybody I didn't want to make
friends with anybody what do you see in
Amber like what does this look like to
you duck at home with him
and we had been apart for the the bigger
part of every year leading into this and
so it was
very very very difficult I know I was
trying to be optimistic we are super
settled in Virginia Beach and so I'm
like oh a new beginning I bought
cruisers for everyone I thought we would
come out to California and suddenly be
this happy family and when we got here
everything just completely hit the fan
because I didn't have my community
anymore and we started every single
morning at Sarah Wilkinson's gym
CrossFit Odyssey at the time it's a core
group of girls and um my kids had their
friends we had an amazing neighborhood a
great house and suddenly we're in
California we don't know anyone and now
Marcus is home and the kids you know
like our son in particular
had this sort of idea of who Marcus was
in his mind she's sort of like this myth
of a dad and
um you know he he really didn't know him
and I think that whenever we what the
dad that he got delivered back was
nothing like the dad that he had created
in his mind at the time and so he
started acting out like everything was
going bad
and um
I don't know I just it's it's hard for
me to like picture this right now
because you seem like a super chill dude
like all nice and mellow and like so
what like what does this look like he'd
become a monster first of all he was a
completely disconnected to us it felt
like he didn't want to be
anywhere really I mean it didn't I
didn't feel like he wanted to be
anyplace else I felt like he wanted to
be in nowhere like he didn't have a
purpose a belonging uh he didn't give a
damn about anything
um
he was definitely drinking a lot a lot
more than I had realized or he started
drinking more than you know he was
comfortable with and um
and there were certainly times that
I was
I I just thought there's no good way out
of this leaving him is not going to
necessarily solve anything staying with
him I don't know how much worse this can
get
um yeah but just to go back Jacko like I
was still like I was still functioning
like I was still
you know engaging with the guys I mean I
had you know I had Bros and stuff but
but I was I didn't want to it wasn't it
wasn't fun for me anymore I didn't want
to be one of the guys and
um you know it was just not just wasn't
the same it was just it was it was
different you know and thank God I got
kicked over to sqt
um so I ran CQC for about a year and a
half and a great staff I mean those guys
you know I joke because we had a great
sub I feel like those guys did
everything I'm like I was like I didn't
even need to be there like literally the
lpo from I mean they just they ran the
show and so thank goodness I was just
kind of in the background just I think I
started school online yeah USD I did a
graduate program there so we would you
know work the students in sqt and then
at night we'd put him to bed and then I
would stay up and you know do work and
stuff and so you know it wasn't like
um
it wasn't like a complete mess you know
like I think yeah everything was like I
was functioning yeah it wasn't you know
I don't want to sit here and say like
you know he was like stuck in the corner
of his house sucking on his thumb every
day no no no he's still functioning yeah
still going to work but like you just
didn't care like you just checked out
check out everything you do well without
a goal and uh you know something to work
towards and so
going back to get his master's degree
while he was at sqt it was definitely
like a check in the box and then
I think at some point oh well then the
bin Lon raid happened
which I kind of lost my mind on that one
just not being there
it's like you like put me in the put me
in coach there was like this big sort of
like Resurgence of let's get back to
Virginia Beach and if I did I called it
the CMC I was like Hey I want to come
back he's like done come back
and then I just kind of faded quickly
well no it was replaced I mean that was
our plan was to go back and then
extortion happened and you know so many
more of our friends died and then it was
like what are we going to go back to to
that same game of Russian Roulette
um you know we just didn't know each
other anymore and it was very
uncomfortable to be in the house he was
learning how to be around the kids the
kids were very uncomfortable like how
does Dad fit back into this Dynamic and
so we thought like at the time we know
dysfunction we know deployments we know
not being together
um we don't know how to be a normal
family I don't know what families do on
the weekends I don't know how a family
spends a Friday night
um but I know how to be a single mom and
so rushing back into that dysfunction
was the safest thing
at the time which was replaced by a big
thought reality slap of oh extortion
just happened
we're gonna go back to the Russian
Roulette do we really want to do that
and so that's at that point he decided
let me just get out of the military all
together no you missed a whole bunch oh
my turn you missed you missed something
what
um that's when I went to speak to OIC
from sqt and I was like hey I'm like I'm
not you know there's something not right
like I'm not doing well he's like why
don't you go speak to the the I don't
know if it was a West Coast dive medical
officer or whatever they call so I went
over there and it was a psych and just
started telling them about what's going
on
he said Marcus
um he's like first off you're not you're
definitely not the only one that's come
in here he's like matter of fact he goes
I can't even count the number of guys
that have come in here now over the last
couple months
um and they have literally given me the
same exact story and he goes I don't
know what it is but he's like you guys
are all experiencing the same exact
thing and he said so this is what I'm
going to do and I think he's I think I
got prescribed a you know a uh an SSRI
or snri first time
and I guess that was supposed to
stabilize mood
and then I got sent to Niko and I came
back with like four more medications
from the Nico you know Niko Clinic out
in which I thought that was actually a
pretty good place
but they do a lot of they do a lot of
checking and giving you drugs and they
don't do a whole lot of in my opinion
healing
when you go and you tell this doctor
something's not right how do you
describe
something's not right like what does
that sound like again I'm looking at
this from a perspective of yeah it's a
first responder a firefighter a police
officer or somebody in the military
that's what what are you tracking that
they should be paying attention to
um I think the one of the biggest is
lack of motivation or like lack of
purpose you feel like
nothing matters anymore at all like what
am I doing this for like I don't even
care
and you're like well what do you care
about well I used to like to surf or
work out I could give a [__] about
surfing or working out or I used to like
to go you know do x y and z
I don't even here we'll give you two
weeks to do that
now how about I just sit sit in my house
and watch TV and drink bourbon because I
don't have to think about anything and I
can numb myself and so I would say to
the people out there listening it's
you're going to start to see that you're
becoming less motivated to do things
of things that you really enjoyed in the
past and that's I think one of the
biggest signs that that right there is a
Telltale sign
stuff you really enjoy doing when it
comes to like a screeching halt like go
talk to somebody for sure
you know and I don't know if that's now
depression kicking in or now if you want
to call it like PTSD or anxiety or like
you know now we're getting into the
science of it and I don't know also like
is this a is this a chemical thing
because right now that that study that
just came out said yeah it's not it's
not a chemical thing right so now it's
like okay well what's what's going on in
your life that you can't get out of bed
in the morning like you don't want to go
to work you don't want to answer your
text messages so it's really just like a
lack of just like
like if you just like slumped your
shoulders down and just like
not gave a [__] anymore that's that's
really the there was also a lot of anger
irritability
um I think those are all the things that
that are part of it so like you you
become this person that doesn't want to
do anything and then you do snap or you
throw mugs through the window or you
choke out the bartender at the Country
Club you know and stupid [__] that all
these things have happened by the way
that you probably shouldn't be doing
um
there's like a weird uh I don't know
that's the wrong word but
when
you're oh when you're living your life
and everything's like like you're saying
you got goals you got things that you
want to do and you got a long-term
vision and you got kids
and when people die
that you know that are your friends
and then
there's this like there's there's this
thing of like well
they're gone
and the world is still going
and
what is what what is any of this [__]
mean
of oh
my friend was this awesome guy
and now he's dead and we're I'm still
going to you know morning muster
well
what is what are we doing here
and I I think that sort of thing you
know because you start getting like an
existential
thought of
this life is the most important thing
but now oh you you lost a bunch of
friends and we're still here and we're
going on but we're gonna end up where
they are and this is the way things are
going it's like seems like that could
lead to
well I might as well just watch TV I
might as well just sit here and drink
bourbon I might as well just do nothing
because
this is where we're heading this is
where we're all heading I don't know
again this is just like I'm thinking out
loud as I'm hearing you describe
uh
uh you know where your headspace was
um and especially when you're sort of
get detached and you get put into a
different environment where you don't
have the same friends and you don't have
the same like crew of families that
you're with and
um you know one thing I can say about
losing guys in combat was like you lose
guys in combat and you're with all your
friends and then you're gonna go do more
stuff in combat and you don't really
that feeling of what are we doing here
actually the opposite happens you now
know why you're here like we're gonna go
and we're gonna make things happen we're
gonna go do our best We're Gonna Stand
Tall like you're gonna go do all those
things so it's sort of the opposite you
get juice no you get Juiced up yeah no I
think you get fired up like you want to
go do that a hundred percent and then in
the environment you're talking about
without a doubt I mean like I said after
that even went down like I couldn't we
couldn't even we were screaming why are
we still sitting here like why isn't it
why in the helicopter land right next to
us put us on there and send us over
there to to go to go get Redemption
right and then when you don't have that
outlet anymore
and then you're looking around and
you're saying like oh
well why am I even gonna get out of bed
this morning
yeah I think you know what you're
describing you know someone told me once
and I kind of laugh at it but it makes
sense he's like Marcus I'm not sure he's
like he's like definitely definitely
dudes have this PTSD but he's like I
think they have what they call
uh LSD lack of uh unless he is yeah lack
of stress disorder he's like I feel like
we have to be in chaos and once that
chaos stops is when our [__] like
unravels and I said you know I was like
I get that and I said I feel that
they're definitely that's part of it but
there's got to be part of something else
like why is everyone and not everyone
but why are there so many experiencing
the same exact thing you know I don't
never tell you that I and I'll still to
this day sometimes fight it that you
know
like you I loved going overseas I loved
going to war I think that stuff is great
I think it it it it makes you grow like
it makes you makes you better
um you know maybe it was some stuff that
happened younger then maybe some wartime
stuff then maybe some transition stuff
like you said like where I wasn't around
some people and then maybe some of the
family stuff that wasn't working and
then maybe the concoction of all these
[__] medications that they put me on
said you're going to get better if you
take this and I'm going to believe you
because you're a doctor you're telling
me this is going to be good
um you know then you get out and then
you're in the private sector then you
don't have any of that
at all so maybe just all that together
is a recipe for it's a perfect storm we
found ourselves right in the middle of a
perfect storm I have never taken any um
like drugs or anything uh don't yeah
like so so even when I hear that and I
but I've I've you know there's been a
bunch of
um data and information about them what
they're like and what they do and you
know people you get on all these what
are they called psychosomatic drugs is
that what they are they're uh I mean
there's a yeah there's a bunch of them
some are supposed to like help you
release some serotonins or you're like
happier and others are supposed to like
stabilize your mood you know but then
the problem is once you start taking
those then I don't know all of a sudden
you're feeling a little tired or you
can't focus so now they give you some
provincial individuals so you can focus
but now those medicines are causing
migraines and I'm like hey I can't sleep
now so like oh here you ever heard of
Ambien I'm like yeah I was on them for
six years while I was deploying but no
you need this or maybe it won't give you
Ambien we'll give you the other one
that's not as like it's just a it's a
constant cycle he did he was on no
prescription until the year that he's
getting out of the Navy and like between
that time and you know a couple years
after he had 10 prescriptions he's on
zero today and Amber I got prescribed my
first at Niko I know from that from the
from the psych and then from Niko they
prescribed me four medications because I
was just looking at my medical records
it's crazy and then once we went into
all this I think it was on seven we get
on average you know uh what we're doing
on the nonprofit the average is seven to
eight medications at one time we have
people coming to us these are Team guys
over 20 medications that they're on not
that they're like hey I want to be on
this that they're being prescribed say
here you're [__] up like you should
take these like who prescribed somebody
over 20 medications that's like he seems
insane insane to me it's insane and you
know no look I I have friends that are
psychologists and they've explained to
me that there's like certain things like
there's certain times that certain
people need certain things and like it
really helps them
but um damn like seven prescriptions for
some stuff that makes you stay awake and
focused and then give you something else
that's gonna make you sleep I
I'm not a rocket scientist or a
psychologist my damn self but that
doesn't seem like a great
thing yeah probably it's the go-to it's
the number one tool in the toolbox at
least if you are being treated by
military medicine or the VA if you can't
write a prescription for it or talk to a
therapist about it they got nothing for
you I think the best research that came
out recently is that they said uh if you
get your heart rate up go for a run go
on the mat
the actual research is showing that
that's better than this these
antidepressants that they've been giving
us for 35 years and that's why I think
now these antidepressants are like
there's a lot of bad [__] coming out
about them like there's no like every
press you read about them now is is not
good so I think they're slowly going
away yeah well I
never stopped working out and never
stopped training Jiu Jitsu like maybe
that's maybe that's it dude I don't know
probably the best thing at least well I
understand you can do but I still think
not for everybody right so I still think
there's certain individuals that
probably need something yep but you know
when they just came out and said hey
going for a run getting your heart rate
up
is better than these like we should we
should take we should take that on board
because like most of America is sitting
from the computer for 12 hours a day
they're wondering why they're angry or
they're depressed you know just a little
bit of uh you know operating heart rate
increase activity you'll help and you
throw booze into the mix right because
like how good is that for you you got
seven meds nine meds 12 meds and you're
drinking like and not working out as
much so
so you you decide that you're going to
get out and how many years do you have
it at this point 12 12 and you decide
all right I'm gonna go do something else
I'm like I just want to run away at that
point I literally just wanted to run
and you what do you thinking Amber
well I should have learned from OCS that
big dramatic changes are probably not
the best but at the time I thought
I don't want to go back to the Russian
Roulette and I know Marcus needs a goal
and he probably feels like you know
leaving the command and becoming an
instructor is going you know not
necessarily going in a goal-oriented
direction and so maybe having a career
is the next best goal he just graduated
he had he got a his master's degree and
um
I went with it dude only freaking team
guy could be going like on all these
drugs and drinking and still get their
master's degree that wasn't [__]
it's like that's so ridiculous I told
people I was the best when I wasn't
thinking like if I could just go if you
could just wind me up and go I'm fine
but as soon as I stopped for half a
second is when when she comes tumbling
down that's insane dude so little did I
know that I was actually like stepping
into like the you know the perfect
perfect storm we were living in a pretty
bad one by The Perfect Storm was
childhood trauma War trauma head trauma
transition trauma family trauma loss of
purpose loss of paycheck loss of
community loss of
identity and he wanted to get so far
away from the military and the teams
that he went into banking
what was what was pushing you away from
the freaking teams
hi no idea no clue if I had to guess
just anger like anger at and probably
wasn't the teams it was just anger of
like everything because you know
what it's like when you like see one of
your teen guy friends that you haven't
seen in a while and you're just super
stoked like I remember I got back from
my last opponent I was working a trade
at dude I worked at trade out you know
so this different team guys go every day
was like a reunion every day like yeah
just like oh hey like every day was like
that I know I mean my freaking
kids will say to me my oldest daughter
right now she'll say to me like why
don't you just go back in I'm always
like well I can't really go back here
and I'm like an old guy now why don't
you just go back in so what was that
just not there anymore were you feeling
like you know you see your friends and
you're like I don't
yeah I don't care I don't care
yeah it was just you know jock it was
just like a
no I don't I don't know how to describe
it it was completely numb inside yeah he
feels like that now that's what I'm
saying it was a period of time when the
Hilo went down like I had this weird
conversation with the Admiral I was just
like
I'm numb this is not even affecting me
anymore like I don't get it he's like
yeah but this hurts I'm like yeah it
hurts but I'm I just don't
it's not even registering it's just so
this is this is when we see like there's
some like to me now like okay there's
something there's something wrong
there's something going on in here like
for a team guy to to not
like be kind of stoked to see their
friends like I just remember my whole
life I would go to work and just be
stoked like there's never a day where I
was like okay I'm bummed out to go to
work today every day was just awesome
and fun and gonna see my friends and
we're gonna hang out we're gonna shoot
some [__] and like
thank God I always had that feeling you
know I always had that feeling so this
is what tells me like again going back
to Chad
and hearing Sarah describe this change
in his
personality you know and that's what I
the only thing that I could imagine
that could cause like like it has to be
something else that's causing you to get
in this mode of
uh you know oh there's freaking
four guys that I haven't seen in five
years and I went to buds with him or I
was at a platoon with them or whatever I
think you would someone have been like
that though yeah but I also used to want
to run and high too remember that like I
never wanted to go back to Virginia
Beach I didn't want to see anybody
and I
also like you know
he sort of had he was at this Pinnacle
of what he wanted for his career and the
teams and so to leave that and go to a
new place was hard you know it'd be like
transferring coasts for anybody when
you're making all new friends or
being out here the vibe I mean obviously
we love it here we're here now
um but the vibe here versus the East
Coast was very different and that people
are a lot more spread out here so we
were by ourselves in a neighborhood far
away from other military families and um
I just didn't feel like people really
got it and so
I think that he got to this place of
being so numb and not really caring
after the transition but it was very
hard to go back to Virginia Beach but I
hear you now because like we live in
Coronado and I love it because I get to
see like my Bros like guys that are
contractors they come in I'm like hey
what's going on you know so it's good
now it's but now it's different I mean
obviously a different place I guess the
thing that I'm trying to say is like you
can
it's like the freaking check engine
light in a car like to me that's a check
engine light in the car of like
just about every team guy you know like
when they see other team guys they're
stoked I remember one of my buddies was
uh stationed up in up in Germany in
North Germany with the coms Farmers he
was up there he was up there for three
years
and I went up to see him one time when I
was in Germany
and like he was because he'd been not
these were around Kick-Ass badass comps
from guys which is awesome and they're
great they're studs
and but man when he saw me it was like
he was he couldn't stop smiling go bro
he's I was like bro you're so happy he
goes bro it's so good he goes it's so
good to see you and it's so good to
speak English
so for me to like sit here and think
about that I'm thinking
there must be like some there's
something wrong with the engine like
there's a chat that's a check engine
light yeah the real check engine light
uh is coming on and and and then you
tell me all these other things like that
list you just rattled off of all these
things that are going on Amber you're
like oh loss of this lost that change
this change of this you know
yeah you can't outrun it whenever you're
processed out and you're a civilian at
all comes Crashing Down
for so many and we were one of
one of those cases where we couldn't
outrun it anymore and um yeah I mean if
you're good you're good so you know you
I think if you get out and everything is
tracking and there's no check engine
light and you maybe go through some
transition whatever but
you're fine
but if you're not you know I like that I
like that analogy I may use that and I'm
gonna steal that from you you can yeah
of course you can
Sarah describes Chad as like a light
going out and I certainly would have
described Marcus the same like because
the light in him completely went out and
um
but over time you just start to
like sort of like justify it or
rationalize it in your head like well
like I mean I guess that's how things
are now and they're kind of all like
that and you know just you just
rationalize it and you try to handle it
but like the level of suffering that you
guys can endure is so
great it's terrifying well this is how
you get a dude that's like going through
all this and getting his master's degree
like that's right such a good example of
I'll just suck it up like I'll just suck
it up and just do this stupid assignment
you know you're a grown ass man you're
getting told by someone to write a paper
and you're like cool give me the
freaking computer let's rock and roll
yeah yeah so um so you decide you're
gonna get out what kind of plan do you
have like where are you gonna get money
from
did you already get a job did you get a
job no I got I mean I was yes yeah so I
was lucky enough I had
um I had a mentor and you know and
Mentor connected me to some folks and so
I did like a New York City Tour met a
lot of different people that met a lot
of people in banking and some other
stuff and then got introduced to a lot
of West Coast folks and just kind of
went out there and figured out what's
next so I you know I consider myself
lucky there
um that I got to I got to meet a lot of
people and kind of figure out what I
wanted to do so I had a choice really I
had a choice and so you got you actually
got a job lined up before you got out
yep which is freaking amazing because
sometimes guys don't realize that they
get a paycheck every two weeks and that
when you get out that paycheck stops
yeah and you know like it's it's a rough
transition for a lot of dudes it could
be very rough and so yeah I was
yeah I was lucky in that regard
um you know I was looking for something
else to do and I mean I wasn't thinking
any other way again like the way I'm
thinking is
I'm getting out to go do something not
to
I guess figure it out so this was the
first gig you're a banker what was it
it's a private Banker
um which is really like a
a fancy way saying financial advisor
and I had some people tell me don't
don't do it unless you have a lot of
rich friends but literally I got told
that by several people I realized how
this works out here
um but no I got I got lucky I worked for
a really good team up in LA and
um yeah I did that for like a year did
you guys move to LA
yeah
yeah that was terrible that's why we
moved to Texas like within a year after
moving there were you still working at
the bank when you moved to Texas no no I
got hired somewhere else
um again through through my mentor
um doing the same kind of thing no doing
different stuff like operations now just
kind of more like leadership operations
uh Business Development and how's your
head space at this point
um I mean
I feel like it didn't really
I was like really excited to get out and
do something different I'm not sure he
was in a holding pattern at that time I
think I felt like it like there was
enough decided you had enough tasks
yeah yeah I was all of a sudden I had
something that like I was it was like
excitement yeah
yeah and I didn't mind LA but
I certainly you know we were so
disconnected and um
it was it was a challenge like our
relationship was a challenge his
relationship with the kids was a
challenge he drinking was still an issue
I was just I was still on the meds
obviously so I was on the meds for seven
years straight
and Butterfly you were incorrect I got
prescribed while I was still on active
duty
so from active duty till 2017
November 11th is when yeah no I I just
meant that like right before you got out
of the military
is you went your whole career not on
meds like even when he would get injured
he'd be like I'm not taking that and
then you know finally relented and like
his last year of service and then from
that point forward he was prescribed
more and more and more
um but you know things were really still
deteriorating at home and I remember
thinking I can't be stuck in California
like as a single mom
um my dad had just taken a job at the
University of Texas as offensive
coordinator there and Marcus was working
in North Carolina commuting and so
um at one point he came home and he's
like quiet why are paying California
taxes I don't even work in the state
and we decided to move to Texas and I
just thought this is going to be a great
place for me to raise the kids and
um just feel better about the kids being
raised in a place like Texas and I can
probably afford it more than California
because I thought we were done
I didn't want to be done but I just
thought this is
this is not working so from your
perspective as you're saying raise the
kids you're thinking you're gonna be
raised alone because it's that bad well
it was just
you know my dreams of my my
feeling of support for his job in the
early days sort of turned to like
indifference and feeling like resentment
that the teams always came first
I never gave him an ultimatum or
anything like that but it was this sort
of like Pride was replaced with pain and
from there I just kept thinking well
maybe if we try this I'll get the
feeling back maybe if we try that I'll
get the feeling back maybe moving will
help my family maybe getting out will
help my family and nothing was helping
it was actually just deteriorating and
so I was basically losing hope that I
would ever get the feeling back of like
caring I did care but I just needed like
this isn't the way I wanted this isn't a
marriage I want to have and so it felt
inevitable
I thought at that point we were just
divorce I wasn't afraid like
anything bad would happen to him I just
felt like this isn't workable
and what are you feeling Marcus
at this point you're moved you moved to
Texas yeah is this where you're choking
out Country Club people yeah what's up
with this yeah yeah Texas uh it just got
worse from there like nothing nothing
definitely got better it got worse
um I hated I hated it there I needed the
water I needed the mountains it was flat
it was hot I didn't like the people the
town we lived
um you know some I got along with a few
people but again like nobody got it I
felt like I was in that space of
nobody gets me you know and you know
I've been at War and like I can't get I
can't have a real conversation with
anybody because only the only thing they
care about is like money and and uh it
was just I was just going through all of
that and again it wasn't like we were
struggling in terms of like financially
or any of that like honestly like we
could have made it could have made a
million dollars a year nothing would
have changed it was like just
it was just a it was just bad like it
was just was not
I don't know I again I I think I had
less friends when we moved to Texas
tonight
um we joke about it but uh
you know I don't want to be too too
angry here over the over the radio
everybody's listening definitely
um a challenging time and that's when
the real Wheels really came off for us I
think that part of what has grounded
Marcus has been his ability to
get in the water and travel and so you
know in the Navy you're always stationed
near water and in the teams you're doing
a lot of traveling and so when we were
in Texas he was basically stuck at home
and
it was 110 degrees outside with no water
and he tried to take up golf he's just
got to have you know that outlet and in
taking up golf he started hanging out
with a crew at the country club that
were very very very heavy Drinkers and
he started to drink
um yeah kind of fell back into the
mm-hmm I think I was drinking hard
anyway though you were but it certainly
escalated to a point that and I
basically had to like sit them down at
one point and be like listen don't call
my husband anymore because this is
becoming a problem and
um
it it just sweet our son at that point
was yeah then he started spiraling a
little bit I think just because of what
was going on at the house and so then
you know we're dealing with him not
being a
you know just like your typical kid that
can go to school and get good grades and
come home and he's not doing that he's
not doing that you know and so the mix
of a little bit of everything
um I think as it was at that time when
you know Amber again started just like
seeing more changes and so she started
getting me into brain clinics yeah it
was actually about 2000 and there was a
former teammate of Marcus's
who took his life as well like one of
the first seal suicides and his wife
actually did a two-part Series in The
Virginian pilot over
um Memorial Day
and uh that was in 2016 I believe
and I read this article about him and
she described him as the light going out
and she described all these struggles
that he was having and I was like
hold on this is what we're going through
no one's talking about this though
and it was the first time that someone
had like had the courage to say that
they were struggling and I had so much
respect for that and I was also scared
to show us and so
what the article basically ended by
saying was that
there was a pattern of scarring found in
his brain linked to blast exposure and
there was also some mention of CTE and I
started researching this and suddenly I
was like I remember going to the garage
and calling my best friend and I was
like I feel like I've just read about a
terminal diagnosis like this [__] is
scary
um I started really digging into
the effects of blasts and repeated head
trauma and like his 15 years playing
football and 13 years as a breacher and
I was like I don't know this is purely
psychological I don't know that
medication is going to help this I know
talk therapy is not helping it and if
anything I feel like it could get worse
over time and time is of the essence so
that's when I really did this heart
pivot and I saw him through new eyes and
I was suddenly overcome with compassion
for him because even though he had
become a monster I remembered I chose to
remember who I met and who he was before
this deterioration and so I held on to
the hope that I could get that person
back but I knew that it was going to be
really really really tough and it might
not happen I started like I was most
comfortable with Western medicine and
even though he was being a really good
soldier and like doing taking all the
medication that he was prescribed I was
like I'm not sure that medication is
what's you know fixable here
um
uh his only diagnosis really was he had
his TBI documented all throughout his
medical record but it was primarily like
pjsd PTSD and in my mind I'm like gosh I
don't know about that because he loved
to deploy and he would probably still be
deploying if you know [__] didn't go so
so far south
um
I don't think that this is
wrapped up in anything he did overseas
what did make more sense was the TBI
piece and so I started getting into
brain clinics and I got him into like
five total and he was willing but you
know it was weeks away from home it was
a lot of Diagnostics
there really wasn't a lot of Hope or
follow-up on the other side and he was
becoming more and more and more angry
and frustrated and
um he was really hopeful that I could
help
and My Hope was
diminishing
month after month of more failed things
what do you do at a brain Clinic oh gosh
they're all I mean they're all different
you take
you do a ton of batteries you do a lot
of cognitive testing you know they put
you in machines they spin you upside
down like they do a bunch of stuff that
are really in my opinion for people who
could like barely walk and talk you know
or have you know autism and all these
other things and so for me I was there
just I felt like passing time I'm like
this none of this none of this stuff
helps like what am I you know what am I
doing here and really uh
oh and you do like like a lot of
balancing I mean it's for people again
and this is my opinion but it's for
people that I I consider really [__]
up right that are not like could barely
talk
um do you at this point think you're
[__] up
I was just looking for answers I was
like just please just somebody tell me
like something okay so you think there's
questions of what the hell is wrong with
it 100 yeah I mean I left Niko with you
know with you know some you know the
fmri is showing like oh you have these
dead dead in parts of your brain that
you know aren't working but and those
are just tbis those are like tbis mild
tbis mild tbis he looked at me one time
chocolate like he was trying to get out
the door and he used to be so like
regimented and like you know everything
had a place and everything was organized
and he was just kind of like this
disorganized functioning but chaotic
the guy now and so he's trying to get
out the door
for a flight and he was profusely
sweating and his eyes were gigantic and
he looked at me and he was just like
sheer Terror like
something is wrong with my brain
I don't know what's wrong with me
something is not right with my brain
and so
all throughout his medical record it's
like
cognition issues memory issues balance
issues and I'm thinking he's the most
capable human I know
there's something that's out of his
control and
I don't know like doctors aren't helping
when you when they when they look at
these tbis these black areas in your
brain what do they do about it do they
do anything are they no what's the no
because I think it's again I think it's
personalized because I know some
individuals that had no scarring
that were struggling bad and then I know
individuals that had a lot of scarring
and they were fine maybe they weren't
fine or maybe they were saying they were
fine and they weren't doing well but you
know my my uh my recollection and the
conversations I have peoples people are
all over the map so individuals with no
scarring to you know 45 lesions on their
brain are acting
different and it didn't mean that the
ones with higher scarring were acting
worse and the ones that were you know
maybe had none so like I'm not a I'm not
a neuroscience or neuroscientist like I
can't tell you why but I think like
everything else is just personalized
um so there's no protocol for like oh
memory loss here's what you need to do
or yes no there absolutely is there's
there's like exercises and yes yeah
there's things you can do there's
supplements you can take you know I do
all of it like I take every supplement
that I can find that says this reduces
inflammation or this helps you you know
think clearly or you know whatever it is
like nootropics like I'll try anything
now that says hey this is going to make
your brain younger that's gonna make you
you know think more clearly
um yeah I mean I think I think there's
still a lot of research around there
about you know what what we can take
um but again I go back to
you know diet and exercise and for all
matters we needed a nuclear option it
all matters yeah you're right but it all
matters it's not one thing and so how
many of these brain Clinic things did
you go through I would do five and you
know and honestly I went to some really
good ones from like like world-renowned
and I thought
they do really good stuff but a lot of
these places as soon as you leave
like it's kind of like they forget you
you know so they collect your money
which are some of these are astronomical
if you know 15K 30k two weeks a month or
whatever it is
um and then you leave and they forget
about you and that's that was the part
that I you know I struggled with is that
if individuals want to get better or
these places want to get people better
then they need to there needs to be some
type of Continuum of Care like they just
need to check in on an individual 30
days 90 days or whatever it is and you
know we'll get probably you know more
into it what we're doing now but
um like Amber was saying I was getting
frustrated because I'd maybe get a
diagnosis but not a
not a like here's exactly what you do
here's a protocol
go home and do this every day it was
just they were all very similar great
for Diagnostics great for Diagnostics
but what do you do with those
Diagnostics yeah well they don't make
any money either by
doing anything else and you showing up
paying your bill and
then telling you to come back so you can
pay another bill
so what was when was and where was
rock bottom
and what did it look like Amber what
what is it what was it like for you
where you were just it can't get any
worse than this right now
um
do you mind if I
there's three stories that come to mind
and I don't think I've shared them
publicly
um the first one
was our son called me and said are you
home and I said no why he goes I need to
borrow a shirt from Dad
um but when I went to your room your
bedroom doors closed your bathroom
door's closed I'm standing at your
closet but the closet doors closed and
I'm afraid if I open it I'm going to
find Dad hanging
and it was like a traumatic conversation
but it was also the normal in our house
and I just you know that was the first
real like oh [__] this isn't normal how
old's your son at this point
15. and and what is it that he's picking
up on
it just felt palpable that
dad didn't have a purpose anymore
and
um
it
catastrophe felt imminent and I didn't
know what that looked like I didn't know
if that meant drinking and driving and
robbing his truck around a pole I didn't
know if that meant taking his life
um
I don't know I just felt like it's
coming and then
um
one night he came home and I it you know
11 o'clock he's not home 12 o'clock he's
not home one two
and I heard him come home and I was just
I was like I need to put the dresser in
front of the door and I'd
and then I ran out the back door
and I thought this is not normal this is
I
he never he's never ever ever been
physically aggressive with me not once
um but it was tending in a direction
that I didn't feel safe because I knew
he'd been drinking and that particular
night neither one of our kids were home
they were both having sleepovers and I
just got unnerved and maybe I
overreacted but you know when you're
sitting in a parking lot at 2 A.M you're
just like
this can't this is is not sustainable
and then the third thing that happened
which was like the true Rock Bottom the
culmination of my son feeling these
things me feeling these things was when
our daughter was riding with Marcus and
he had gotten into some like road
construction
and sort of like got lost or got off
track and they were coming to pick me up
from an event I was out with my friends
and by the time they got to me he was so
frustrated
and of course I didn't know had he been
drinking I I didn't I I just see my car
coming down the street and out comes our
daughter and she comes like spilling
towards me and she and he tears off down
the street and she said he's he's crazy
mom
he we can't get in the car with him
he'll kill us
and
she looked at me and she said how much
longer do we have to do this and
I said not one more day
and the next day I got on the phone with
his best friend who died Josh with his
family who had a foundation
and I said we we need help
um
I think if he goes to California and he
does this sort of like Trifecta brain
treatment that
I can at least have like a minute to
figure out next steps I it was my last
hope
and so they arranged for the funding I
arranged for him to leave what was
supposed to be six weeks turned into
like three months and during that three
months I came to visit him twice and the
first time I came to visit things were
pretty good for a week or so but like on
the last day of the trip everything fell
apart and so I went home really defeated
and frustrated
and
in my mind I was like
I don't think I can do this anymore you
know we got him out of the house
and there's been so much peace in my
house since he's been away
I was doing a I went out and do TMS like
the transcranial magnetic there was a
and not to knock that because that's
incredibly beneficial but it wasn't what
we needed at the time it wasn't enough
um would I sign him up to do it again
like for an extra bonus to where he's at
now like totally
but it wasn't what we needed at the time
so
I came home thinking okay this is it I
got to start making plans and I did I
started making plans but I wasn't like
totally ready to pull the trigger
because I just I never wanted to leave
him but I definitely felt like I was in
a position where I had to choose him or
our kids
and so
um he extended his saying got more time
at the at the centers and I thought I'm
gonna go visit him one more time so
around this time for on my birthday I
came out to visit him and we were in his
truck and I said something so benign and
he started just like tearing down the
five and I thought if I survived this
truck ride
I'm done
and I didn't even tell him that I was
leaving the next day I got up and I
packed my bag and I left for the airport
and I came home
and
um
I my mom was there with the kids
and I called my dad and I basically told
my parents that I'm quitting it was the
first time that I'd really quit anything
and
my dad was like
you know this is not a disappointment to
me you are the you're you are the most
important thing right now and you feel
that this is the right thing to do then
I support you in whatever you need
and I said I think he's going to be dead
in two to five years and I hate that but
I'm going to try to start forgiving
myself now because I feel like the
inevitable is going to happen
I'm not we are the only stabilizing
force that he has in his life when
that's gone
I don't know
and so I was really working on forgiving
myself and also like during the the year
or so leading into where we were at that
point I had been on my own really
in-depth
journey of like healing and getting back
into my faith and like tapping into
a higher power to help sustain me and so
there was this massive storm
all around me but I had become the eye
of the storm and so
things had never been so out of control
but I had never been so in control and
so I was thinking clearly I was making
like really strategic
decisions but at the same time I was
listening to my intuition which was like
you need to know that you've tried
everything
because one this is going to stay with
your kids
and you know if the worst does happen
they're gonna be they're gonna have to
deal with it for the rest of their lives
and two am I going to be able to know
and say that I've tried everything
so he's running out of funding
in October and at that point our
finances had become a mess and um he
called home and said I'm running out of
funding like can I come home and I
basically said you can come home buy it
as soon as you get here I want to I want
to
talk
and so he came home and I sat him down
and I basically took a completely
different approach because up until that
point I mean I definitely developed
compassion for him and I had tried
really hard for you know this like 18
months that he was going to all these
brain clinics but before that it was
like guilt shame condemnation
um you know all of the things that I was
feeling I was basically projecting onto
him and I was creating what I was trying
to avoid so the more I would guilt him
and shame him the more bad behavior
would come from it so the more guilt and
shame I would throw on it was just this
toxic cycle
um so like this this sort of time where
I was reconnecting with
just a greater wisdom of how to handle
the situation I was overcome with
compassion for him and like seeing him
for his struggles and for them seeming
to be out of his control where before I
always thought like you're you know you
could figure it out
um
and so I just approached him in a
completely new way and I said
if you fight with me I will fight for
you every day of the rest of your life
but you have to fight with me
you know I love you I will never leave
your side
but we've got to do this together and he
totally
it totally softened him and he was like
what do you want to do and I said
there's one treatment that you haven't
tried
one of our
dear and trusted friends a couple had
had gone down this path so like one
other team guy that we had known
at the time who'd done this and his
situation was like you know more of a
crisis situation
where ours was like very deliberate and
we had been we'd known about it and
talked about it on and off for a year
but it seemed crazy
uh so I reapproached him about it and I
said
you know to go to Mexico and to try this
and he was like I mean
I'll try it like don't get our hopes up
I remember saying that too I was like
there's no chance that something is
going to work because we've tried all
the stuff that we're supposed to like
guys that you know other team guys have
gone to have gotten better or not gotten
better but something that I thought was
crazy that I read about seemed like it
was crazy I didn't think that trying
something new was going to even slowly
or slightly help but I you know I
committed just because like I sometimes
maybe like you I feel like a a
you know a guinea pig I'll try anything
if you tell me like it works or it makes
me you know bigger faster stronger
smarter so
um you know and I did some research and
it started to make sense that you know
initially when we're talking about
psychedelic medicines you know they were
intended and are intended for medical
use not for you know recreational
parties you know anything could be
abused for recreational parties and so
um the more I read the more research I
read I said does kind of makes sense
um I'll you know basically I'll give it
a go
when um what was Rock Bottom for you
like when when Amber's going through all
this like from the outside looking at
you just a little seeming like there's
just no hope
what was Rock Bottom for you no hope
like no hope no passion no Drive anger
frustration sadness you know depression
all of it like it just was like
again going back to what we talked about
earlier didn't want to do the things I
enjoyed doing didn't want to hang out
with anybody didn't want to have a
conversation didn't want to make do
small talk
um
just just done all the above just done
yeah just done
um and and like everything else I've had
I'd have days of like
um
I don't want to call it Joy but just you
know up like some uplifting days but the
majority of days were down and you know
including weeks on end some days I
didn't want to get out of bed like I
said I just shut my phone off where now
you know we joke about it as long as
you're trending upwards you're going to
have like you said like you you know but
but yours is different you're you know
you get upset over a situation you know
that's completely normal I'll still have
some down days
but they'll only last like an hour where
before they would last for literally
days and you know I think that just
takes time over you know what we've been
working on over the last couple years
but yeah I was just I was just checked
out of everything
medically you know mentally physically
emotionally
um there was no
there was nothing in sight it was just
like
flat
clear you know not clear but flat and
and uh really nothing to look forward to
just real quick how the hell were you
guys paying for like everything like
just life like you weren't working for
months on end how
well it was a struggle it was a real
struggle um we maxed out a lot of credit
cards Marcus has his medical retired too
yeah okay yeah so I met but I was like
got it which was not yeah it's not I
mean but at least it's like groceries
right I mean yeah yeah no it was and we
had and we had you know we had saved
money just for you know from the teams
and stuff over the years
um
I'm trying to think were you working at
the time or no well Caden had also
gotten or send it was dealing with some
chronic health issues and so
um I was actually pulled away from
from but we were paying out of pocket
for a lot of these like medical expenses
because most of this stuff a lot of
stuff wasn't covered under insurance and
you're probably dealing with it well
some of the stuff you're doing but
um yeah you know luckily we had a lot of
these foundations or
you know are there for like these
reasons yeah
all right so we get the deal where we're
like well this is our last shot last
shot at uh the one treatment that you
haven't tried yet which is psychedelic
um what is it drugs psychedelic plants
what do you call it we'll call it yeah
we'll call it a psychedelic assisted
therapy psychedelic assistant therapy so
the drugs are psychedelics
um
you know psycho delic mind manifesting
psychedelic that's the meaning of it
psychedelic drugs are the you know the
class
um the way this is going this medical
route they they're including therapy in
it because what they're showing with the
researchers at it they they take the
drug and then they bring in the therapy
with it the results are like through the
roof because the the Psychedelic really
opens your mind up for a change
basically gives you new like you think
of it as uh if it's snowing and you have
like fresh powder and tracks haven't
been on the on the powder yet that's
what psychedelics do it basically gives
you like this new
um blanket of snow to build your own new
tracks and you could you can still build
those bad so you can still build in bad
habits but the idea is if you have that
coach or that therapist or that support
you can build new tracks like good
tracks good habits and that's that's the
idea of psychedelic assisted therapy at
the time we had no idea what we're
signing up for I don't even know what
we're talking about right now when when
I heard about this right but there's a
team guy who his wife was like hey you
need to do this yeah yeah and I mean
that is the essence of our Community is
I always take care of one another and so
um they'd been there for us in the past
and we knew about their struggles they
knew about our struggles but
um you know thankfully she felt
compelled to reach out to me and then I
talked to him and then he talked to
Marcus and because we trusted and
respected them so much
I felt comfortable I didn't do an ounce
of research I did nothing I I just
convinced him to go trusted them got him
on the plane and I literally looked at
the steering wheel of my car like
this is it I did the research and like I
said from what from initially what I
thought was you know I'll use the term
crazy
to it started to make sense that again
these were intended for medical use and
you know it was stigmatized because we
all know it as just crazy crazy drugs
that people around the 60s and 70s you
know ran around concerts doing uh losing
their minds but you know they're
intended for for for mental health and
Behavioral Health use and how substance
abuse and you know host of other things
so so the more I read the more it made
sense
um and I figured okay I'm gonna give
this a shot
so you get on a plane you just said you
well you drop them off at the airport
yeah and I'm like this is this is like
putting everything on the table
and if it doesn't work I'm gonna have to
come back to the drawing board if it
does work the best I can hope for is
that it buys me some time to find
something that's a little bit more
comfortable I didn't think it was like a
Magic Bullet but I definitely thought
that if anything it'll just buy me some
time
um and then I went to see him the next
day so I can talk about that whenever
but well yeah let's get so you get on a
plane where and where do you fly to
Marcus coming to San Diego
and then sweet yeah it's not bad and
then uh Caravan down to a clinic in
Mexico I've been operating for a long
time with a good reputation
we'll keep those separated for now
because uh one just kind of you know
security reasons guys going down we like
to try to keep the two separated wait
what are we keeping separated just us
what we're doing with the non-profit and
then the you know the Retreats that a
lot of people are going to for these uh
to do these medicines so we just don't
like to connect
the two I don't understand that's okay
that's good we're just we'll talk about
it as we go so uh when you say keep
these things separated just mean like
different clinics or something like
disclosing The Retreat locations
for sure no problem got that okay check
check in Roger sorry my communication
skills were terrible there so I
apologize
no it's all good so you go to this
Clinic yeah I go to this with the other
team guy oh you're with another team guy
isn't it too no the one he's just
escorting you you suggested this you
just throw it out he's growing out and
make sure I'm good
uh because I don't know what to expect
what is the place like is this like no
awesome is it beautiful like beautiful
home overlooking the water everything
perfect food uh stuff does it seem like
a hospital or does it seem like a does
not seem like that does not seem like a
hobby but it is set up with hospital
equipment yeah and it's set up with like
full medical you know you're on uh EKG
or a heart rate monitor you're doing
your analysis to make sure there's
nothing in your system you're doing
blood work to make sure you're not lying
um
there's like there's a whole protocol
and the more stringent you are on the
screening uh the better the outcome
individuals that have trouble with
psychedelic medicine again is the
screening so if the screen is not done
correctly there can be issues you screen
properly there's almost little to no
issues and so the more that this whole
industry moves forward
um it's just got to be done correctly
and so this place again has been running
for a long time had been doing it the
right way not an underground
Shaman that is getting drugs from God
knows where and saying here do this it's
good for you getting drugs from Fred
and who's making it in his bathtub
exactly uh who was a chemist in high
school how long are you there for like
okay so so you show up yeah it's it's a
it's a three to five day event summer
shorter some are longer
um you do this you know you do a full
like I was saying full intake a full
medical screening uh you talk to a
psychedelic coach who's a therapist
first like a psychologist or like a
licensed therapist who's trained in
psychedelic medicine they prepare you
for the experience and again uh the
better outcomes are the ones who prepare
the most so if you can uh what that
individual does at licensed professional
is going to talk to you about what your
experience may be like or what you're
going through and what you may
experience and the idea is to prepare
your they call it set and setting your
mindset get your mindset in the right
place to go into these treatments and so
sometimes you hear about these bad trips
sometimes bad trips are just that an
individual's mindset was not in a good
place they were at a Slayer concert they
were at a Slayer concert or yes for sure
or they watched like an nasty movie that
they started thinking about during their
experience that just turned it sideways
but here's the other thing about bad
experience is what we're learning some
of those bad experiences actually many
or most of them especially with Team
guys and other veterans they're they're
good experiences those bad experiences
they have to go through to get out the
other side so the bad experiences are
some of the [__] that they may
experience as a kid maybe there's some
sexual assaults that went on as a child
maybe you know maybe they did watch
their friend get popped in the head and
die right in front of them and they
experience that on their you know on
their Journey
so all types of that so those are bad
trips but those bad trips are actually
like working showing them working
through stuff you know people may take
years doing it through quote unquote
talk therapy or Psychotherapy you can do
that in a few days done properly again
not at a Slayer concert with Joe shaman
so what's the so you so you screen your
screen you do
um you do some integration excuse me
some preparation again this is from the
therapist coach
um once that's done
um
you're you're given the medicine and
just like you would take ibuprofen or
Tylenol or Excedrin or probably a few
others that I don't know for a headache
psychedelic drugs are the same way so
there's you know ibogaine and there's uh
psilocybin and there's MDMA and there's
um
what am I missing Ayahuasca what you're
hearing about
um so there's all these psychedelic
drugs that slightly do they're similar
but they do something slightly different
but they're all relatively trying to
solve the same problem and so
um the the drug that I experienced was
called ibogaine and um again to me
you could have told me I was eating
fruit loops
um I'd be like okay Fruit Loops that's
that I had no idea is it a pill it's a
yeah it's built it's just like powdered
pill it's an it's in pill form you take
it uh dependent upon your body weight
and it but again it's personalized so I
metabolize [__] faster than you might so
what works for me if I take I don't know
I'm making this number 800 milligrams
you may need you know 1.2 grams and just
because I maybe metabolize it faster or
slower so it's it's science but there's
also a little bit of subjectivity to the
amount that individuals need I'm having
a flashback of when you were talking
about when you were drinking for the
first time you're like I don't
understand how this is going to make me
like think any different oh this is
exactly the same this is probably even
worse because I mean we're talking about
uh we're talking about going on a
journey here the world's most powerful
thing yeah and so that's where I was
getting at is that ibogaine is
considered uh one of the world's most
powerful psychedelics that's why you
called the nuclear option not everybody
needs to do this no no way near or not
even close to everybody needs to do this
but
what we're seeing is some of the stuff
that I was experiencing you know as I
was transitioning out of the teams and
like the years of like you know if you
want to call it comorbidity of other
things like oh he's a little depressed
and maybe he's got some tbis and maybe
he's going on you know going through
some [__] with transition and you know
Ivy games good but for an individual
that may be just going through a little
bit of depression maybe you can't get
themselves out of you know out of a hole
maybe ibogaine is not the right thing
for it because it is it is a really
rough journey and I'm sure like you said
you've talked to some friends
um it's not fun like it's not it's not
Joy at all and anybody who takes that
for recreational use
like I want to talk to them and actually
they need to go talk to a psych because
there's something definitely wrong with
that individual
so so you take it yeah you take so you
take this medicine I'm gonna call the
medicine even I don't think technically
we can call it yet but we're calling it
medicines because they are medicines
um and then you know you lie down the
bed you put
um like noise canceling headphones on uh
you put eye shades on and
you know within an hour you start kind
of going into this experience and
for everybody it's different
um but you basically go on a you know
six to eight to twelve or even longer
hour uh journey and for everybody else
again because it's your mind or my mind
and our minds are different what I'm
going to experience is going to be
different from what you experience or
from what you know you experience
and it's working on a few different
things so one is the story and that's
like the psychological piece the trauma
piece where
um if there are real things that really
[__] you up in the past whatever it is
so a lot of the addiction Right is
coming finding out from things that
happen in individuals lives not just
because they like to drink or they like
to do heroin or whatever they're doing
it because something [__] them up so
bad that they turn to that whatever it
is and again we don't need to discuss
what
whatever that is
um the Psychedelic does a really good
job and and they say it's a jokester too
because it will show you that and it'll
[__] with you too
um but the thing is what you just said
sometimes the only way
um
the only way
the only way to heal is through
and
the only way to conquer something is
through like you have to face it we know
that you can't you can't bury stuff or
if you have an issue with a with a team
guy that you work with if you just keep
bearing or put stuff on off the side
it's going to blow up one day but if you
can take that person say hey let's let's
settle our differences what's going on
here like you don't like me I don't like
you why we have to work together if we
don't have that conversation it's it's
going to be messed up forever so that
that's what the Psychedelic does to the
mind it shows you the problem that
you're dealing with and you face it in
this 12-hour journey and it could suck
and for me it it was really tough I mean
it was it was 12 hours of like Gore and
blood and just crap
but when I was done it literally felt
like I just took a thousand pounds out
of a backpack it was just like
it was just like this relief that I
never had before and all this like
pent-up frustration that Amber's talking
about that just like went away
and for everybody else it's different
and so what talk therapy or
Psychotherapy can take 5 or 10 or 15
years I mean I still have friends up in
La that are still seeing a psychologist
for 20 years I'm like dude I can help
you out probably in a week like you've
been paying this person it's obviously
not helping
um you know it can it can do that in a
much
faster time frame and like Amber said
it's not a Panacea it's not a Magic
Bullet
sometimes you need to go down twice
sometimes you may need to do it three
times maybe you need to do it once a
year everybody's different
but again I don't want people who are
listening to get the the wrong idea that
that this is a one and done or it's like
a magic pill because you know everybody
would be rushing to do it and think like
again you know all my answers you know
be solved and just this you know this
bottle right here it takes a lot of work
the experience itself is gonna suck it's
going to be miserable you're gonna cry
you're gonna throw up like you're gonna
like nobody wants to face their rapist
you know what I mean so if they were
they were raped as a young child
and that's what's affecting you for the
like you're going to face that
individual during and that's that's
pretty traumatic for an individual right
if they're grown up and their uncle was
molesting them for years upon years you
know upon years
if that's still affecting them in their
life they're going to face that in their
journey and that's tough but you know
what you need to face that to move on
and that's what these medicines do they
also work on the brain so they they
promote neurogenesis which means like
you know brain growth and they they're
turning on parts of the brain that may
have not been working before and I think
that's what we're seeing in in the
success for a lot of these guys is if
they do have mild tbis and they're they
have these scarring that we're talking
about and maybe parts of their brain
we're not allowing them to function well
it is allowing them to function well now
so there's a host of things and I don't
want to get into science because I'm way
above my pay grade Jocko but you know
this experience was was Radical it was
it you know did a 180 for me it was
life-changing and life-saving and Amber
actually came in the day after
and I walk down the hallway and I we
just first of all I freaked out because
it hit me when I was in the car headed
there
um I was very uncomfortable and I was
raised you know super conservative and I
feel like you know I was in the survival
mode and suddenly like this piece had
come
and in the car on the way there I had
this moment where I was like I can't go
I don't know what we've just done I
think what we've done is bad
um and I'm too scared to face it
and my girlfriend
was like you have to go he's asking for
you and we told him you're coming so you
have to go and I walked in there so
uptight and scared of
oh it was the most nerve-wracking
feeling and I heard him walking down the
hall and I was just like oh my gosh
please please let this have worked
um and he came around the hall and
immediately I could just see that he was
back it was like it was literally like
being reunited with the person that I
met
um
which is a
complete and utter
excuse my language mind [__] I think it
really it it really threw me in in the
best ways and also in the worst ways
because then you start to doubt it and
second guess like it's too good to be
true and like you're just letting your
walls down you're like oh don't do that
because
it's too it's this isn't Gonna Last so a
lot of spouses have experienced that in
that mild freak out
you know is certainly replaced with this
feeling of complete relief and then
how do we maintain this yeah and so the
first thing I did I said Amber this is
exactly I mean the first thing out of my
mouth is like this is exactly what the
guys need I say we keep getting you know
I keep getting phone calls of you know
friends that are like struggling like I
was I'm like dude I can't take care of
you because I can't even [__] take
care of myself right now
um so when I experienced this like
that's the first thing I said I was like
we got to figure out a way to like get
our friends here and do the same thing
like we have to figure out how to raise
money because someone paid for me you
know four thousand dollars or whatever
it was and so I said well how do we how
do we get you know our buddies and and
families that are struggling to do the
same thing he said I don't know he said
well like we got to go raise money let's
you know we'll start a non-profit again
had no idea what we're talking about
um we'll go we'll start a nonprofit
we'll go raise money and then we'll fund
our friends so they could get the same
healing that like I feel like I'm
experiencing we thought maybe a handful
like yeah
we didn't honestly we didn't know
um and that's what we did like well then
we were contacted
um by Elizabeth and she said I want to
give to a veteran organization he
actually had his treatment on Veterans
Day so it was really special and then
end of year giving you know right after
that in December made this lady contact
Marcus and say I need a recommendation
for veterans organization to give to and
he goes you know
um
you we can't give you a tax write-off
but if you pay this Clinic I could get
you know five of my friends down there
for a treatment that could save their
life and she was totally on board and
that's what really launched
what has become that
but
we don't want to talk about it we don't
want to talk about it because it's so
stigmatized and so taboo to say you're
struggling like maybe some of our
internal friends knew primarily because
the wives were talking not because the
guys were talking and so my thing was I
don't want to jinx it I don't want to I
don't know if it'll work for everyone I
don't know if it'll continue working for
us I don't want to talk about it until
12 months have gone by and we've raised
money and provided this opportunity for
12 other guys to go down there and at
that point maybe we'll talk about it
this one's not one for like you know PR
and stepping out of the Shadows so this
was a a big deal but I thought well I'm
just gonna buy ourselves a year here and
get some really good data
and come out with like a little bit of
foundation beneath us and
his treatment was on Veterans Day so
November 11th would have been the one
year mark Chad Wilkinson took his life
on October 28th
and we were sitting in his funeral just
days before the one year anniversary
of Marcus or you know right around the
same time and um
we'd been to the Little Creek Chapel so
many times for war funerals
and this felt so different and I was
seeing all the same guys that would
deploy you know with Marcus and be at
all these other funerals and like you
know they had more medals and they had
more gray hair and they had more
wrinkles and they were you know getting
older and becoming like you could see in
their faces that like
they were struggling
and this is the first suicide funeral
I'd been to and I started shaking
chocolate like I had this
tremble release response at Chad's
funeral where the I was jackhammering
shaking the whole bench was shaking
people were looking down like what is
going on down there and I was just
overcome with this conviction of like if
we don't talk if we don't step out and
get out of our comfort zone
um more guys are going to die by Suicide
and
we're gonna just do whatever it takes to
prevent that because this community and
this Chapel can't take that
so we're not gonna let that happen
and so we started basically just
stopped hiding kind of what we were
doing and started speaking about it a
little bit because we thought well if we
start
speaking about it you know and of course
we talked to Sarah
um we just said hey
you know we're just gonna we're gonna
start talking about this a little bit so
people know so in the unlikely event
that an individual is getting to the
point where Chad got to they might pause
and go oh you know what there's
something I haven't tried or there's
this thing that I heard is working for
some individuals after you know because
mostly a lot I mean most of these
individuals are on the same path like
they go to Niko they go to these brain
clinics they're on a bunch of these mood
stabilizers and then they're like okay
well well now what
so I at that point just said you know
[__] my career
um because I was still like trying to
figure out like to get into
Corporate America and you know whatever
um I just said
I think this is more important
um
and if someone is not going to hire me
or doesn't want to work with me because
we're talking about psychedelic
medicines then like shame on them like I
don't need I don't I don't want to work
with that individual like open your mind
a little bit we found something that
works and that's the story here the
story is not Marcus and Amber running
around doing psychedelic drugs or
running a cult which we were told by the
way initially we were running a cult
which is kind of funny
um but no we're we're trying to heal
people that's all we found something
that worked I think that's what happened
and and so that was it we just started
speaking about it we started doing
um you know interview here interview
there maybe a small podcast you know and
and you know one thing leads to another
people get interested
um people with money want to donate
and you also know how the community is
like what I love most about the
community is just this like unwavering
commitment to caring for one another and
for every person that comes through our
program
because the efficacy rates are so high
they refer back three to five of their
buddies and so it creates a need that we
simply you know are having really hard
time meeting but
um to date we've provided funding for
over 600 other
operators not all seals I mean we serve
all branches of Special Operations but
um
you know it's it's really taken on a
life of its own and it it absolutely
started at Chad Wilkinson's Funeral and
this just goal of ending veteran suicide
did you your original
um like when you first came out and
started talking about it that was after
Chad's funeral yeah at Chad's funeral is
whenever I was so convicted of like
it everything we do I'm keeping Chad
Wilkinson and Sarah and the kids right
here because
The Fallout from suicide like to survive
all these combat deployments and then
lose your loved one to Suicide like oh I
can't even fathom like
I'm just super convicted
how long did it take to start getting
traction
like almost immediately
almost to me we had gotten traction Mega
Traction in terms of the need but what
didn't necessarily match that was the
donor dollars it was very stigmatized we
were talking about four years ago at
this point
um it was still very stigmatized and
unknown like there's a lot of there's a
lack of Education around psychedelic
therapies and then there's
misinformation around psychedelics and
so to combat those two stigmas and to
also try to combat the stigma of saying
you need help
it's been like you know pretty dicey
yeah that's a war on all fronts right
there yeah yeah well then you go into
the the real fun war of like
military leadership and policy makers
and big Pharma in VA and
it seems like it's getting really good
traction right now is it isn't it yeah
yeah because veterans are driving it and
the veterans driving it at the tip tip
of the spear
the seal community and the broader
Special Operations community and like I
don't know if I needed to get something
done I'd call you guys
so you've so so the the charity is
called well it's got you got on your
T-shirt there right it's vets Solutions
yeah right veterans exploring Treatment
Solutions and it's vet
solutions.org if people want to go and
check that out and can they donate from
there and all that yeah
yeah
um and so what's the plan there on that
side of things just continue to grow
continue to accept donations continue to
get more people treatment
we got upwards of 10 qualified
applications a day needing funding day
and it is so overwhelming like I
actually dread it when we have to go
through applications we do it on Mondays
and you know you have a certain we have
a certain number of Grants or funds
allocated and
um choosing who gets those funds when
everyone is so deserving it's like
so reaction I mean we actually have to
you know we had a like an algorithm
built in to like rack and stack who's
done the most combat deployments like
what are they going through so it
actually you know it ranks the
individuals you know or if there's like
an immediate crisis they immediately get
put to the top and they get a phone call
immediately and so there's a whole you
know there's a whole system to it
because again of those 10
if we're talking about only being able
to support
175 to 200 a year
there's a you know there's most of those
people are not getting funding
um there are thousands tens of thousands
that
could use it or need it or
or trying to access it but because these
are schedule one substances in the
United States they have to travel abroad
so you know one of our I would say most
effective talking points when we're
talking to policy makers and leader
leaders is that you know our nation's
veterans are leaving the country they
fought for for access to meaningful care
and this is so far superior to anything
else that's currently available at least
from my perspective what I'm seeing is
there's healing happening in four key
areas of Veteran suffering and so when
we were in such a bad way if you would
have given me Immediate relief in one of
the four areas it would have been an
absolute blessing the fact that it
provides immediate relief for most
people in all four categories is unheard
of so the first category is
psychological trauma so anything that's
affecting someone you know even on a
subconscious level whether it's
childhood trauma repressed trauma that
you know don't even remember
um War trauma whatever the source of
trauma is it deals with that like Marcus
said it shows you the trauma and then
you're able to work through it confront
it deal with it put it away be done with
it
um there's an anti-indictive benefit
which is really ironic because these
drugs are scheduled as being addictive
and like a high potential for abuse
they're actually being used to treat
addiction but because they're so
challenging to even research in the
United States that data is largely
missing so Marcus and you know so many
other guys that are going down there
might not have a full-blown addiction
but they have substance use disorder and
so for Marcus it was alcohol some guys
go down there because they're hooked on
opioids
um whatever the addiction is it it like
resets it scrubs and resets those
um receptors receptors and the addiction
you know no longer
has the upper hand
um there's a physiological benefit as it
pertains to TBI at vets we primarily
write grants for ibogaine and 5-mio DMT
protocol that's two of the six
psychedelics that we can provide funding
for most guys are going down there to do
I begin and 5meo we're just wrapping up
a study with Stanford the preliminary
data is not released yet but I think
that it will show significant
improvements in cognitive functioning
neurological functioning it creates this
really incredible neuroplasticity in the
brain so the brain's ability to change
itself create new neural Pathways
neuronal connections
um you know whatever it's doing in the
brain as it relates to TBI is pretty
remarkable in our Stanford study I think
we'll prove that the fourth thing
is a spiritual
connection or reconnection and I think
that that's what science will never be
able to fully explain that when someone
feels as though they're put on this
Earth
by a higher power and we're all
connected and like you know we're all
humans and we're alive and the grass is
alive and the flowers are alive and the
animals are alive and you see that
you're part of this really incredible
huge ecosystem of purpose and Perfection
you feel as though you have a place to
belong again and you feel this God
connection that
I think is the answer to a lot of
societies
issues right now so psychological
anti-addictive physiological and
spiritual
when you check all four of those boxes
you go home like I feel pretty good now
on the back end of this there's a lot of
things that are really important so
we're screening another one of our
screening categories is like how
committed are you to this because we've
got guys coming to us that say I don't
know anything about this my buddy said
to do it and then we've got guys that
say I've been researching this for a
year and I've changed my diet and I'm
really committed to working with a coach
those are the guys that are going to
have the best chance for Success the
spouse support is another huge factor in
overall trajectory and success so
um you know it's every it's the
Psychedelic just provides this massive
reset
and then
you when you get someone like from fetal
position to one knee like they can stand
up and take it from there especially
guys like you guys so guys are leaving
these weeks with this checklist of now
what because now I feel great again and
so for Marcus and for hundreds of others
at this point
you're feeling good you're feeling like
you know suddenly you've got a thousand
pounds lifted off of you you're sleeping
better when you're sleeping better
you're getting up earlier you're getting
up early you can work out now and you
work out you want to take supplements
you take supplements you might as well
eat right and it just becomes this sort
of like
self-propelling
bio hacking Snowball Effect in the very
best ways and those are the guys that
are going you know through these
remarkable changes but for anyone that
would think like oh you're just going to
Mexico to do drugs uh no no people that
are going down there are leaning into
the hardest work of their lives and
actually having to come face to face
with things that they might have been
running from for decades
she's being conservative about the
Stanford study too but it's the results
are
remarkable like so remarkable that I
think there's going to be a lot of eyes
on it once they release it to the public
Wednesday
no no no no it won't it won't be
published for quite some time it won't
be published but we're going up there
Wednesday just to they're gonna
talk about the results officially but
not just from the reduction of symptoms
like we were talking about earlier but
also the fmris that are coming out uh
before and after are like astounding
it'll be groundbreaking it won't just be
groundbreaking for veterans it'll be
groundbreaking for
contact sport athletes for First
Responders First Responders for
Alzheimer's patients for Parkinson's
patients like the the changes in the
brain on the physiological level I
hypothesize that there's
not been anything like it to date
Marcus
when you uh I'm dragging you back real
quick yeah
what give me an example of
what you see you said bloody gory
number one do you know
that it's a cycle that it's psychedelic
does it or does it feel like it's a real
thing
and like give me just an example just
any example just so people kind of can
connect
all these positive things to like what
you see
when you're in on this
Journey yes there you go
um I tried hard not to use the word
that's like we're trying not to call
this thing trip I picked that up so it's
funny you say that because you know
obviously we're around the whole kind of
medical psychedelic Community now and
you hear all these things or how they
correct people because you know a
politician doesn't want to hear like
drug there's one here psychedelic they
immediately think of Woodstock or you
know right so you know we've been doing
the same thing like we say this we don't
say that you know it all means the same
thing so appreciate I appreciate that
I'll make a very simple one and one
that's not bloody or gory
um
my uh one of my close friends his
experience is he
uh he was sitting down and each
individual from
um from extortion
uh was like dressed in white and would
sit down and put their hand on his
shoulder and say hey man it's okay like
I'm good like you can let me go now and
but he had the conversation with that
person
he would look at him and go yeah okay
and then that guy would go and then
another guy from extortion would sit
down dressed in white
and say hey man I'm good like we're I'm
good I'm in a good place and then that
person would go and and each person that
he was like obviously
having whatever this person was dealing
with had to do
with all the Buddies he just lost on
that Hilo and once that was gone
again he he just dealt with whatever
that was his trauma it may have been
locked back into subconscious as Amber
mentioned but that's what he was dealing
with in life and once he faced them and
talked to them and they talked to him
and they told him it was okay
he's okay like he's not mad anymore like
he let he let that [__] go
and uh I you know we hear these stories
like over and over and over again and
it's um
you know it's it's they're all different
but they're all the same
um and I think that's what's you know
pretty remarkable about it I've
developed some of my own theories
whether they're true or not yeah Emory
has theories as we're fine science
hasn't proven my theories but my theory
is that
whatever the trauma response is it goes
back to the origination of the trauma
and some people channel that trauma
in ways that Society deems unhealthy
versus healthier I feel like what I've
seen in the Special Operations Community
is that there's something in the early
childhood has like enabled this sort of
like
dialing down of suffering like like you
could just the community is able to
maintain such suffering and so a lot of
guys I've felt are going way back to
Childhood and dealing with like sort of
repressed things and
I don't know Marcus if you want to tell
any of her stories like about your
actual experience of going back to
actual memories in childhood but then
also to your question Jaco on why the
blood and the gore I also feel like when
you're in the face of evil
that sort of can stick to you and
Marcus had to get through some really
dark
very demonic
you know heaviness
to come out on the other side and he's
been back to do I began since he's like
basically does this annual protocol
reset or like every year and a half yeah
yeah and so if he started in the
basement of his soul
every year he gets a floor higher and
the last time he died again which would
be their fourth time
he described it as blissful
so yeah so it wasn't it wasn't painful
it wasn't tough
um it was an angry I didn't feel like I
was like you know fighting demons you
hear a lot of guys I mean they talk
about literally like fighting demons it
was none of that it was just
um just kind of like peaceful and
surreal and not not tough and what it
told me is like I'm good like I I think
I've scrubbed whatever I needed to scrub
you scrubbed the darkness yeah you know
you kind of just got rid of any of the
the garbage that I think was you know
affecting me and so I mean I'm I'm like
I'm light now like I don't have
nightmares anymore and and I think that
was like a lot of the the blood and gore
or like you know you'd go to try to pull
the trigger and like the magazine would
fall out or like the barrel would melt
like just all the dumb stuff
um like I don't have I don't I don't
have those
Visions anymore
it is and some of it is funny I mean if
you hear some of the stories you're like
man that's [__] hilarious right right
especially like you guys talking about
their funny stories I'm laughing because
like everyone has that dream yeah
somebody 100 times and they just like
look at you yeah
wait a minute I'm really good at
fighting why can't I knock you out in my
dream
yeah exactly so we're we are trying to
get this uh to as many veterans as we
can that's what you guys are working on
right now and you're you were telling me
earlier you're also looking to take this
uh in a in a Direction
private as well yes like as a privately
owned company yeah so you know as Amber
was alluding to earlier you know the
amount of applications we get a day
those are just from veterans the amount
of individuals that reach out via you
know Instagram or Facebook or link you
know really LinkedIn
um you know and linkedin's like a you
know Professional Network so a lot of
like a lot of corporate a lot of CEOs
and entrepreneurs just asking hey you
know how do I do this you know I heard
you talk on so and so you know where do
I go to find these treatments
um can you introduce me to a coach or a
therapist and so you know the more that
I saw over the last two years I just
said Amber you know we started this we
said hey we'd help we want to help our
our teammates First Team guys but we
want to help you know all the special
operations and then we want to help all
the veterans and then we want to help
you know athletes like you know NFL
players at 99 of the brains they found
autopsied
you know
um from the uh individuals that have
um took their own life or all had CTE
you know we want to help those
individuals we said you know what like
we want to help anyone that is like
going through the same thing and again
it's not everyone it's just everyone
that is struggling the same way and that
was kind of like my vision a long time
ago is you know I want to start with
veterans and help help our help our
brothers and sisters but like I want to
help everybody
and
um it took the interest of some you know
a VC that started donating to vets and
just said hey I really love what you're
doing like I think this is needed you
know like I understand personalized
medicine
um how do we take this and introduce it
to the broader population and reach more
people and I said well let's work on
that so I've been working on that for a
year and we're actually launching this
week and the company's called uh Tara
t-a-r-a Tara mind uh the website will be
taramind.com
um right now we'll have a uh we
basically have a landing and info page
for people to go to and just put in some
information and uh they'll start getting
some you know some newsletters and some
some some info but uh launching at the
end of this year or will be you know the
first couple weeks of January uh we're
launching a care navigation
um and uh directory and basically a
platform for uh for psychedelic
um
Retreats clinics
providers coaches basically a
Marketplace to connect all these
individuals and so the individuals that
are reaching out to us on a regular
basis and saying hey where do I go what
do I do we're building that platform for
them and you know we're going to provide
educational content we're going to vet
everything and have you know high
standards and and protocols that you
know
um that uh these providers in the U.S
that are doing this right now it's going
to be ketamine ketamine assisted
Psychotherapy because that's the only
thing that's legal so we're just you
know the the vision really is to build
the the largest platform in the world to
to connect all you know all the
stakeholders and eventually
um we will be collecting data on all
these individuals and we will be going
to the insurers and making sure at the
end of the day that they pay for these
because right now not everybody can pay
six thousand dollars to go outside the
US and do it right now it's like the top
one percent can do that or if you're a
non profit you know and you raise money
for this you know then an individual can
go but again we're supporting 200 people
a year how do you support 20 million
insurance is going to have to pay for
that so the idea with to our mind is
um we collect we we connect all the
stakeholders and psychedelic medicine
um and then eventually we go to the
insurers and show them the data and say
hey this is working you need to offer
this up now as a benefit and pay for
these individuals and subsidize these
treatments so
Tara is the um
is uh one of the
highest uh the most uh I guess you want
to call it
um important deities in Buddhist and
Hindu traditions and uh it's a goddess
of uh you know of empathy and bringing
people to the light uh and those in
suffering to bring them to Deliverance
so it's kind of a
kind of a I thought a cool name uh
especially where kind of we came from
and where we're going and what it's
doing to people so and the URL was
available and the URL was available for
I think twelve dollars actually
oh well it sounds like like uh
we're kind of up to date then right this
thing is launching in a couple days we
talked about vet
solutionsvetsolutions.org
um you're on social media you're you're
on you're at Marcus you're at Marcus
Capone
um
then you guys have am I right Marcus
underscore Amber underscore Capone
what's the deal with that I started that
Instagram page oh listen we bounced like
low the social media so we're really not
on it that much but um we definitely
have help with our social media accounts
because we want to make sure that we're
providing information to others that are
interested psychedelic therapies are
poised to be the next major breakthrough
in mental health care so you know ssris
were the last major breakthrough in
mental health care 35 years ago yeah and
they're really you know cssri for some
they work but you know there is that
that warning label on the side of SSRI
prescriptions that says this may trigger
like an uptake up increase in suicidal
ideations well why are we fighting
better in suicide with anything linked
to Suicide like that's so asinine to me
so as veterans continue to drive this
forward in the United States I certainly
feel like psychedelics are poised to
come on on the scene a lot faster than
maybe something initially anticipated
yeah especially with some of the
conservative
um you know lawmakers that are coming
out now for sure you know Dan you know
put a you know put through an amendment
to provide funding not for veterans but
actually and this was I think a complete
surprise for everybody for active duty
so he thinks active duty should have
access to this if they need it
um and of course you know Governor Rick
Perry who's been in our corner from day
one
um you know he helped us pass the bill
in Texas and uh he's just been a strong
component or proponent of what we're
doing again because it's a tool that
works yeah you know that's all he cares
about that's uh it's really good to see
the Open Mind of people realizing that
this thing and that's the same thing
I've seen uh you know I've had some good
friends who had Dakota Meyer come on
here and like he actually he I think I
think I talked about this on the podcast
but you know he asked me like hey do you
think I should do this I'm like dude I
have no idea so I called like uh Joe
Rogan and Tim Ferriss and I was like hey
you know like what do you guys think
they're like two thumbs up they actually
know they both were like
were thoughtful about it and Joe had had
uh Dakota on the podcast and he was like
he he was like yeah I think I like I
think it would be good for him and I was
like cool and I I said hey man I'm in no
position to recommend the stuff but
here's what I got from my friends that
know more about the stuff and you know
Tim Ferriss is is really involved in you
know the Johns Hopkins stuff that's
going on so I feel like at least I you
know I'm never a person that claims to
know anything I don't know I mean I I
don't ever want to do that but I've
talked to people that you know gave the
best recommendation from their
perspective which and and he went down
there and he did it and he said it was
awesome man and it really helped him out
a lot and and I mean that guy's been
through the freaking ringer you know
just been through the ringer as you know
losing his freaking team and
um man and he came back in a much better
spot so uh when I see things like that
and then you have like a real
conservative like you know Rick Perry
just like on board
that's just really cool to see and and
Dan's obviously you know he's got
friends that have done it and and for
you know he's he's
taking it forward so yeah I think it's
true leadership you know that's what I
say because again I don't think I'm sure
this they were exactly like I was like
this doesn't sound right this is crazy
and then you do some research you talk
you really you talk to friends and then
you have like loved ones that you see
have gotten better
um it's the only decision to make but
again to do it the right way and I know
I'm glad that you talk to people like
Tim you know and Joe Rogan and I'm glad
they didn't just say oh yeah go ahead
and do it like they were like let's you
know and we've seen that with some of
the Retreats because again we uh we
write grants for individuals seeking out
these treatments so we talked to a lot
of vetted Retreats and some
some have actually questioned like wait
a minute it's a combat veteran
um we're not we're not so sure that we
want to take that person because you
know they got PTSD and we're not sure if
they're going to flip out and so you
know we're we're dealing with
individuals that are like you know worst
of the worst in terms of
um in terms of like trauma and and some
other things a lot of these other places
are just used to dealing with some
people are coming in with I got some
depression or you know I have a little
anxiety I want to deal with so this
should be definitely
um looked at and approached carefully I
got asked a question the other day about
basically a guy was like Hey you know
I'm hanging out with these friends and
uh they're drinking a lot and I'm not
really drinking they're smoking pot and
you know I'm not really smoking pot or
when I do I kind of like waste the
weekend or waste the night like what do
you think uh you know how can I drink
less and you know is it cool to drink
sometimes and blah blah blah right and I
started kind of answering the question
and I was
I just sort of said I
I have seen enough people's lives ruined
from drugs and alcohol that I actually
at this juncture in my life I can't even
say like hey dude it's okay you know
have a I I just can't do it I can't do
it anymore I just I've seen too many
people's lives destroyed from drugs and
alcohol
and so when when I talk about this stuff
it's coming from someone that like is as
far I don't think I could be anymore
well I guess I could be a little bit
more I I just think that drugs and
alcohol are so bad for you and I've seen
them ruin so many people's lives I've
seen them ruin freaking T how many Team
guys have you seen just like trash their
lives with just alcohol yeah you can't
count it's it's ridiculous and so I
can't get behind it at all and
and yet at the same time I've had plenty
of friends that have gone they've done
this and what I like about what you guys
are talking about it's a hardcore
screening
it's not like oh you feel a little bad
okay let's just jump right into this
it's like hey let's try some other
protocols along the way and make sure
that this is what you really need and
then I don't know if I want to use the
term Last Resort because I don't know if
you consider you guys considered it a
last resort but to me it's like okay
I've tried this I've tried that I've
tried something else it's been too much
time
and I'm at a rock bottom and I need help
and this seems like okay I need to get
in there
um
yeah because because from my perspective
I've seen drugs and alcohol ruin so many
people's lives that I just I just can't
get behind it but you know here you have
something that people aren't getting
like addicted to it it's not you know
it's not like the seven or whatever you
said nine freaking prescription drugs
prescription drugs triggering addictions
yeah
um so
appreciate appreciate that side of it
and not just throwing this at people
just like you know no one should be
thrown into situations like this um you
got to go through the proper screening
and and then go in the proper facility
uh you know you guys are talking about
like you know Fred the shaman from
Wisconsin or whatever you know whatever
this like just going into random places
and doing it or at a Slayer concert it's
not what we're talking about at all
um and like I said it seems to have
helped I know it's helped I know it's
helped I mean obviously I'm sitting here
in front of you and it helped you get
back from the brink and I've got plenty
of other friends that have done the same
thing so
um awesome to see this kind of progress
probably a good place to wrap it up
Amber you got anything else no I would
just say um thank you for having us
thank you for having an open mind I know
it's you know it's very nerve-wracking
to public I'm scared of it by the way
I'm sorry I'm scared like I I don't want
to do anything to my brain I don't want
to like I'm scared of it I'm scared of
uh maybe it's like that weird like
control thing where I don't wanna but
like I'm scared what I'm scared of is
like I don't want to mess anything up I
don't want to I don't wanna like I feel
for lack of a better word bro I feel
fine you know so I feel fine so I'm
always like oh man I don't I wouldn't
want to do that because it makes me
scared uh to mess something up but
that's because I feel pretty I feel
pretty good right now so I think that um
my fear of it is a healthy fear yeah and
uh I think that's good though like I
think when you approach you know
anything with that could be risky like
you should approach it with some fear or
respect I guess you want to say it yeah
you know I mean it's like the first time
when we were playing with you know demo
and some other stuff or you're like ah
you know I've been throwing 100 grenades
you know or a thousand grenades like
nothing could happen but like actually
something really can happen but you
approach it with respect and you you
take care and you make sure you you tape
them correctly and you know you you know
you don't pull the you know drop this
you know drop the grenade throw the
spoon or whatever
um you know same same thing with these
medicines you know approach them with
care only do with me if you need to if
you feel fine and you're good like
why yeah
um
you haven't either no and I don't feel
called to do it I feel like whenever you
know you you know and um I will say that
I've seen it I've seen these medicines
change the lives like not just help but
literally change the lives be them be a
the difference between life and death
for countless
operators and um for a lot of spouses as
well and there's a lot of trauma to heal
I used to catch Marcus looking out the
window with like this thousand yard
stare and I would say like please help
me understand what's going on in your
head what are you thinking about right
now and he would say how much better off
you would be without me here
how much easier your your life would be
in the kids lives would be without me
here and so I feel like any time you
walk up to that line you have to have an
open mind of like whatever works I have
totally changed the way I think about
what I have been told is a drug
versus a plant like
my faith is so important to me and I
feel like God has given us everything
that we need on earth a lot of these
medicines most of them originate from
plants so I had to really like check
myself and I have thought that something
made by man in a laboratory that's
prescribed by a doctor in a lab coat is
what is the cure
and a plant is a drug and I've almost
like flip up that and I I feel like so
many of these answers are found in
nature and found within us and so I've
just seen replicated time after time
again that you give someone this
opportunity with something that's
god-given
and totally unadultered and you create
this reset and connection and like oh
they're good they're good as opposed to
like putting a Band-Aid out of a
Band-Aid after banding the US government
is big pharma's number one customer and
so you know getting people off of that
cycle this Carousel of pharmaceuticals
is this unintended byproduct of what
we're doing but man we are seeing guys
and gals really start to live again all
right yeah I didn't mention that Jacob
so I was on those all those
antidepressants and whatever uh through
November 11 2017 when it went down for
treatment I haven't touched a
prescription since not anything
so it's it's pretty remarkable and again
my story is like one of hundreds I'm not
you know I'm not the only one
which is nice good to get rid of all
those
nasties the only other thing that I want
to add really quickly is another
unintended
byproduct of our work is that we've seen
this incredible reunification
um
just this is a topic that everyone can
generally agree upon is veteran health
care and so we're seeing both sides of
the aisle like actually come together
actually want to work together
actually
like one another again and so I I hope
that that Ripple out effect continues
across our nation I feel like we need
healing now more than ever and um
it's pretty surreal it's happening
it's an honor
Marcus any closing thoughts
foreign
just you know
first off thank you for having us on
here I know this was a different topic
for you
um and again trust me this was nothing I
ever intended out to even think about
getting involved in
um but I just I see the power in it
um
you know and two
approach these medicines carefully uh
they're not to be used at the Slayer
concert I think the way we're going
about it is the right way I think the
way that these are going to be
introduced
to the public is going to be done
correctly I think it's going to be a
really medically driven industry at
least first you know if it goes other
routes
um you know it's not what we're here
where we're talking about and so I I you
know I uh I want to just tell people
that if they're interested you know and
they're searching make sure they do
their research make sure to find vetted
providers I've been doing this for a
long time that know what they're doing
make sure they have a coach a therapist
that understands how these medicines
work and again you know it's why we
built vets it's why I'm building Tara
mind again it's to provide access and
affordability for for people and so
um last thing you know I'll say is that
there's there's hope so if you're you
know if you're out there and you're
thinking that uh there's there's nothing
ahead of you there's there's no purpose
you know why are you here I promise that
that is a
um that's a temporary thought and 100
you can climb out of that and once you
do you'll see how cool life can be and
to get back to your old self or maybe
invent a new better better person we are
living our best life and we really are
and it is such an incredible blessing i
pepper punch myself every day that this
is actually happening Marcus way says I
have to get in the final word which is
there's some accuracy to that that's
work less work when something else that
I just thought of when you said that is
that you know part of what we're doing
to reverse these stigmas
especially around asking for help is
adopting more of a mindset that really
really true strength is vulnerability I
think that our society would say the
opposite but it takes a lot of courage
to be vulnerable and um we're seeing
that day in and day out events yeah if
something I'm gonna get the last word
yeah some of the things we like coming
up here and talking about like all this
[__] that's gone on and and think we
enjoy this Spotlight is [__] crazy
um because we don't at all but uh we
definitely feel it's necessary so like
now I don't even think it's about us I
think it's just like this needs to be
done
well I mean um thank you thank you for
both of you stepping into the spotlight
and I know it's a a bright Spotlight and
I know it's a a burning Spotlight in
many cases you know when you talk about
being at Chad's funeral and and just
knowing that
you had to do something and you you had
at least an answer for a lot of people
so thank you so much for for joining us
um
thanks for thanks for your service
um and yeah Marcus thanks for your
service and the teams and and for
signing the dotted line and risking life
and limb and you know Amber I don't get
the chance my wife has always said like
she's my wife has zero percent chance of
coming on this podcast she doesn't like
to talk to anybody she doesn't
um but uh for you for all the wives for
all the spouses that
you know you didn't put your name on
that line but you put your name on that
dotted line and what the wives and
spouses and families and your kids
what they go through is
is so harsh and yet you you're there and
you're supported and you continue to
support and now you're supporting all
the families out there and all the
veterans so
thanks for what you have done in the
past thanks for what you're continuing
to do
as you help veterans
get out of the darkness and move toward
light and life
thanks for what you're doing thank you
thanks choco it's been awesome thank you
with that Marcus and Amber have left the
building
so
uh
pretty
Dynamic story of change and a journey
um that they've been through for sure
or do you you were sitting in the corner
you were saying you were off camera on
that one Echo Charles what do you think
good evening Echo by the way good
evening very interesting it was funny
even from the beginning I was relating a
lot because like both our birthday he's
one year older than me both her
birthday's in December so we entered
College later or we were late you know
and entered caller uh played football
um
um and even and how's this as far as the
was it you we don't know him he was
saying
about alcohol right like oh how's this
gonna affect me like how can it you know
you thought that way too yep with
alcohol I was like I'd always ask my
friends like because I didn't start
drinking until I was like 20 21. and so
I would always ask like hey like can you
tell that you're drunk or can you tell
that you're buzzing or are you just
buzzing then afterwards you remember oh
I was buzzing or you know can you tell
like what does it feel like kind of a
thing I remember relating very deeply
with that small tiny part
um also you're the one who said Andy
Stumpf might be one of the bigger wise
asses he is I'll I'll go into I could
say he's the biggest oh Dave that was
one of the stuff getting props from Echo
Charlie number one biggest why is that
yes fully
um what uh
you were talking about you think your
mind this is more of the serious one so
you know you're you were saying your
mind is like you feel okay so like
you're kind of would you say scared to
take psychedelics what if it jams you up
right
like what if he did take it and it like
made you because you know how like some
people they're so driven but because of
like something that's kind of off in
their mind I feel like that's kind of
you in real life yeah like there's
something probably significantly like
off with you but it sort of like just by
happenstance like works for you you know
how some people are like that
so what if you took psychedelics and
then like now you're like you kind of
you're kind of like more lazy right like
you don't work as hard anymore I don't
like that idea yeah I know so I've even
had people say like oh you know you
should hey man you know you should smoke
pot yeah and I'd be like well why be
like oh because kind of take your edge
off and I was like why would I want to
take my edge off I want to sharpen them
you're gonna start sending like um like
Christmas cards now and giving gifts
like oh you know like you're gonna do
all that kind of stuff that's what I
think I think you're gonna be like man
I've been I've neglected the emotional
elements of friendships of my life for
so long did you get the Christmas card I
sent you yeah
that's what I think would happen to you
that's what I think or are you gonna
like start really valuing your rest days
you know you're gonna start scheduling
like two solid rest days you're gonna
start exercising moderation in a bunch
of things because it's better for you
like all this stuff it's gonna You're
Gonna Change fundamentally I wouldn't
count on anything that you're saying but
there's a serious point of what you're
saying like it does
that that kind of makes like even just
where our joking is like a legitimate
concern I wouldn't want that yeah I
wouldn't want to be like quote more
mellow yeah and the other thing is you
got to remember is
we you know me dude I mean
it's not like I'm walking around
freaking you know like I go home play
guitar or whatever watch the sunset it's
all you know what I mean like that's
normal stuff yeah fully what was it you
ever watch Robocop too uh uh not sure so
RoboCop two he's so you know RoboCop
he's kind of like you he's hardcore it
just goes hard yeah drop your weapons or
there will be trouble yes exactly right
there so in part two they're like hey
the robocops for you know he does this
whatever he does and then they're like
hey
he's getting giving us a bad image I
think like some other company came in or
something like that and she was like um
hey let's make them like more appealing
you know more and more friendly to the
public and stuff and they write all
these directives and like it jams him up
that's gonna be you bro because they're
right but in theory they're right you
know but how did it cause problems like
he he wouldn't solve crimes anymore he'd
start saying poems and stuff and like
some dumb stuff that doesn't really
match his thing you know it's like that
you gotta watch it that kind of scene
but anyway so yes I am not
down with um messing with what I've got
going on right now and so but like I
said 10 times I think I said it 48 times
but knowing a lot of guys that have gone
through this kind of thing and it
definitely just talking to Marcus man
you know he's like I said to him on the
podcast I'm like dude it's hard to even
imagine him getting like mad or you know
throwing a coffee cup through a window
or what you know like this he's he's
chill he's mellow he's and yet he's
still doing great stuff he's not like
he's not getting after it he's still in
good shape you know he's still uh he's
got businesses going here he's 100 on on
track on a bunch of different levels so
you know and this this stuff really
helped him out so I'm down I'm down for
if if it helps people out
for sure I do think it should be like a
last resort scenario look not so close
to the edge that the edge is a threat
but you know try some other things out
make sure you you know make sure your
diet's clean make sure you're not
drinking every night and expecting
things to be good in life if you're
drinking every night you can't expect
things to be good in life yeah I'm not
saying you're gonna have a bad life but
there's a chance you are yeah so clean
up the diet get off the alcohol I can't
give any advice about the all the all
the uh prescription drugs
but you know maybe talk to your doctor
about how you could get off some I don't
know man
um he was saying downstairs and he made
a really good point where
um because some people they like you
know how you say and I I get it because
it can seem like this but some people
are most people with a problem with
drinking they can't just stop drinking
like there's just I'm not saying they
can't I'm just saying there's a lot more
to it than just oh yeah just stop
drinking you know yeah so for sure so he
was like we were downstairs talking
right after uh right after so he he said
it you can't tell someone who's in the
basement you can't tell them hey go on
just go exercise oh just go on the mat
you know that's kind of hard to do even
for a normal person
so you can't tell someone who's in the
basement just to just to do that because
that's hard he's like let's get him out
of the basement first so he's safe
they're out of the basement then we can
start introducing them to the mats to
more exercise to all this other stuff
that's going to take more work by the
way
so you love Jiu Jitsu I'm sure working
out has been a part of your life for a
very long time so it's second nature I
know but for a lot of people
especially if they're not into working
out you're saying you want them to work
out for hour a day
pretty much every day yep like that you
know working out freaking hard yeah well
the other key component of what you're
saying is I mean if you remember I I
like tried to nail down Marcus a bunch
of times
but like what did you feel and what he
felt was not like not doing anything
like not motivated to do things so
that what you're talking about the the
basement like getting someone to like I
think oh get him to work out
what does that mean that means you just
get up and you work out like to me it's
this normal thing yeah but for a lot of
people that might be a big step now
listen it could be a smaller step if you
put your mind to it you know it's going
to help you and maybe you get the
rewards for it you commit to doing it
for a certain amount of time it's like
the we were just talking to a kid in the
locker room he goes I just submitted
someone for the first time in three
years you've been training for three
years got his first submission yeah
yeah so remember that was one of the uh
one of the things I said when someone
said hey I really don't like Jiu Jitsu
how long should I train for and I was
like train until you submit this train
until you submit to someone
same thing with like working out like
work out until like there should be some
thing that you have to do like can you
do a pull-up if you can't do a pull-up
workout until you can do a pull-up yeah
if you can't you know uh
run a mile
in less than seven minutes work out
until you can run on my own list so I'm
just saying those aren't the correct
answers but I'm saying something along
those lines because there's no if you're
not feeling the short-term reward
because let's face it you and me we get
a short-term reward from working out
just because we kind of know how it's
going to feel later and we know the
long-term health benefits so even a
single workout
feels good to me because I know the
long-term benefits and I know the I know
even the short-term benefits so it feels
good yeah but if it doesn't feel good to
someone and you don't know about the
long-term rewards you don't see that
strategic thing it just wasn't fun yeah
just another thing they're gonna avoid
yeah just wasn't fun so yeah he said he
said he mentioned something too real
briefly but it there's so much to it
where he said I forget exactly the the
full context but he said um get your
heart rate up and it's like better than
most medicine yeah
I'm like man that's so true that's true
and I used to tell you about this like
remember when I was like kind of down
for drinking every day or whatever it
was like years ago and
sometimes you you enter in this funk you
know and I was still working out and
like doing everything but it's just a
fun you just have a funky day the next
day like you're dragging and sometimes
it would go all the way into your mind
where I would have these real low level
mundane feelings of what kind of what he
was talking about where it's like yeah
why bother like why do I even care about
this what Jiu Jitsu like who cares like
bro what you know that's the path that I
went down during that conversation of
like when death when you're confronted
with death
and then the world moves on and you're
like well
we're all going to end up in the same
spot anyways so really kind of what's
the point right and I think that's the
the place where you could lose
like lose the motivation to do really
anything because I'm thinking dude we're
all gonna end up in the grave anyways so
whatever and that's a horrible place to
be because you forget about all the
thing all the all the beautiful things
that are in life else doesn't know I was
listening to uh Jordan Peterson the
other day you know Jordan Peterson goes
off on the like
you know life is suffering and it's
going to be a nightmare and it's a
misery and like which I get and you know
you know it's even it's not just him
saying it's like religion is like all
the religions are like life is suffering
and the Buddha is like oh it's suffering
and and I get it I get it yeah but man
there's a lot of things in life that are
really kind of fun and cool and look
you're gonna I think the point of Jordan
Peterson
is you look you're gonna have suffering
right you're gonna have suffering that's
what's gonna happen at some point right
people are going to get sick people are
going to die things aren't gonna go
right you're gonna get fired you're
gonna your business is gonna fail like
all those things are gonna happen right
so but to just blanket say
because of that life
it's I'm gonna I'm not just gonna go
into Jordan Peterson right now I'm going
against uh uh Buddha who they say life
is suffering I'm gonna say you know what
they're suffering in life but life is
not suffering there's a lot of cool
stuff that happens a lot of funny stuff
that happens you make friends you say
some funny stuff y'all laugh you've been
sitting around laughing so hard uh that
it's just you can't even it like hurts
your stomach yeah have you ever had that
happen yes sir it's real come on man is
that suffering now no no it's not so
let's not take it to the extreme of life
is suffering they're suffering in life
and I get that and we're 100 agreement
on that
who was it I think Hemingway said
I think Hemingway said
if two people love each other there can
be no happy ending which is true right
you know what I'm saying because
someone's gonna die someone's gonna die
and at some point that other person's
gonna be sitting there crying because
they lost that person yeah all the but
that being said live a happy life you
know you take care of each other
whatever you have family you you know
you you have grandchildren hey like
maybe that is a little bit of a happy
ending you know what I'm saying yeah so
I don't know I think we're leaning a
little bit far into suffering right now
and look I get it you know I get it man
um
your heart is gonna get broken you know
and I'm not just talking about oh I'm in
a relationship I'm talking your friends
die your heart's gonna be broken it's
going to hurt yeah
but that's not everything
so uh and I think you know from what
from what Marcus is saying um you know
some of that visibility of the re the
good stuff
comes by dealing with that other stuff
and that's another thing for me
um
and I talk about this in disciplinary
freedom field manual a little bit but
I think you know I've lost friends and
I've talked about it and it straight up
giving eulogies for my guys
that like immediately as soon as they
die you're basically like writing about
what you thought about them and how you
felt about them and what they meant to
you and how awesome they were like that
is so therapeutic even though I was
doing it as my duty it also I recognized
that it was a therapeutic thing I
recognized later in life that oh like
how did I get through oh yeah I wrote
about them and when you write about them
you detach from it when you detach from
it you get to read and you get to think
and you get to Think Through It you get
to process and all those things happen
by by writing about you know your your
friend your hero this person this
individual that made this sacrifice and
it's a way of processing this stuff that
I think you know uh the term that Marcus
used was you know you gotta the only way
to get
to get over this stuff is to go through
it right and that's sort of like you do
when you write a eulogy or you write a
letter to someone that's passed or you
talk to their parents about them you
talk to their their siblings about them
like that is so
such a good way to help move through the
pain that you're going to feel and
you're going to feel pain
you're going to suffer but life is not
suffering
there's much more to it and a lot of
it's good
so yeah I heard that everyone that I
know that went through
psychedelic Journey always even like
some people some people I do isn't the
official one they'll just take some
mushrooms but they do it with intention
it's all worked for them like I know
people who quit drinking
it's weird but the two people I know who
quit drinking was real surprising too
but slowly by slowly like it came back
and then they started drinking again not
just all of a sudden they didn't just be
like okay that was fine and now I'm
drinking again it would be like
you know six months later they'll be
like I'll just have one and then it just
slowly creeps back in which actually
went in line with what he was saying
where it's like hey it's not just a
magic pill one time it's kind of like
it's kind of like a it's like a therapy
almost kind of a thing because it's like
I guess it like rewires your the way I
always saw it was like all year the way
you regarded the way you create meaning
or whatever it has to do with like all
your past experiences mixed with how
you're you know your genetics or
whatever so all your past experiences
UPS down traumas no traumas like
everything kind of creates little
meanings with every little interaction
so if those meanings that you created in
your head are all jammed up or even if
they're I don't know maybe they're
everyone's gonna have different meanings
for different things so what it does is
it goes back to those original like
meanings that you're making and it just
jumbles them all up
and kind of so you can kind of detach
from the way they were formed so it kind
of like oh so you can make your and he
made a good analogy with the snow Yeah
so it's like you can make your own
tracks be careful oh yeah the tracks you
make could be wrong oh yeah because in
because some people they'll just take it
recreationally and they'll be like oh
yeah it was just a trip and it opened my
eyes but they don't really get any
intended like positive outcome they just
oh I just wanna that's my little
brother's wife said some people just
want to take mushrooms to fry
and you don't recommend this no no one
time Jade was getting all deep in the
you know in one night and he's like yeah
you know you're taking mushrooms and do
all this stuff and she's like why you
got to try to be all intellectual about
it why can't you just admit some people
just take mushrooms to fry
but yeah that's a different thing yeah
I'm saying yeah
um all right well
if you want to support this podcast
um get some Jocko fuel get some Jocko
fuel pink Mist if you had pink Mist yet
I have how you like it it's good pink
lemonade but it's not your thing it's my
jam just like oranges my jam so it's
like good like a secondary it's like
this pink mess I taste it pink lemonade
oh yeah good but we already knew that
kind of a thing it's not like mango or
I'm like this is freaking mango let's
say look if you go you have a fruit bowl
and you might be different but this is
just me I got
a grapefruit I got orange yep and I got
a mango you're going mango huh I'll eat
the orange and I'll be like cool I'll
have a grapefruit or pink lemonade or
whatever lemon whatever good fine but
bro come on a mango mangoes just taste
better to me okay all the other stuff
tastes good mango all right so we got
some drinks discipline go we can get
mango I'll tell you what the new the new
Tactical tea which is like a iced tea
lemonade a lot of people and you know
what I mean by a lot of people a lot of
people are saying that that might be the
one you also got the new Dax Savage
which is ridiculous so basically
everybody so like okay so a wise man
named cake nuts once said
he's all everybody's showing up so in
your case everyone everybody he's like
you me everybody everybody
uh jockoffuel.com go get some of that
stuff get some Mulk we get the get the
ready to drink milk which is I'm telling
you what I got problems with ready drink
Bowl because I'm drinking it way it's
way too easy too easy it's too easy it's
like boom but you know what's nice it's
just like a little 30 gram protein
hitter yeah which is an unbelievably
convenient and joyous thing in life it's
just to be like you know what and it
tastes freaking good uh Pete son Keegan
because I don't like vanilla you know I
don't like vanilla right it's not my
it's not my jam because you like this
it's real vanilla
but so I was drinking bananas drinking
chocolate
and that camp Pizza on Keegan he's like
it tastes like melted vanilla ice cream
and I kind of didn't believe him because
let's face it even people that don't
like vanilla melted vanilla ice cream is
hella good right you know what I'm
saying
you're 100 accurate you're correct yeah
so I said to myself there's no way this
tastes like melted vanilla ice cream
because then it would be hella good and
sure enough I cracked it open it's it
tastes like melted vanilla ice cream
it's legitimate yes it is a legitimate
tasty
treat so that's the ready to drink milk
um check that out jockoffuel.com you get
a Wawa you can get the stuff at the
Vitamin Shop vitamin shoppe's got pink
Mist in it right now
um yeah there you go jockofuel.com get
some of that also originusa.com if you
need jeans look American made stuff this
is this is the big thing all right
because there's people all over the
world that are enslaving children
to make you a pair of pants
and you should not support that you
should support America which means you
should support
originusa.com get genes get boots get
hunting gear the hotline's out yeah
um get what else do you need to get the
new washes of the Delta says yeah yeah
I'm getting the two-year I'm gonna get
the two year let me get this yeah that's
the middle one the middle one I'm
getting them all you're getting them off
yeah the thing is about the light one
yeah is if it's if it's their Sun out
that's gonna that's gonna be cool a lot
cooler you know what I'm saying because
Sun dark whatever yeah it is more summer
vibes-ish
originusa.com don't forget about geez as
well oh yeah because once you put on an
origin ghee you literally will not wear
another ghee again yeah I literally
literally donated all my other geese
yeah like just the other day actually
two weeks ago
they have no purpose in life no purpose
those old Keys uh we apologize to the
the receivers of these geese but at
least see if they can get them started
then they can become a world champion
and get you know get a good ghee yeah so
uh originusa.com get some of that that's
true also Jocko store if you want to
represent we got a new shirt out
I talked about it already but official
I'm announcing it I'm gonna send out an
email to everybody the the standard
issue discipline equals Freedom so it's
the kind where
if you don't have the standard issue are
you even really represented
I know the answers probably yes
I know I know the answer is probably a
little girl like that no I'm not sure I
don't want to do it like that but what
if a dude is just getting after in seven
different fronts and he's not got a
standard issue t-shirt you'll be like
hey you're not really representing I
know do I even have to eat right you're
right and look hey look I'm still
hypothesized for judge message people
you might not be representing yeah
or just check it out that statement
actually might piss some people off I
kind of got a little bit pissed when you
just said yeah that's why I was like
it's kind of like you know it's a
working it's a working uh what do you
call it slogan yeah okay so less
pressure
either way it's out and it's good it's
cool people have it there's multiple
versions of it depending on your your
proclivity to support various
units yes good way to put it unless it's
out there's a lot of good other cool
stuff on there also the short Locker new
shirt every month creative designs was
this what the last uh design was uh
toxic productivity toxic productivity
oh you got me on a surfboard with like a
computer in one hand book in another
hand paper's flying everywhere
goes in the wave
all right so yep you can get the
Sherlock or chocolate store.com go you
go to if you want to subscribe to this
podcast do it leave a review so Echo if
you want to leave that little review
about Echo where you're like maybe he
should just be quiet yeah if you want to
say that echo's best podcast ever was
today when he wasn't on it then you
could leave that review on there we'll
be happy about it uh Jocko
underground.com go and uh support look
we don't own this platform that you're
listening to this on unless you're on
the Underground if you're on the
Underground guess what we will be there
no matter what we're not going to get
kicked off our own platform right we
made our own playground remember that
you know you get kicked out of some Club
make our own club we got kicked out of
some Jiu Jitsu schools made our own Jiu
Jitsu school might get kicked off a
platform we got our own platform Taco
underground.com if you want to support
that go to go there sign up register
YouTube channel check that out
psychological warfare you know flip side
canvas talked about Dakota Meyer today
that's his company to hang cool stuff on
your wall bunch of books you know what
they are only cry for the living by
Holly McKay
check that book out final spin
and a bunch of other books I've written
Echelon front leadership consultancy we
solve problems through leadership we
also have an online Training Academy
extreme ownership.com you can't just go
to the gym one time and be in shape you
can't just pick up a guitar and take one
lesson and know how to play guitar you
gotta get in the game
and if you want to get better at
leadership which will make you better at
life
go to extreme ownership.com
if you want to support Marcus and Amber
and their
their charity Vet Solutions a
go-tovetsolutions.org
they are helping as many people as they
can and they need to help more so go and
check that out support if you can and if
you want to help service members active
and retired their families gold star
families check out Mark Lee's mom mama
Lee
she's got a charity organization and she
does she also helps vets she puts them
through a bunch of protocols one of the
primary protocols is the hyperbaric
chamber like like 30 and 45 day
protocols where you're on clean food
you're getting hormone treatment if you
need it you're getting vitamin treatment
if you need it your everything is paid
for that's what she's doing to help out
one of the many things she does but
that's one of the that's one of the
things that she does so if you want to
help that or you want to donate or you
want to get involved go to America's
Mighty Warriors dot org another little
trip that people can take
a little journey I guess we're not using
the word trip another Journey that
people can take and get a journey in a
hyperbaric chamber you can also take a
journey in the wilderness Heroes and
horses dot org Micah Fink up there
taking people in the wilderness where
they're gonna find and confront
themselves as well
and if you want to follow Marcus and
Amber and you want to follow vets
they are at Marcus at Marcus Capone at
Marcus underscore Amber underscore
Capone and also at veteran Solutions
and for us on Twitter on the gram on
Facebook Echoes adequate Charles I'm at
Jocko willink of course be wary be very
wary of the algorithm and uh once again
thanks to Marcus and Amber for
everything that you have done for the
country for the teams and what you're
doing now for the veteran community and
a a special
thanks today to all the families
all the families out there the husbands
and the wives the sons and the daughters
the mothers the fathers the brothers and
sisters
thanks to all you families that support
our service men and women around the
world and thank you for waiting and
worrying and supporting them through all
those sleepless nights your families
make a huge sacrifice for our nation and
we thank you for that and the same goes
to the families of our police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol Secret Service all First
Responders your family's support
what you provide as families to our
first First Responders allows them to do
their job so that we can live in safety
and everyone else out there
look life is hard
and there is suffering
and it can get dark and sometimes it
might seem like there's no way out and
it might seem that you're alone
but you're not alone
and there is a way out
and there is light and there is life out
there and it is good
but you got to hang in there
you gotta never give up
and you got to remember that you are
never out of the fight
so keep on fighting
and until next time this is Echo and
Jocko
out